Jetzt sollte es eigentlich wieder funktionieren.
Ja, jetzt haben wir auch ordentliche Bitrate.
Jetzt sieht das Ganze auch nicht mehr so abartig, pixelig aus.
Jetzt ist es besser.
Real old one eyes.
Ja, ich vermute, du bist auch etwas älter.
Nicht wundern, dass ich mich so komisch an.
Ich muss mal kurz die Vorschau checken.
Ob alles gut eigentlich ist.
Alles gut.
So, nice.
Ja, du siehst hier das Game, in dem du dein halbes Leben verbracht hast.
Ich auch.
Mach dir nichts draus.
Ich habe eindeutig zu viele.
Liko Fletchens Coach.
What?
Who cares, man?
Ich wollte hier einen Ticken leiser machen.
Alles klar.
So, dann holen wir uns eine Runde Free Level ab.
Und dann machen wir die Epic.
Also wir haben heute tatsächlich einiges vor.
Nebenbei muss ich mal in Discord gucken, ob meine Leute on kommen.
Also will ich sagen.
Ach, meine Leute, stimmt.
Das sind nicht meine, sondern die Leute, mit denen ich immer zusammen spiele.
Wir haben da so einen Discord-Channel, weil das ist wild verteilt.
Wir haben Franzosen, Italiener, Polen.
Das ist eigentlich alles dabei.
Glücklicherweise die meisten EU.
Guild Invite bräuchte ich auch mal.
Summoners Hall Explorer.
Ja, alles gut.
Ihr wisst, Dark PvE.
Braindead as fuck.
Also wer Dark PvE was anspruchsvolles machen möchte, der hat Serious Max.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Also wer Dark PvE was anspruchsvolles sucht.
Ey, wie ist das?
Ist der Game Sound so laut?
Ist das der Game Sound wirklich hier drüber?
Ja, jetzt ist es besser.
Außerdem muss ich After MSI Afterburner starten.
Okay, ich sollte nicht nach After suchen hier.
Wenn Windows automatisch Sachen.
Aus dem Internet einblendet.
Vielleicht taktisch nicht so geschickt.
Ich habe auf dem Streaming Accounts MSI Afterburner nicht installiert.
Ich kann keine FPS anzeigen.
Was sagt?
Weil ich habe zwar den übelsten NASA PC, aber Dark läuft, wenn so viel los ist, trotzdem kacke.
Das ist aber normal.
Muss man sich keine Gedanken machen.
So, ich cast mal ein bisschen Speere.
Ja.
Also die Sakazen, die ich jetzt eben nähergelegt habe, in der Mitte, ich glaube die Karte hier ist,
die Leute sind in der Mitte.
Da ist mir ohnehin nicht so gut.
Ich bin mir da schon so gut gewöhnt.
Ja, das ist hier nicht so gut.
Auch nicht so gut, weil.
Eigentlich.
Ich was ich kenne ich schon.
Ich bin da gerade beim Didn't Play.
Da bin ich so, da kann ich nicht mehr.
Ich habe immer in der Mitte.
Ich kann mich total gut umdrehen, oder es ist so zu uns, man muss sich nicht kümmern.
So, ich habe 3.
Aber ich verkaufe es mir nicht.
Schon mal.
Ich habe da nicht.
Also ich habe gar nichts.
Ich habe es mir nicht gesehen.
Also ich habe es mir nicht gemacht.
kann als PvE-Spieler, sagen wir mal nicht als PvE-Spieler,
aber sagen wir mal jemand, der PvP mag, aber auch ab und zu mal ein bisschen PvE spielen will,
da haben sie es auf Eden ganz gut gemacht, denn auf Eden gibt es tatsächlich zumindest einen,
sagen wir mal, relativ anspruchsvollen Group-Content-Dungeon
und man kann auf Eden Tor-Encounter machen, allerdings ohne Artefakte und alles,
rein für Reskins, was sehr nice ist.
Also Tor war ein Add-on für Dark von 2005, da gab es so Atlantis-Gebiete in Atlantis mit unter Wasser und sowas
und da gab es halt, das war das Add-on, wo viele Leute keinen Bock mehr auf das Spiel hatten,
weil sich das Spiel für viele dann zu sehr Richtung, ja, so modernere MMOs orientiert hat,
so mit viel PvM und...
BG ist Private, okay, und 24-7-gecrinede und sowas, da hatten viele keinen Bock drauf.
Deswegen ist Tor äußerst umstritten gewesen und auf Eden, also das ist hier dieser Reshut-Server, auf dem ich spiele,
auf Eden haben sie es wirklich sehr clever gelöst.
Auf Eden kannst du Tor-Content machen, noch nicht alles, ich glaube, die schalten in Zukunft noch ein bisschen mehr frei.
Auf Eden kannst du Tor-Content machen, bisher nur den Open-World-Tor-Content,
also du kannst die ganzen...
die ganzen, ähm, ML-Rates noch nicht machen, aber du kannst die...
Oh, oh, Laps am Start.
Alter, die Alps, ey, das sind echt PvE-Profis vor dem Herrn, man.
Der Server ist vor, wie viel?
Vor drei Minuten neu gestartet und die sind schon am Start, man.
Keck, wait, Alter.
Ja, da können wir jetzt nichts machen, ne.
Tja, jetzt wäre es gut, wenn unser BG-Leader mal eine Anzahl...
da gemacht, was... was passiert.
Also, wir... wir werden...
Wir werden wahrscheinlich verrecken jetzt, ich sag's euch...
ich sag's euch nur mal so, proaktiv schon.
Ich versuch mal durchzurushen, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert, nach rechts.
Meist... bester... bester Weg ist meistens nach rechts, nach rechts durchrushen.
Oh, fuck, ich bin dead.
Okay, dead.
Dead, gell.
Okay, wir klumpen uns hier.
Na, erst mal Effekte ausmachen.
Also, wir sind jetzt tot, die waren vor uns hier drinnen, da haben wir gelitten.
Das sind... das sind tatsächlich echte Gegner jetzt, ne.
Nur so, nebenbei.
Nebenbei erwähnt.
Aber die waren halt schon vor uns drin, ne, deswegen werden wir gerade...
gefickt.
Ich caste mal ein paar AEs drauf.
Die ersten sterben schon, nice.
Das können wir im Leben nicht gewinnen.
Hab ich schon... hab ich schon... Moment, Moment, Moment.
Train? Hab ich schon TWF?
Hab ich schon... hab ich schon TWF?
Ich hab TWF? Ah, ich hab's nicht.
Moment, TWF?
TWF?
F5?
Fuck.
Ich war zu langsam, shit.
Ich hab's noch gar nicht auf der Leiste gehabt, lol.
Okay, wir sind dead.
Unser...
Unser BG-Leader ist auch despawned, gefühlt.
War nix zu holen hier.
Das sind übrigens alles echte Spieler.
Das dürften so, na, ich denk mal so 100 Alps oder so sein.
Dead, gell.
Twitch-Maze, danke für den Sub.
Ja.
Der BG-Leader ist auch geil, jetzt flamet er die Leute.
Der hätte erst mal ne Ansage machen sollen, was passiert, wenn man Gegner trifft, ne?
Kannst nicht erwarten, dass spontan 120 Leute die gleiche Eingebung haben.
Ja.
Da ist die Leader-Diff am Start.
So, das war's.
Dann können wir das jetzt vergessen.
Dann kann ich meine Epic mit dem Rooney machen.
Und ich muss nebenbei mal ins Discord schauen.
Ob irgendwer...
Bock hat, ein bisschen RvR zu spielen.
So, mal in Discord gucken.
So.
Also, wir sind alle verreckt.
Sehr nice.
Wir haben keinen DF-Access.
Heißt im Endeffekt...
Im Endeffekt...
Wir...
Sind dead.
Okay.
Nö.
Dann disbande ich jetzt einfach und verpiss mich.
Dann mach ich jetzt mal kurz den ersten Step von meiner Epic fertig.
Mit dem Rooney.
Weil ich muss den Rooney unbedingt auf 50 kriegen.
Das geht zackig.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Ich muss den unbedingt auf 50 kriegen.
Wenn es CL-Dungeon gibt, muss ich mit.
Weil ich will gleich mit 50 CL5 und den Champion-Level starb.
Dementsprechend, weil das ist die easy...
Die einfachste Waffe, die was taugt, die man auf die Schnelle bekommen kann.
Und ich hab schon ein paar Scrolls ready.
Um...
Ich hab auch kein Boot.
Auf dem Char.
Naja.
Da müssen wir schwimmen.
Was?
Ähm.
Gut.
Der will jetzt Dragon Raid machen.
Da hab ich kein...
Oh bei.
Gehen wir Dragon Raid.
Ich könnte...
Ich...
Könnte...
Tatsächlich ein paar Skills gebrauchen noch.
Komm.
Wurscht.
Ähm.
Wir gehen Dragon Raid.
Aber mit einem anderen Char.
Wir gehen auf Shami.
Weil Shami wird immer gebraucht.
Wie ist das Level auf dem Shard?
Kommt man da gut auf Rente?
Easy.
Richtig gut gemacht.
Also ganz im Ernst.
Eden ist mit Abstand.
Also meiner persönlichen Meinung nach.
Der mit Abstand beste Dark-Server den Ziel gegeben hat.
Und das ist nicht etwa von den offiziellen Leuten, die aktuell dafür verantwortlich sind.
Sondern wir machen Train-Rate.
Schamane.
Ähm.
Weil die haben so viele sinnvolle Sachen auf Eden eingebaut.
Unter anderem.
Ich würd's dir zeigen.
Aber gerade muss ich schnell...
Muss ich mal schnell...
Porten.
Sooo.
Upland.
So.
Wer hat die BG für...
Für Dragon?
BG.
Join.
Wat?
Ah.
Wer hat das?
Wie hieß der Typ?
Igor?
Ne.
Igor.
Schauen wir mal kurz rein.
Shaman.
LFG.
So.
Wir müssen...
Alter, Instant-Invite als Shami immer.
Instant-Invite, Alter.
So, dann warten wir mal auf den TP.
Mulan, TP.
Nice.
Hast keine Arbeit mehr.
Ne.
Heute nicht.
Ich arbeite doch nur 80% Teilzeit.
Und montags hab ich immer frei.
By the way.
Ey, die Musik lautsteigt jetzt.
Ist okay.
Zu anstrengend ist.
Mulan, TP.
So, erstmal Self-Buffen.
So.
Also.
Also, ich erzähl dir jetzt mal was zu, wie man auf Eden levelt.
Alter, wo sind wir hier denn gelandet?
What the fuck?
Ach so, hier oben.
Da ist der Rest.
Da steht der Rest schon oben.
So, wir müssen jetzt eh 2-3 Minuten warten, bis gepullt wird.
Da kann ich dir auch was zu erzählen.
Also, ich buff mal.
Ich buff mal kurz meine Leute.
Wobei ist noch gar keiner da von denen.
Jax ist da.
Der stand doch da oben irgendwo rum.
Okay, jetzt kommen sie.
Alles.
Also.
Leute mit orangen Stimmen.
Ich hab einen Namen.
Nur mal so für alle, die...
Die es gar nicht wissen.
Was wahrscheinlich die meisten sind.
Leute mit orangen Namen sind in meiner Group.
Leute mit grünen Namen sind in meiner Gilde.
Und blaue Namen sind so einfach random Leute, die so rumrennen.
Guck mal hier.
Ein Herr der Ringe Fan.
So, erste Neuerung auf Eden, die extrem nice ist für alle Klassen, die buffen können.
Man kann sich Buff-Makros anlegen.
Also ohne, dass man irgendwas extra an das braucht.
So vom Game.
Funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Ich klick jetzt unseren Skull hier an zum Beispiel.
Guck, wo der Typ steht.
Da drüben steht der Rum.
Dann geh ich auf mein Buff-Makro.
Über Tanks.
Drück das.
Und ihr seht.
Ne, Moment.
Ich hab die...
Also ich hab die Effekte aus.
Deswegen sieht man nix.
Dann geh ich hier hin.
Guck.
Und ihr seht.
Ich kann den komplett buffen.
So wie das für einen Tank gehört.
Dann klick ich so einen anderen Typ an.
Tank-Buff.
Guck mir den Spirit-Master an.
Der sonst wo rumsteht.
Nächster Skull.
Tank-Buffs.
Ich zep...
Sag mal.
Wie viele Skallen haben wir in der Gruppe?
So, dann haben wir hier Spirit-Master.
Krieg Caster-Buffs.
So, und der andere Typ.
Da steht der oben rum.
Der kriegt auch Caster-Buffs.
Da ist er.
Also man kann per Makro buffen.
Das ist extrem nice.
Das geht nur in PVM-Zonen.
Oder in der jeweiligen Grenzfestung.
Aber es ist für alle Klassen, die buffen müssen, enorm praktisch.
Also normalerweise würde das so aussehen.
Wenn ich jemanden buffen muss.
Ich klick den an.
Geh auf meine Buff-Leiste.
Geschicklichkeits-Buff.
Constitution-Buff.
So.
Und das ist das.
Und das mache ich.
Achtmal pro Gruppe.
Buff-Ports sind nicht erlaubt.
Nein, du hast auch generell den zweiten Count nicht erlaubt.
Und das machst du achtmal pro Typ in der Group.
Du drehst durch.
Und jedes Mal, wenn du stirbst, musst du rebuffen.
Und früher war es sogar so, jedes Mal, wenn du geportet bist, musst du rebuffen.
Das ist auf Eden auch nicht mehr so.
Auf Eden bleiben die Buffs erhalten, wenn du portest.
Du hast quasi nach jedem Port und so immer eine halbe Minute bis Minute gebufft.
Und immer die gleichen Sachen gedrückt.
Das war super.
Das war super nervig.
Und jetzt kannst du einfach andrücken, dein Buff-Makro drücken und gut ist.
Also sehr gute Neuerung auf Eden.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die das auf Live nicht hinkriegen.
Aber es ist halt so.
Auf Live ist das Game eh nur noch komplett auf, wie nennt man das so, Live-Support.
Also auf Eden passiert mehr.
So und um deine Frage zu beantworten, real old one, wie man levelt auf Eden.
Also du kannst auf Eden auf...
Verschiedenste Arten leveln.
Ehrlich gesagt, jeder so, wie er Bock hat.
Gibt ja Leute, die machen hauptsächlich Oldschool-PVE in der Gruppe.
Dann hast du Leute, die wollen lieber Quests machen.
Dann hast du Leute, die wollen lieber PvP machen.
Du kannst auf Eden potenziell alles machen.
Was auf Eden tatsächlich im Vergleich zu Live, zumindest zu früher, Live als Dark quasi noch lief, in Europa.
Auf den Servern bist du ja meistens, hast du ja meistens in Gruppe gelevelt.
Da hast du dich, hast dich mit Leuten an einem Spot versammelt und hast für fünf Stunden am Stück irgendwelche Mobs gekloppt.
Das war enorm langweilig und super ermüdend auch.
Habe ich noch genug Platz überhaupt im Inf?
Ja.
Und super ermüdend.
So und auf Eden hast du verschiedene Sachen zur Auswahl.
Du kannst auf Eden normal leveln, so wie du das kennst.
Du kannst eine klassische Gruppe machen, Mobs bashen.
Und wenn du ein gutes Setup hast, geht das auch verhältnismäßig schnell.
Wenn du keinen Bock hast auf optimiertes Level-Setup oder keinen Bock hast auf acht Stunden Mobs kloppen.
Dann kannst du leveln mit Kill-Tasks.
Da kriegst du, da gibt es, muss ich dir zeigen, da gibt es ein Wiki auf Eden.
Ja, Wiki.
Und da siehst du die ganzen Gebiete, sagen wir Midgard zum Beispiel, je nachdem in welchem Reich du spielst.
Wo spielst du Real Old One?
Letztendlich ist es aber ziemlich egal.
Gehen wir mal Albion von aus.
Ja, viele Leute.
Wir spielen ja Alb.
Da siehst du hier die Gebiete plus in welchem Level-Range es Kill-Tasks gibt.
Und sagen wir mal, du bist jetzt Level 24 oder du bist Level 20, zwischen Level 20 und 25, Level 20 und 24.
Da siehst du, okay, du kriegst, einmal kriegst du Kill-Tasks im BG.
Hier kannst du einen Dungeon machen.
Du kannst hier in das Gebiet gehen, Kill-Tasks machen.
Hier in das Gebiet gehen, Kill-Tasks.
Kill-Tasks sind im Endeffekt, du gehst zu einem, du gehst mit, okay.
So, mit gehst du hier zum Beispiel Porze nach Gotha, machst Kill-Tasks.
Da gehst du zum NPC.
Hipp, okay.
Das ist im Prinzip überall das Gleiche.
Da gehst du zum NPC, nimmst Quests an.
Da kriegst du Quests.
Da steht dann drinnen, das sind die 0815 MMO-Quests, die man kennt.
Da kriegst du auf deiner Map, kriegst du dann rote Punkte, so wie hier.
Da siehst du markiert, wo du, wo du Mops gibst.
Da gehst du hin, killst 10 Mops.
Gehst zum nächsten Spot, killst 10 Mops.
Da gehst du zurück.
Und turnst das, turnst das in.
Ja, geiler, geiler Denklich-Satz, man.
Gibst die Quests ab und kriegst Explore.
Das ist super, um zu leveln, wenn man keinen Bock hat auf PvP-Stress.
Und wenn man trotzdem mit Group leveln will, aber jetzt keine optimierte PvM-Gruppe hat.
Also wenn du eine Gruppe hast, sagen wir mal, mit Speed und, Speed und DPS und vielleicht ein Heiler und random Leute drin.
Hunter, SBs, alles, was du sonst nicht in Gruppe haben willst.
Kannst du super mit Kill-Tasks leveln.
Geht, wenn man ein bisschen Plan hat, in welcher Reihenfolge man das macht, super schnell.
Zum Beispiel die, ähm, in Mid ist es so, die, es gibt eine super Questrunde, äh, Skona, Warnan, Sumpf.
Da kannst du drei Gebiete, oder es gibt auch eine super Questrunde hier in, äh, in SI.
Kannst du beispielsweise mit 45, kannst du, äh, Faraheim machen.
Plus Dellingrater, plus Moderna.
Kannst du drei angrenzende Zonen machen.
Und da kriegst du pro, pro Runde kriegst du so drei, drei bis vier Level.
Das dauert halt auch ein bisschen, aber du kannst halt, kannst das super machen.
Entweder solo oder eben auch mit anderen Leuten.
Sag mal, wer, welcher Depp hat denn das Viech gepult gerade?
Das ist der, das ist ja mit Abstand der schlechteste Platz, das Viech zu fighten ever.
Die Noobs fliegen den Heli, man.
Man fightet das Viech hier.
Guck mal, der, Leute, man kann den da gar nicht killen.
Guckt's euch mal an.
Die Leute spielen das Game seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren spielen die das.
Aber die Basics, die sitzen nicht, ey.
Guckt's euch an, man.
Die Noobs fliegen den Heli.
Es wird geflaggt.
Ich bin übrigens gleich dead, wenn, wenn mich das Viech hier angreift.
Die Noobs fliegen den Heli, man.
Guckt, Alter.
Ich renne jetzt raus, ich hab keinen Bock.
Haben wir, haben wir einen Heiler oder sowas?
Ach, wir haben gar keinen Heiler.
Auch sehr nice.
Pog.
Not Pog.
Guckt's, guckt's euch an, man.
Man denkt, die haben das Game noch nie gespielt.
Oh, Moment, Moment, Leute.
Ich seh grad, auf dem Char hab ich den, den Chat noch nicht komplett.
Ich glaube, ist der, ist der Chat weg?
Ja, so ist gut.
Okay.
Die Leute, man.
Nur Profis am Werk hier.
So, also.
So, um, um, um dir das weiter, um das weiter zu erklären.
So, um, um dir das weiter, um das weiter zu erklären.
So, die zwei Sachen kannst du, kannst du machen.
Zum schnell leveln.
Und dann gibt es bei Eden als drittes noch die Möglichkeit, Battleground only zu leveln.
Ach nee, Moment.
Es gibt dann noch Quests, es gibt noch Killtask-Quests in, in, im Grenzgebiet.
Die geben tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr XP und glaube ich sogar RPs.
Weil die halt im Grenzgebiet sind.
Und das Beste, meiner Meinung nach, zu leveln auf Eden, wenn man kein Problem hat.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Sekunde, mein Headset spackt.
Was ist das?
Okay, gut.
Ihr könnt mir jetzt pullen oder nicht, man?
Was ist los mit euch?
Alter.
Man hält es, man hält es.
Was machen die Leute denn da vorne, man?
Man hält es nicht für möglich, dass es Leute gibt, die das seit 20 Jahren spielen.
Und, okay.
Genau, und das Beste auf Eden zum leveln ist eigentlich Battlegrounds.
Auf Eden kannst du Battlegrounds, also ich habe das Viech jetzt einmal Damage gemacht, das reicht eigentlich.
Mehr muss ich nicht machen.
Einmal Damage und gut ist.
Beim Shami waren sie ein bisschen, hatten sie ein bisschen wenig Bock auf Animationen, die, der Gamehersteller.
Weil so gut wie alle Spells vom Shami haben die gleiche Animation.
Okay, außer die Heals, die Heals nicht.
Ich, ich vermute, das ist glaube ich, ohne Mist, das ist der, der dümmste Dragon Raid, den ich je gesehen habe.
Haha, guckt es euch an, man.
Ja, und das Beste ist tatsächlich Real Old One Battlegrounds leveln.
Da haben sie an Eden viel gemacht, also du hast Battlegrounds von 1 bis 59.
Hast du Battlegrounds? Guck mal hier, slash Battlegrounds.
Du hast von Level 1 ab.
Ganz ehrlich, die ersten, die ersten zwei Battlegrounds benutzt man eigentlich nicht, da macht man das Tutorialgebiet, dann ist man Instant Level 10.
20 Minuten bist du Level 10, dann machst du Battle Crowns und wenn du dir das hier anguckst, du kannst quasi, sobald du Level 10 bist, kannst du Battle Crowns leveln, quasi hier siehst du ja auch von welcher Level Range das ist und da haben sie sich enorm viel Mühe gegeben auf Eden, dass du wirklich sinnvoll quasi von 10 bis 50 Battle Crowns leveln kannst,
weil du kriegst nicht nur RPs in Battle Crowns, sondern du kannst in Battle Crowns ein paar Kill-Quests machen, die geben auch ganz gute XP, du kannst Captain-Quests machen, also wenn du das Keep erobert hast, für jeden Keep-Take in Battle Crowns kriegst du einen Free-Level und wenn du das Keep hast, kannst du dort beim Lord, kannst du Quests holen, Quests ist, du musst so ein paar NPCs der anderen Reiche killen und dann kannst du wieder zu ihm zurück und das einreichen,
plus jeder Kill in Battle Crowns.
Und ich glaube sogar jeder Mob, also jedes Viech, was du killst, gibt Tokens und die Tokens kannst du einreichen beim Lord oder bei NPCs, da kriegst du XP für und alle, keine Ahnung, alle 500 Tokens spawnt für jedes Reich ein Siege-Giant, der das Keep angreift, sodass du quasi keine RAM und sowas brauchst im Battle Crown, um die Türen von der Festung aufzukriegen.
Was enorm nice ist.
Also die haben das wirklich gut durchdacht.
Ach ja, übrigens, für alle, die sich fragen, wo man das spielen kann, hier, Dark Eden, funktioniert folgendermaßen, ist total simpel zu spielen, ich glaube, die haben sogar eine Anleitung mit Play Now.
Genau, du musst den offiziellen Dark-Client runterladen, einmal ausführen lassen und dann den in Launcher runterladen, installieren, Dark-Folder einstellen und auf Play drücken.
Das war's.
Also ich behaupte mal, ich behaupte mal, das kriegt jeder hin.
Habe ich doch genug.
Platz für Loot.
Hoffe mal.
Off, Hand out, let's go, ich will umloggen.
Ich, ich logge jetzt aus, gibt eh nix.
Ich logge jetzt aus, wobei ich logge nicht aus.
Ich, ich porte jetzt zurück und packe das erstmal alles in mein Vault, weil mein Inventar ist fast voll.
Okay, habe ich irgendwas gewonnen?
Nein.
Nice, wäre das gedacht.
Du musst dir aber überlegen, was du spielen willst denn mit.
Weil, also je nachdem, auf was du baust, ach guck mal, Auroch am Start.
Weil, du kennst das ja noch, wenn du damals live gespielt hast, es ist nicht alles gleichermaßen beliebt.
Und, also sie haben auf Eden auch viel gemacht an der Class-Balance.
Meiner Meinung nach zum größten Teil gut.
Ein paar Sachen sind aus meiner Sicht ein bisschen zu OP.
Aber nachdem das nicht live ist und die 500.000 Jahre brauchen, um was zu patchen,
traue ich denen bei Eden zu, das ganz gut hinzukriegen.
Also eine Sache, die meiner Meinung nach persönlich extrem OP ist, ist Warden auf Hip.
Weil du hast quasi einen vollwertigen Tank, vollwertigen Healer, also ein 95% vollwertigen Tank,
gepaart mit einem 95% vollwertigen Healer mit Shield-Spec.
Also deswegen, deswegen, also du hast die beste Rüstung, du hast, du hast, also Warden finde ich,
jetzt für BG nicht unbedingt, aber Warden generell zum Kupenbauen ist durch den Shield-Spec mega OP.
Ich weiß nicht, wird kaum diskutiert, aber ich finde, es ist eines der OP-sten Class in dem Spiel zur Zeit.
So, mein Vault ist voll.
Dragon Scales habe ich noch im Pages.
Ich muss mal mein Inventar ein bisschen aufräumen.
Pages, Glas habe ich noch ein bisschen.
Sonst noch irgendwas?
Irgendwas, Eis, okay, Eis brauchen wir, das Eis ist voll.
Switchen wir das mal, switchen wir das mal mit Eis.
Eis ist voll, sonst haben wir hier nix.
Okay, schauen wir mal im anderen Vault nach.
Disband, BG Leave, schauen wir mal kurz im anderen Vault nach.
Alter, ich habe einfach alles random in meinen Vault geklatscht, Mann.
Paukt das was?
Das können wir mal für 300 Gold oder so ins Housing stellen.
Bounty Scrolls brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Brauchen wir alles nicht, brauchen wir alles nicht.
Brauche ich bei meinem Runi, wenn ich den 50 habe.
Okay, umloggen.
Reshade ausschalten vom Relog, weil sonst crasht das Game.
Und zurück auf den Runi.
Den müssen wir jetzt nämlich 50 machen, da ich heute Abend
für sehr feuer einen 50er Runi habe.
Ich habe einen 50er Runi am Start.
Also ich habe einen Chars, ich kann das vielleicht auch nochmal kurz zeigen.
Ich habe mehr oder weniger alles, was man braucht am Start.
Ich habe, wenn ich den Runi 50 habe, habe ich jetzt was für Nice BG RVR Aescasten.
Ich habe meinen BG Heiler, also meinen 49er Heiler.
Ich habe meinen BD fürs Farmen.
Ich habe meinen Skaldel für RVR Group.
Und ich habe meinen Charmy für Füllen, wenn man gerade keinen Charmy da hat.
Also ich habe jetzt echt...
Für alle Situationen was am Start.
Was muss ich jetzt als nächstes machen?
Return, okay.
Also wir müssen...
Also ich muss heute ein paar Sachen erledigen.
Deswegen dachte ich mir, das dauert eine Weile.
Ich mache auch den Stream an, weil es lohnt sich nicht für eine Stunde oder so zu streamen.
Also ich muss...
Okay, ich muss mal ein Salvage...
Salvage Crafting Skills trainieren.
Das mache ich nicht ohne Stream, das ist langweilig.
Das ist fuck.
Ich muss mir mal den Charplaner für den Runi und den Heiler angucken.
Ob das alles so passt, wie ich mir das überlegt habe.
Ich muss mir ein Template für den Runi raussuchen.
Genug Währung habe ich.
Template für den Heiler für Level 49.
Ich muss CL5 machen.
Mit dem Runi.
Ich muss die Epic machen mit dem Runi.
Ich muss die Epic fertig machen mit dem Heiler.
Dann will ich ein bisschen RVR machen.
Gleich, wenn die Leute am Start sind.
Okay, wir machen jetzt ein bisschen PvP zur Abwechslung.
Ich muss mal kurz Discon...
Ich glaube wir machen eine Runde BG RVR.
Halbe Stunde zur Abwechslung zwischendurch.
Dann muss ich noch ein bisschen Auto-Hotkey-Skripten für meinen Heiler.
Und dann machen wir Daily PvP-Quest.
Und nehmen die ein oder anderen Currency-Rates mit, die aufploppen.
Okay.
Dann machen wir mal zur Abwechslung eine Runde PvP.
Bevor wir heute den PvE-Crime starten.
Halbe Stunde.
Kollege ist schon am Start.
Wenn die Dark-Installation durch ist, Glückwunsch.
Sie haben eine Milliarde Files runtergeladen.
Ja, ist echt so.
Aber im Vergleich zu anderen Games.
Ist das Game glaube ich auf 5 Gig groß oder so.
Ich spiele jetzt mal eine Runde Heiler.
Ich muss dazu sagen.
Ich bin nicht der allerbeste Heiler-Spieler.
Zumal ich erstens noch nicht die Skillung habe, die ich haben will.
Zweitens keine gescheiten Hotkeys und sowas.
Aber für einen Battle-Crown reicht das.
Gestern auch noch knapp 40k im BG gemacht.
So, dann porten wir mal.
Battle-Crowns.
Wo ist der Papst?
Das ist ein Charakter von meinem Kollegen.
Mit dem ich hier öfter zusammen spiele.
Heißt tatsächlich The Pope.
Wobei ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob er jetzt den Papst spielt oder was anderes.
Ist der Papst on?
Ja, The Pope ist am Start.
Okay.
So, Heiler.
Ist meiner Meinung nach.
Der anspruchsvollste Char im gesamten Game.
Du hast vielleicht noch ein paar andere, die da hinkommen.
Aber aus meiner Sicht ist Heiler der schwierigste und anspruchsvollste Char im gesamten...
Alter, wo ist der Typ denn im gesamten Game?
Das liegt daran...
Erst Sekunde...
Das Buffen.
Ich hoffe, ich werde jetzt nicht weggestellt.
Während ich zu meinem Kollegen renne.
Also hier auf der Map sieht man seine Crew-Members.
Der ist gerade am Quest-Spot.
Das Problem ist, als Heiler...
Du kannst zwar enorm viel...
Was du nicht kannst ist...
Gegner killen und Damage machen.
Also alleine bist du als Heiler komplett verloren.
Daorg ist in dem Gesichtspunkt echt noch so richtiges Oldschool-MMO.
Du hast Support-Klassen.
Ohne die kannst du nicht spielen.
Aber Support-Klassen alleine bekommen nichts auf die Reihe.
Und das... Oh nein!
Die wollen CL5 machen.
Mein Huni ist noch nicht 50.
Aber CL5 ist laufend.
Und dementsprechend...
Muss einem das liegen?
Muss einem Spaß machen?
Aber ehrlich...
Ich finde, es gibt kein MMO, wo Support-Spielen so rewarding ist wie in Daorg.
Es kann übrigens sein, dass wir jetzt direkt auf den Sack kriegen.
Weil wir sind bloß zwei Leute.
Wo ist der... Wo ist der...
Oh, da sind Mids.
Wo ist der Papst?
Der Papst ist schon am Start.
Guck mal hier.
Der Papst killt schon Leute.
Oh, oh.
Der Papst wird gebasht.
Aber der Papst kann nicht gebasht werden.
Solange ich ihn heile.
Das war jetzt...
Das war by the way ein echter Spieler.
Man hat es wahrscheinlich kaum gesehen.
So, das ist jetzt eine Neuerung von Eden.
In jedem Battleground
hast du neben Quests und Tokens...
Guck, es gibt für jeden...
Für jeden Kill gibt es Tokens.
Die kannst du einreichen.
Ich habe jetzt nicht aufgepasst.
Der Papst regelt schon.
Es gibt in jedem BG so ein Deserter Camp.
Das ist eine repeatable Quest.
Du musst 10 Deserter killen.
Und kannst es abgeben.
Dass du 10 gekillt hast.
Dafür kriegst du...
Dafür kriegst du RP.
Und XP.
Das heißt, wenn du dominierst im BG
kannst du und schnell durch den BG willst
kannst du im Endeffekt
einfach chain
für 45 Minuten
einen Deserter machen und du bist
aus dem BG rausgelevelt.
Also das ist...
Captain-Quests und Deserter-Quests
ist mit Abstand das Schnellste, was es gibt.
Oh, das sind Mids.
Ich muss mal kurz meinen...
So, dass man den Chat nicht sieht.
Chatge...
Okay, gut. Passt.
Ah, wo ist der Papst hin?
Ich habe den Papst...
Alter, es hat geleckt as fuck.
Ich habe den Papst verloren.
Was, der Papst?
So, das hier ist ein Battleground.
Sprich, das ist von Level...
sieht man hier von Level 45 bis Level 49
quasi so ein Übungspvp-Gebiet
könnte man das Ganze nennen.
Das ist quasi nicht das große PvP-Gebiet
was man hier sieht.
Sondern das ist ein relativ hier
überschaubares
Ein-Map-PvP-Gebiet.
Und...
Das ist aber relativ beliebt
das 49er BG.
Da spielen viele zur Entspannung
die gerade keinen Bock auf großes PvP haben.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
ich mache mir mal einen
49er Heiler.
Weil mit einem ordentlichen Heiler
steht und fällt halt
in der Regel so eine RVR-Gruppe
oder so eine PvP-Gruppe.
Wenn ihr wollt, kann ich euch mal später
ein bisschen was zu Dark-Gruppen-Setups erzählen.
Also...
Aktuell ist es so,
wir haben nur zwei Leute in der Gruppe.
Gegner sind nicht zu sehen.
Der Papst ist
Spiritmaster
und ich bin Heiler.
Was ein ziemlich gutes Duo ist für den BG.
Damit kann man durchaus auch
zu zweit, naja vielleicht nicht
die ganze Gruppe killen, aber man kann durchaus zu zweit
drei, vier, fünf Leute killen.
Wenn man sie gut erwischt.
Und jetzt vielleicht mal...
Ne, in Dauer kannst du keine Untoten heilen.
Das wäre eine coole Mechanik.
Das wäre cool.
Da könntest du als Heiler vielleicht ein bisschen was killen. Ne.
Ne, das geht nicht.
Zumal man sagen muss, Heiler ist glaube ich so ziemlich
die dümmste Klassenbezeichnung,
die es in dem Spiel gibt.
Weil...
Die Sache ist halt die, der Heiler kann heilen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber...
Der Heiler ist auch Primär-Heiler in Mid.
Ja, aber...
Das meiste, was du machst, ist meistens gar nicht heilen.
Das meiste, was du als Heilen machst,
oder je nachdem, was du für einen Heiler spielst,
ist eigentlich
dafür sorgen, dass die Gegner
keinen Damage machen können.
Also eigentlich bist du als Heiler mehr dafür da,
dafür zu sorgen, dass die
Gruppe keinen Damage bekommt.
Da musst du auch nicht heilen.
Wisst ihr so.
Also...
Und der Grund...
Der Grund, warum Heiler,
der meiner Meinung nach
Char ist mit dem...
Also im gesamten Game mit dem...
Wie sagt man heutzutage so schön?
Mit dem höchsten Skill-Sealing.
Der Papst ist in seiner
Kirche, guckt.
Das liegt daran,
wenn man sich mal hier anguckt, allein schon, was man für
30 Milliarden Spells hat.
Man hat vielleicht insgesamt nicht die
Menge an Spells,
aber beim Heiler ist es so, dass man alle Spells
braucht.
Nicht wie bei anderen Klassen, wo du 90%
quasi einfach weglassen
kannst. Der Papst,
auf geht's.
Genau. Und was Heiler so anspruchsvoll
macht ist, du bist halt
hauptsächlich dafür da,
die Gegner daran zu hindern, eben was
machen zu können. Und du bist
die beste CC-Klasse im gesamten Game.
Meiner, meiner Ansicht nach. Wobei ich...
Wobei, ehrlich gesagt,
ich würde sagen, gleich auf...
Gleich auf mit Hexe und eventu...
Bade kann man sich drüber streiten,
aber du bist auf jeden Fall
die vielseitigste
CC-Klasse im
gesamten Spiel. Also du hast,
nur mal so zur Erklärung,
du hast nen Stun
als Heiler, sowohl als Single-Task,
als auch als AE-Target.
Stun bedeutet in Dark...
CC, der geht relativ
kurz. Stun bedeutet in Dark,
du kannst
nichts mehr machen, wenn du ihn abbekommst.
Und er wird nicht gebrochen durch Damage.
Also da hier zum Beispiel ist ein Mid,
den kann ich jetzt nicht killen.
Okay, im BG ist nix los.
Du kannst den Gegner stunnen
für, in dem Fall,
8 Sekunden, glaub ich, 10 Sekunden.
Und der Stun hält dann, je nach Resi,
so 6 Sekunden, 6
7 Sekunden. Und in den
6 Sekunden kann der
nichts machen. Du kannst den,
du kannst den vollen Damage reinklatschen,
ohne dass er sich wehren kann.
Also Stun ist so ziemlich die beste CC-Variante,
die es gibt, aber dementsprechend
auch die kürzeste.
Was der Heiler hat, was
sonst niemand im gesamten Spiel
hat, ist AE-Stun.
Du hast quasi in nem Radius
von 250 Units
kannst du Gegner stunnen
für 9 Sekunden.
Das ist super krass.
Also das ist, das ist eines der OP-sten
Spells im gesamten Game.
So, dann hast du als Heiler noch,
Alter, in dem BG sind ja nur Mids da.
Nicht einen Gegner gesehen bisher.
Außer die zwei Hips am Deserter-Spot.
Too many Mids.
Albs sind auch keine da.
Äh, sieht, sieht gerade mau aus
mit PvP, ja.
Es ist ja, es ist ja nichts da, Mann. Nichts.
Nichts, Alter.
So, ähm,
so, neben, neben Single-Stun,
damit ihr mal ein Gefühl dafür bekommt,
wie OP-Heiler und dementsprechend auch
wie kompliziert Heiler ist,
du hast nen Single-Stun,
du hast nen Area-Stun,
du hast, um noch einen oben draufzusetzen,
einen Instant-Stun, den du erst gar
nicht casten musst, wenn du noch,
oh, guck mal, da kommt ein Gegner.
Der wird jetzt, der wird jetzt gebasht. Guck mal, ich zeig
euch jetzt mal, wie OP-Stun ist. Passt mal hier auf.
Stun, und jetzt
Dead.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Der konnte nichts machen.
Der musste jetzt einfach,
der musste jetzt einfach für neun Sekunden dastehen
und konnte sich nicht wehren.
Also, ich glaube, das ist,
und das war, das war auch noch
Area. Ich hab seinen Pet und ihn gerade
gestunnt für neun Sekunden. Er hat einfach, er,
er konnte, ist einfach aus dem Game
für, für neun Sekunden, ja.
Also, massive,
massive OP-Spell.
Und nicht nur, dass du als
Trailer Single-Stun, Area-Stun
hast. Du hast Instant-Single-Stun,
Instant-Area-Stun,
je nachdem, wie lang du, wie lang du,
wie hoch du, wie hoch du skillst.
So. Das ist aber, das ist
aber noch nicht genug an CC.
Du hast ein Single-Target-Root, wo
du Gegner quasi root für,
als sie quasi am Boden festfrieren, oder da können sie sich
nicht mal bewegen. Das ist für Caster
nicht so gut. Die können ja immer noch Range,
DPS casten, aber für Tanks ist es halt
sehr gut. So, du hast ein Single-Target-Root.
Du hast nen
Sleep, ein Single-Target-Sleep,
ein Area-Sleep.
Du hast alles. Heiler hat alles
an CC, was es in diesem Spiel gibt.
Äh, Polemo spielt jetzt mit, ja.
Obermalaka
spielt jetzt, spielt jetzt mit.
Ich sag ihm mal, dass wir gerade
streamen. Jetzt ist er bestimmt,
ist er bestimmt verwirrt, äh.
So. Nächster Punkt.
So, als wär das, als wär das
noch nicht alles genug.
Als, als wär das noch nicht alles genug,
dass du als Heiler jedes CC
hast, was das Spiel zu bieten hat,
sowohl in Single, Area,
okay, außer Root, und Instant und
Instant-Area-Variante. Nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, das reicht noch nicht. Ach ja,
und diese, und die Spells musst du
auch alle zur richtigen Zeitpunkt, äh,
an der richtigen Stelle anwenden. Das heißt,
als Heiler musst du wirklich genau gucken, wo du
stehst, dass du das gescheit machst. So.
Dazu kommt noch,
neben dem, dass du alle CCs hast, die das Spiel
hat, du kannst selbst
Sleeps heilen, also wenn Gegner
Sleeps casten auf deine Leute, kannst du die heilen.
Du kannst Near-Sight
heilen.
Caster werden ganz gerne mal
ge-Near-Sight, wie das in Dark so schön heißt.
Da kriegt die, da können,
das verkürzt die Zauber-Reichweite,
ja, normalerweise hat so ein Zauber
1500, 1500 Range,
und mit Near-Sight hat er dann auf einmal
plus noch 300 Range oder sowas.
Okay.
Leute, der, der Papst,
der Papst hat euch gewunken gerade.
Er hat euch geblässt.
Ähm, was wollte ich denn jetzt
sagen? So, genau. Du kannst
Sleeps heilen, du kannst Near-Sights heilen,
was du auch regelmäßig machen musst, weil sonst bist
du ein schlechter Heiler. Du kannst
Vergiftung und Seuche heilen als Heiler.
Du kannst dafür sorgen, dass
Gegner, wenn sie Zauber casten,
vergessen, dass sie Zauber
casten und den Zauber neu casten müssen.
Das ist eigentlich eines der OP-sten Sachen
im gesamten Game. War lange Zeit
unter dem Radar der 0815
Casual-Leute, die das Spiel gespielt haben.
Das ist ein massive
Spiel.
Ähm, Pilz ist nicht in der Unterzahl.
Nein, nein, Pilz ist immer noch
super, super, super krasse
Riesen-BG. Gestern Abend wurden, wurden
die Hips bisschen weggefickt.
Anders kann mans nicht, kann mans nicht sagen.
Die haben ziemlich auf den Sack bekommen.
Aber davor den ganzen Tag
hat Pilz alles weggezerrt.
Also alles, alles beim Alten.
Ja, hiermit kannst du gegnerische Caster
vergessen lassen, was sie gerade casten
und dann müssen sie es nochmal neu zaubern.
Plus, zu dem ganzen Zeug,
was ich jetzt erklärt hab, was Heiler
so OP macht und was Heiler auch so kompliziert macht,
kann Heiler selbstverständlich
auch noch heilen. Und das musst du
neben dem ganzen CC-Kram
auch noch machen.
Und deswegen ist meiner Meinung nach Heiler
mit die anspruchsvollste
und schwierigste Klasse im Spiel.
Ich, ich hab mir extra einen Battleground-Heiler
gemacht, dass ich mich ein bisschen dran gewöhnen kann.
Es geht, also man muss sagen, wenn
man, was ist denn da am Start? Mitz, oder?
Ja, Mitz.
Also ich muss, ich muss euch sagen, es geht
eigentlich ganz gut, was BG
RVR angeht, auf Eden, in Mitz.
Weil
wir haben, oh, erschreck mich
nicht so. Wir haben, sagen wir mal,
wir haben mit Polemo, unserem
griechischen Obermalacca,
haben wir
quasi den Haupt-BG-Leader,
der quasi jeden Tag mehrere Stunden am Start
ist. Dann gibt's noch Siri, der
macht ab und zu BGs, ist auch
ganz nice. Wir haben noch die ein oder anderen
bisschen kleineren, die haben aber meistens dann nicht so die
große Spieleanzahl. Aber mit Polemo
geht's eigentlich abends ganz gut. Und du kannst dich
bei ihm halt auch drauf verlassen. Der ist halt einfach
da. Der ist halt
immer da. Stehen, wie sieht's aus?
Was macht dein Döner?
Moin.
Jetzt, kleine Besonderheit. Der Papst
hat, wie sich das gehört,
ein Relikt aufgenommen. Jetzt werden
wir auf der Map angezeigt.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hips. Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen.
Das sind keine, das sind keine
Games.
Die werden jetzt gebasht.
Du gehst, du gehst.
Alter, ich kack nur mich.
Ich hab, ich hab den nicht angeklickt
bekommen. Null, Alter. Aber ist egal.
Ist egal. Den kann ich instant C10 hier.
Das geht schon. Kein Ding.
Habt ihr's gesehen?
Habt ihr's gesehen? Ich hab mein Reli-
Ich hab das Fenster, ich hab das Fenster über
dem Instant, Alter.
Ich hab's verkackt.
Ich hab's richtig verkackt.
Hm.
So schnell kann's gehen als Highlight.
Siehste? Einmal, einmal verkackt.
Direkt, direkt gelitten.
Ich hab den Gegner nicht angeklickt
bekommen, weil ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
Räumer im Finger hab oder so.
Und...
Schon dead.
Waffen wir das Pad nochmal kurz.
So schnell kann's gehen.
Als Highlight nicht aufgepasst. Alles kaputt.
So, next.
Das Schöne an Battle Crowns ist,
es geht halt schnell, ja. Die Action
geht halt, geht halt schnell.
Ah ja, ein Problem
war auch, dass
ich hab den, ich hab den zwar
gesleept, den Typ an mir, aber
irgendjemand hat den rausgeholt.
Sonst hätte ich das überlebt.
Das nächste war, ich hab meine Instance nicht
quickbindet, dementsprechend konnte ich die
auch nicht auslösen.
Da sieht man, man muss als Highlighter einiges machen.
Ja, E-Twin.
Eigentlich wär das
E-Twin gewesen, wenn ich's nicht verkackt hätte.
Was, was findet ihr besser, Leute?
Hut?
Oder ohne Hut mit Kappe auf?
Ich, ich, ich
find Hut ja nice.
War da oben was?
Mit Hut? Ja, Hut ist stylisch, ne?
Find auch Hut nicer.
Extra nice.
Eine dumme Sache
am Battle Crown ist,
man hat so wenig...
Also ich hab richtig, richtig
schlechtes Gear, guck mal.
Ich hab so viele Nahkampfresis,
deswegen hat er mich auch so schnell gekillt.
Deswegen, ich will mit dem Heiler unbedingt die Epic machen.
Damit ich mal ein bisschen
ordentliches Gear hab, wenigstens.
Das müssen wir heute auch machen, mit dem Heiler.
Die Epic fertig. Vielleicht machen wir das
jetzt sogar gleich anschließend.
Ach guck mal, die wollen sich das Keep holen.
Mit diesen
Tokens hier, die man für jeden
Kill bekommt, kann man diesen
Siege Giant spawnen.
Und mit dem Siege Giant
kann man jetzt versuchen, das Keep anzugreifen
ohne, dass man Ram und sowas braucht.
Was ist denn da vorne? Was ist da los?
Alps? Alps?
Oh! Oh! Oh! Viel zu viele, Mann!
Viel zu viele! What the fuck!
Wobei das gar nicht so...
Moment, das sind...
Den muss ich, den muss ich CC'en.
Ich hab's... Oh, ich bin so schlecht
gerade, Mann!
Weißt du mal, wie's richtig...
Ich muss den Papst heilen.
Der Papst muss geheilt werden. Und der hier muss...
Ich...
Alter Falter, Mann!
What the fuck!
Der ist aus Range gelaufen, ey!
Siehst du, so schnell kann's gehen,
bist du direkt dead.
Sollte es dann auch...
Ich will nicht 50 werden!
Ich will nicht 50 werden, ich hab...
Ich hab XP off.
Ich hab XP off mit dem Heiler.
Oder Papst
muss weiterarbeiten.
Ach, der Papst hatte Mittagspause
und wollte ne Runde BG spielen.
Jetzt versteh ich's, okay.
Oh, das war jetzt
miese Files, Alter.
Wenn ich so oft Chars switche
und die Quickbinds und so
noch nicht drauf hab, ey.
Richtig verkackt.
Und ich hab gerade gefühlt auch echt
so übelst nen Krampf im Finger und krieg
nix angeklickt. Macht nix!
Macht nix, wir gehen jetzt zurück.
Oder mach ich jetzt
die Epic fertig?
Ich mach die Epic
mit dem Heiler fertig. Komm, wurscht.
Äh, wir sind
stehen geblieben.
Na ha, geil.
Wir machen die Epic fertig.
Weil das Ding ist, ich hab halt mega
miese Ausrüstung.
Das einzig coole, was ich habe auf dem Heiler
ist der Umhang.
Und der Umhang ist auch nicht gut, der Umhang
hat nur nen guten Skin.
Also die Stats vom Umhang sind
wirklich nicht berauschend.
Das brauch ich als Heiler nicht.
Also im Prinzip ist der Umhang kompletter Schrott.
Ich hab den Umhang nur wegen dem Skin an.
Weil er ein bisschen pro aussieht.
Ja, nice. Bisschen.
Und es ist auch ne coole
Sache, die Eden hat.
Zeig ich euch mal schnell.
Mega nice.
Passt mal auf.
Eden hat ein Skin-System.
Das Game mit Heiler
fängt erst richtig mit RR8 an.
Warum? Ich mein, mit
umso höheren RR du hast,
umso mehr
Sachen hast du noch, die du machen musst.
Gut, du hast ein paar Vorteile, ja.
RR8. Kannst vielleicht insgesamt
ein bisschen schneller casten und sowas, aber
warum? So, eine Sache,
man kann auf Eden,
das gibt's auf live nicht, so, man kann
den Umhang nehmen, kann den Umhang diesem
NPC geben, dann muss man 200 Gold
bezahlen, bekommt jetzt ein Pattern.
So, guckt, jetzt hab ich den Umhang
hier an und dieser Umhang
hier, der sieht so aus.
Der sieht kacke aus, ne?
Batterie, Perchmog, jaja das stimmt schon, du hast schon recht.
Aber ich finde gerade
vorher, vorher muss man sich ja erst
recht Mühe geben, du kannst nicht einfach mal Mock drücken
und sowas. Außerdem musst du ja irgendwie RR8
werden. Und der RR8 dauert
schon eine Weile. So, also ihr seht,
zack, hier guter Umhang, hier
schlechter Umhang, aber
der schlechte Umhang hat deutlich,
deutlich bessere Stats
als der hübsche Umhang.
Und es gibt jetzt die Möglichkeit
in Dark, Skins
auf, also
Skins von Items anzufertigen,
zum Beispiel von diesem hübschen Umhang.
Und da kostet 200 Gold,
und dann sag ich jetzt hier, Skin anwenden
und zack, sieht der gute
Umhang aus wie der gut aussehende
Umhang. Massive.
So, dann machen wir doch jetzt mal
die Epic
mit dem Heiler.
Dass ich,
ich bin, ich bin mir nicht
sicher, ob ich die Epic mit dem Heiler machen soll.
Weil, also,
das Ding ist, ich muss 50, ich muss 50
mit dem Runi werden.
Ich muss 50 mit dem Runi,
um es zu verändern.
Wir haben noch
einen Game.
Erst mal gecrashed.
Ach so, das war, weil ich Reshade noch an hab.
Ja.
Reshade
crash das Game immer, wenn man in den Login-Screen
geht. Warum?
Man weiß es nicht. Aber nur wenn man in den
Login-Screen aus dem Game reingeht.
Andersrum nicht.
So. Ich muss den Runi 50 machen,
damit ich CL5 mit kann,
Oh, wo bin ich denn hier?
Okay, wir machen jetzt schnell mit dem Huni den...
Ich gebe den Epic Step hier ab.
Danach machen wir nicht weiter.
Ich mache den Huni jetzt so schnell wie es geht, 50.
Mal gucken, wie ich das am besten mache.
Vielleicht habe ich Glück und es ist irgendein Free Level Raid oder sowas.
Ansonsten, ich mache jetzt...
Ich mache einfach sinnlos ein paar Killquests.
Den Epic Step habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Wir machen ein paar Quests.
Das geht, das geht.
Normalerweise würde ich sagen NF-Quests, aber es gibt in Haggar, gibt es eine relativ schnelle...
Relativ schnell ein paar Quests, die man machen kann.
Da sind die Mobs quasi hier um die Ecke, die man killen muss.
Und das geht relativ schnell und wahrscheinlich, wenn ich Glück habe, reicht das sogar schon für 50.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
So.
Spiele eine Runde Huni.
Heißt Main Range DPS Caster in Midgard.
Hast... Ups.
Kannst du, wenn ihr das vergleicht, ne?
Zwischen dem Heiler und zwischen dem Huni... Moin EDV Forensik.
Wenn ihr das vergleicht zwischen dem Huni und dem Heiler, die Leisten hier oben.
Ist halt ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht.
Huni brauchst du eigentlich nichts.
Als Huni brauchst du zwei Tasten.
Bolt 1, Bolt 2 und danach DD.
Und Gegner...
Tod.
Ehrlich.
Ich glaube, wir müssen 10 Stück davon killen.
Das wird jetzt ein bisschen langweilig.
Ich glaube, 10 davon.
Wenn ich Glück habe, hat irgendjemand Bock mitzumachen.
Weil ich muss den Char echt so schnell wie es geht 50 kriegen.
Wir könnten versuchen, eine Runde PvP zu machen in Katal Valley mit dem Huni.
Das Ding ist halt...
So schlecht ist es...
Ey.
So schle...
So schlecht ist mein Gear gar nicht.
Für nur random Krempel.
Blaues Mollwig-Random-Zeug, Alter.
So schlimm ist das gar nicht.
Da könnten wir sogar ein bisschen was killen.
Das Problem ist, man kann...
Also, wenn man keine gescheiten Leute hat, ist BG-RVR halt echt...
Sehr anstrengend.
Wie lange streamst du?
Bis heute Abend.
Wir killen jetzt schnell jeweils 10 Mobs hier.
Das dauert 5 Minuten.
Dann gehen wir ein bisschen BG.
Das Ding ist...
Also, der Grund, warum ich so schnell wie es geht 50 werden will, ist...
Weil...
Es gibt ein paar Quests, die kannst du erst machen, wenn du 50 bist.
Wenn du 50 bist, kannst du Halls of...
Boah, frag mich nicht, wie man...
Hier, Halls...
Vielleicht ist da jemand drin.
Nee, ist keiner drin.
Halls of...
Irgendwas.
Raid machen.
Und das ist super simpel.
Du gehst...
Reinkillst ein paar Mobs und dann ist es durch.
Kannst du aber erst mit 50 machen.
Kannst du auch nicht solo machen, aber...
In Group ist das...
Also, mit BG ist das super easy.
Und danach bekommst du...
5 Champion-Level gratis.
Also, als Quest-Reward.
Und mit den 5 Champion-Level kannst du erstens ein paar neue Fähigkeiten kaufen.
Okay.
Aber du kriegst deine Waffe.
Kriegst deine Champion-Waffe.
Und das ist aus meiner Sicht die einfachste Waffe für Level 50er.
Gerade für Caster.
Die einfachste Level 50er...
Also, die beste, einfachste Level 50er-Waffe, an die man schnell rankommt.
Und CL5 ist auch Pflicht.
Insofern...
Ich müsste mir mal ein ordentliches Setup raussuchen, was man...
Mit Rooney für...
Auf 50 für ein Template...
Was die meisten Leute da spielen.
Da müsste ich mal in Discord gucken.
Dafür schon fertige Templates gibt.
Bin ich eigentlich auf Steam eingeloggt?
Ja.
In your face spielt?
Ähm...
Ja.
Weiß ich jetzt grad nicht.
Muss ich mich einloggen, um das Spellcraft-Programm zu starten?
Weil ich brauch ein ordentliches Template für meinen Rooney.
Mit Template ist in Dark gemeint.
Das ist eine ziemlich bescheuerte Bezeichnung.
Wenn man sich ein Ausrüstungsset zusammenstellt, ja?
Also, Rüstung passend zu Schmuck, Umhang und so.
Und so dieses Set, das nennt man Template.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich hab gar keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich hab gar keine Ahnung, warum man das eigentlich Template nennt.
Aber man nennt es Template.
Und...
Es macht einen enormen Unterschied, ob man einfach nur Level 50 ist und ein halbwegs brauchbares Tier hat oder ein sinniges Template.
Also der...
Man wird sich eigentlich so denken...
Mal als Beispiel.
Ich hab ja mal einen 49er Heiler.
Der Heiler ist Level 49,5.
Das ist in Dark wichtig, weil ab 40 gibt es für jedes halbe Level auch Punkte.
So, also mein Heiler ist Level 49,5.
Was meint ihr, wie groß der Power Spike ist zwischen einem Level 49,5 Heiler mit Level Gear und einem 50er Heiler mit gutem Gear?
Wie viele Preacher brauche ich da noch?
Also, was meint ihr, wie viel besser?
Wie viel besser ist ein 50er Heiler mit gutem Gear?
Versus ein 49er...
Äh, versus ein 49,5er Heiler mit Level Gear?
Gut, wahrscheinlich wird es keiner wissen.
Ich kann es euch auch nicht in Prozent so richtig sagen.
Aber ich würde mal sagen...
Wahrscheinlich so...
Nicht doppelt so gut, aber...
30, 40% besser.
Allein schon der Cast-Speed ist halt enorm.
Du castest das Gefühl doppelt so schnell.
Mit Level 50 und gescheitem Gear.
Plus noch vielleicht ein paar RRs.
Als mit 49,5.
Du hast Gear mit Geschicklichkeit, Charges drauf und Geschicklichkeit.
Warum auch immer.
Dark ist da nicht sonderlich logisch.
Wenn ihr jetzt hier zur Auswahl hättet.
Bei den Fähigkeiten-Stats.
Welches von diesen Stats hier ist zuständig für Zaubergeschwindigkeit?
Was meint ihr?
Also, nehmen wir mal zwei zur Auswahl.
Zwei zur Auswahl.
Quickness, also sagen wir mal, Schnelligkeit oder Geschicklichkeit.
Was ist wohl wichtig für Zaubergeschwindigkeit?
Die meisten Leute werden sich jetzt denken, so, ja...
Bestimmt Geschwindigkeit, also Quickness, weil heißt ja Quickness.
Ist es aber nicht.
In Dark ist Geschicklichkeit für Zaubergeschwindigkeit zuständig.
Weshalb wissen nur die Hersteller, nur die Leute, die das programmiert haben, keiner.
Keine Ahnung.
Man weiß es nicht.
Was brauche ich jetzt überhaupt noch?
Neun.
Wie viele von den Schlangen muss ich denn jetzt noch killen?
Habe ich das jetzt schon?
Warte mal, ich seh jetzt.
Es ist Geschicklichkeit, ja.
Okay, fünf.
Eins davon noch und fünf von den Schlangen.
So, was ist denn Dark?
Geschicklichkeit.
Und das geht so weit, dass es damals der Hersteller selbst nicht wusste,
beziehungsweise der Distributor in Deutschland nicht wusste.
Kollege von mir.
Er hat Ordi gespielt früher.
Das ist Giant Alp, der einzige Giant Game, der als Waffe so Stäbe verwendet.
Auf jeden Fall auch ziemlich gut.
Zumindest der hat zu Release damals in Deutschland den Hersteller gefragt,
was soll er denn für Startstats skillen bei seinem Ordi?
Und die haben ihm gesagt, ja, mach mal irgendwie Quick und Con und sowas.
Total bescheuert.
Falsch.
Komplett falsch.
Die hätten ihm eigentlich sagen müssen, 15 Decks oder sowas.
Rest such dir aus.
Also der Hersteller wusste es damals selber nicht, dass Decks für Zaubergeschwindigkeit zuständig ist.
War komplett pepega.
Also vieles in Dark ist halt, man weiß es, weil man es weiß oder man hat gelitten im Endeffekt.
So, ich hoffe, ich bin danach...
Mal gucken.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Also ich kann in dem Gebiet...
Oh!
BG RVR geht los.
Wir könnten.
Wir könnten tatsächlich...
Alter, was ist das denn?
Vormittags BG RVR.
Problem ist, heute war richtig früh.
Ich habe keinen Mana mehr.
Mana, please.
Ohne Mana kann ich das Viech nicht killen.
Dead.
Ich gehe mal kurz hinsetzen.
Oh nein.
Alle Tränke leer.
Fuck.
Ich brauche Power-Tränke.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, warum man unbedingt seinen 50er...
CL5-Stab haben will.
Macht der...
Macht der Epic?
Was?
Macht der Quests?
Macht er Quests?
Ich hoffe, der Typ macht Quests.
Dann nehme ich den mit und wir machen schnell die Quests zusammen fertig hier.
Weil Quests geben immer gleich viel XP.
Ich frage den mal, ob er die Quests macht.
Das mag ich übrigens auch an Daok, dass du einfach Coop machst mit Random-Leuten.
Okay.
Der hat keinen Bock zu antworten.
Dann nicht.
Eschen.
So, habe ich 10?
Ja, fertig.
So, und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie viel XP das Ganze gibt.
Was?
Wo ist er denn?
Er ist in DF.
Was machen die in DF?
Da mache ich ja schnell die zwei Quests fertig und dann bin ich 50.
Und wenn ich 50 bin, kann ich die Epic mit meinem Heiler weitermachen.
Das ist gut.
Nice.
Die Sache ist halt, ich habe keinen Bock, jetzt Epic mit meinem Heiler zu machen.
Deswegen müssen wir jetzt hier ein bisschen langweiliges wie Killmops machen.
Ich habe keinen Bock, umzulongen, die Epic mit meinem Heiler zu machen.
Und dann zu sehen, dass es CL5-Dungeon gibt und ich kann nicht mit, weil ich nicht 50 bin.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Müssen wir hier runter noch ein paar Viecher killen?
Ja, bei diesem Baumhaus ist noch was.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was ganz merkwürdig ist?
Ich sehe das gerade auf meinem Vorschau-Bildschirm.
Auf meinem Vorschau-Bildschirm, da wird die Lampe hier, er hält den Boden ganz ungleichmäßig.
Und das muss an der Video-Compression liegen.
Keine Ahnung.
Mahlzeit, moin.
So, das Viech müssen wir killen.
Und dann Prage 50 nach der Quest.
Okay, davon muss ich die anderen auch killen.
Habe ich vielleicht noch ein Lagerfeuer?
Noch ein Lagerfeuer?
Jawohl, ich habe ein Lagerfeuer.
Nice.
Dann geht das jetzt mit Regen auch deutlich schneller.
Das, was ich übrigens mache, wäre mit Heiler komplett undenkbar.
Ach nee, warum mussten wir jetzt resisten, Mann?
Mit Heiler könnte ich hier nichts killen.
Heiler kriegst du nichts dauern.
Nee, die brauche ich nicht, okay.
Heißt, ich brauche nur...
Moment, ich habe die andere Quest nicht angenommen.
Ich bin ein Kack-Noob.
Guck mal, der Bersi ist auch am Start.
Ich bin ein richtiger Kack-Noob.
Ich habe die anderen Quests nicht angenommen, oder?
Ja, weil normalerweise kann man die...
...die Holzfäller auch killen.
Und dann bin ich 50, wenn ich die zwei Viecher gekillt habe.
Also 10 Stück.
Und nachdem da jetzt noch ein Tank rumrennt, ist es noch einfacher.
Nee, nicht moderner.
Oh, da kommt Scheiß drauf.
Ich nehme einfach alles an und lösche dann wieder, wenn ich 50 bin.
Ja, perfekt, geh her.
Und...
Ah, der Linkrat, da brauche ich...
Ihren Wut nehmen wir auch noch an, Quests.
So, jetzt sollte ich wirklich alle haben.
Weil man kann die Quests...
...die Quests nicht unbedingt immer nur in dem Gebiet erledigen, wofür sie da sind.
Sondern manchmal spawnen Mobs auch außerhalb von so einem Gebiet.
Ähm, Moment.
Ich habe...
...bin etwas orientierungslos.
Wie hast du damals mit Fahrradfahren angefangen?
Bist du kürzere Strecken gefahren und dann immer länger?
Oder bist du schwierige Strecken gefahren?
Hä?
Naja, ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre ich super viel Fahrrad schon gefahren.
Nicht, weil mein Fahrrad ist jetzt ja kaputt.
Äh, ich bin tatsächlich...
Ich habe mit ein bisschen kleineren Strecken angefangen.
Ja, nice.
Jetzt kriegt man nämlich auch hier mehrere...
...mehrere Quest-Belohnungen für den gleichen Mob.
Ich habe mit ein bisschen kürzeren Strecken angefangen.
Aber irgendwann habe ich gesagt, komm, weißt du was?
Auf geht's.
Und...
...da bin ich auch...
Also, meine längste Strecke bisher waren, glaube ich, 58 Kilometer.
Und mit einem Berg dazwischen.
Ich glaube, der Berg ist knapp 430 oder so Meter hoch.
Habe ich auch auf Twitter gepostet.
Sieht man, glaube ich, auch.
Hier, warte mal.
Habe ich das?
Ähm...
Ups, nein.
Ey, 51 Kilometer hatte das.
Okay.
51 Kilometer.
Nach Frankfurt sind es 58 gewesen.
So viel.
Genau.
Sowas.
Und ohne Scheiß.
Das Ding ist, das kriegt man hin.
Man muss...
Wisst ihr, er muss mir nicht pissen.
Alter!
Mein Ohr.
Ähm, das muss...
Man darf es halt nicht übertreiben.
Wenn dir schon die Beine brennen nach 5 Meter, ist halt schlecht.
Und selbst wenn man sich super lahm vorkommt, irgendwie muss man es halt durchhalten.
Also besser langsam und man schafft, was man schaffen will, anstatt es total zu übertreiben.
Ich bin jetzt auch kein wirklich richtig guter Radfahrer oder so.
Alter, der macht schon Damage, ey, der Huni.
Und das, obwohl er noch Kack-Gear hat.
Ein richtiges...
Rot-Gear hat der.
Und er macht immer noch übelst Damage.
Äh, was heißt immer noch? Schon wieder übelst Damage.
Schon übelst Damage.
Und man kann ihn mit zwei Buttons spielen.
Das ist der perfekte Begecha für mich.
Oh, 5 von 5.
Nochmal Greenhand bashen.
Mal gucken, der Bersi macht das.
Wir leachen, wir leachen da jetzt einfach rein.
Guck mal, wir sind jetzt, wir sind jetzt, wir sind jetzt richtig assi.
Wir lassen den Bersi den anhauen.
Und dann casten wir einmal drauf und lassen den Bersi den Rest killen.
Und jetzt kriegen wir trotzdem Quest-Belohnung, Clay.
Weil wir einmal, einmal Damage gemacht haben an dem Viech.
Und in der Zwischenzeit können wir Mana raggen.
Ich hab übrigens auch keine Probleme, wenn der Bersi das auch macht, gell.
Also.
So.
So, Woodsman müssen wir nicht killen.
Greenhand müssen wir killen.
Und.
Drei Stück noch.
Und dann 50, Level 50 Ink.
Den bleiben.
Alter, der macht gut Damage, ey.
Okay, zwei Stück noch.
Irgendwie Greenhand.
Greenhand, ja, ein Gelber.
Gelber ist easy.
In Dark ist das übrigens so.
Falls ihr euch fragt, warum die Mobs verschiedene, verschiedene...
Farben.
Vom Namen an.
Vom Namen her haben.
Gelb bedeutet, die sind ungefähr dein Level.
Grün, äh, grün, null.
Orange bedeutet, die sind über deinem Level.
Ein bisschen über deinem Level.
Und rot bedeutet, die sind eine ganze Ecke über deinem Level.
Und lila bedeutet, die sind sehr viel über deinem Level.
Umgedreht gibt es das Ganze auch.
Blau bedeutet, die sind eine Ecke unter deinem Level.
Grün bedeutet, die sind sehr viel unter deinem Level.
Also sind noch weiter unter deinem Level.
Und grau bedeutet, die sind so weit unter deinem Level,
dass du gar nicht mehr XP dafür bekommst.
Ähm, übrigens das Falsche, was ich hier annuke gerade.
Guck mal, ob ich ein bisschen leachen kann bei dem Bersi.
Oh ne, der hat schon einen gekillt.
Fuck.
Okay.
Nice.
Sehr schlau gemacht, Max.
Du musst ja trotzdem noch einen anderen killen,
weil du den nicht gebraucht hast.
So, lass mal überlegen.
Was machen wir als nächstes?
Wenn ich 50 bin mit dem Runi, gehe ich rüber auf den Heiler.
Mach Epic mit dem Heiler.
Guck mal, ob ich einen roten kriege,
ob der nicht zu viel resistet.
Mach ich Epic mit dem Heiler.
Das geht glücklicherweise relativ schnell,
weil ich die meisten Steps schon hab.
Dann muss ich theoretisch noch die Epic mit dem Runi machen,
aber ich hoffe, dass es CL5 gibt mit dem Runi.
Ja.
So, geschafft.
So, pray get chat.
Dass ich jetzt 50 bin und nicht noch irgendwas komisches questen muss.
Es sollte eigentlich reichen, ja.
Zwei Quests für 2,5B sollte passen.
Wenn wir auf Nummer sicher gehen wollen,
können wir noch die, können wir noch die Elche da vorne killen.
Die bringen auch ein bisschen XP und haben auch eine Killquest.
So, pray get 50.
50 Blitz.
Einmal hier abgeben.
Ja, easy.
Noch 0,9.
Easy, haben wir geschafft.
Nice.
Level 50.
So, dann lasst uns mal kurz in den Skillplaner schauen.
Okay.
So, in den Characterplaner.
Runemaster Level 50.
So, AE ist es.
47, mehr als 47 in Runecarving.
Bringt nix.
Wie viel hab ich in Runecarving?
Ich glaube, ich hab bei 47 gestoppt, ja.
47 Runecarving.
Jetzt ist die große Preisfrage, was wir als zweite Skilllinie nehmen.
Eigentlich Suppression, weil Suppression ist die beste, die bessere Support.
Support ist Group-Support-Skilllinie hiervon und Utility-Casting-Skilllinie.
Aber eine Sache ist halt, dass man bekommt jetzt als Runemaster einen Kälte-Debuff,
einen 50% Kälte-Resistenzen-Debuff.
Und wenn man Darkness spec'd, bekommt man eine, nicht spec'd,
wenn man Darkness bekommt, mit Darkness bekommt man einen 180er oder 179er Kälte.
Single-Target-Damage.
Das heißt, ich geh davon aus, wenn man wirklich richtig gut Damage machen will,
ist es wahrscheinlich sehr sinnvoll zu debuffen und dann Darkness zu nuken.
Das Problem ist nur, ich hab Darkness nicht geskillt.
Und wenn man mit Darkness Damage macht, müsste ich da ein bisschen Punkte reinpacken
und dann kann ich Suppression nicht skillen.
Also geh ich mal von aus, ich skill Suppression.
Anstatt Darkness.
Heißt im Endeffekt, für einen sinnlosen...
AE, Spam, BG, Runi, 47, 47 Runecarving, 6, 6, bringt 26 eigentlich was?
Ah! Ah! Man kriegt sogar, man kriegt sogar einen Group-Play-Turn. Das ist nice.
Also, Train.
Übrigens, das ging, das ging auf Live auch nicht.
Auf Live musstest du, um zu skillen, musstest du immer so einen Trainer-NPC...
Hier, Troll-Buba.
Musstest du immer so einen Trainer-NPC suchen, der zu deiner Klasse passt, damit du trainieren kannst.
Das muss man jetzt auf Eden glücklicherweise nicht mehr.
Auf Eden kann man sagen...
Was machen die denn alle in DF?
DF ist doch zu, oder?
Check ich's nicht.
Oder ist DF für alle auf gerade?
Da steht zwar, da steht zwar Albion.
Aber...
Wenn ich mir die Keeps angucke...
Was machen...
Alter, was machen die alle in DF?
Ist DF irgendwie auf, oder?
Ist das für alle offen gerade?
Ich check's nicht.
So, zumindest kann man jetzt sagen, Slash-Train.
47, was hatten wir gesagt?
47 Rune-Carving und...
Gut, restliche Punkte in Suppression.
Also 47 passt.
Heißt im Endeffekt sowas hier.
Gut, dann werden wir unsere Level-50er-Skill-Leisten bauen.
Gab's hier noch irgendwas?
48er Nuke.
Den hab ich schon.
Gab's nix mehr dazu.
47.
Den hab ich auch schon auf der Leiste.
Easy.
War Darkness, kam nix dazu.
Rune-Carving, gab's da noch irgendwas?
48, jetzt hab ich schon.
Bolt, hab ich den?
46er Bolt.
Suppression kam aber was dazu.
Suppression gibt's ein...
Ups, das war das falsche.
Gibt's ein Schild.
Gibt's ein Schild, dass ich ein bisschen mehr aushalte.
Stärke, Debuff und sowas.
Overrated, Outdated, Debated.
Braucht keiner.
Und Nearsight hatten wir doch gerade noch bekommen.
Wir hatten doch noch einen blauen.
Nearsight gekriegt, seh ich das richtig?
Das müsste hier sein.
Ja, blauen Nearsight.
Und Group BT.
Ja, nice. Sehr schön.
Gut, Rune-50.
Dann wollen wir mal.
Ich werd mal jetzt checken, ob DF auf ist.
Mich wundert's, dass so viele Leute in DF sind, obwohl DF eigentlich Alp gehört.
Was enorm selten ist auf Eden.
Also, auf Eden haben Alps eigentlich...
NIE DF.
99% Hip, 1% mit und Alps nie.
Jetzt können wir gleich mal unsere Quests, unser Quest-Log aufräumen.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir irgendwie in DF reinkommen.
Wär auch nicht verkehrt.
Dann kann ich den Huni in DF parken.
Dann mach ich mit dem Huni DF-Quest, sobald's ab ist, falls man reinkommt.
Dann logge ich jetzt auf Heiler.
Mach mit meinem Heiler die E-Pick.
Wenn Leute on kommen, machen wir ein bisschen RvR-Zweige.
Aegel in Heiler zwischendurch und ansonsten machen wir heute Abend BG.
Ist DF...
DF ist auf? What?
Warum zum Teufel ist DF auf, aber Realm sagt mir, dass Albion Zugang hat?
Was?
Nee... Ist DF Fleet Festival oder sowas?
Hier steht doch EINDEUETIG, DARKNESS FALLS & AXIS ALBION.
Und nicht mit... Ich versteh's nicht...
Ach, es ist...
Es ist DF-Event.
Wo sieht man das?
Ich sehe hier nichts von DF-Event.
Okay, ich lösche mal alle meine alten Quests.
Vielleicht sehe ich dann wieder was.
Es ist DF-Event.
Ja dann, let's go.
Scheiß auf Epic.
Wir machen DF-Event.
Ich weiß nicht, wie DF-Event aussieht, was man dafür macht.
Mit welchem Char...
Da gehen wir mit dem Skalde hin.
Oder mit dem Shami.
Muss ich kurz umloggen.
Aber erstmal Quests.
Erstmal Quests.
Entfernen.
Das ist echt
volles Kreisel-Klein-Programm heute.
Das brauche ich, muss ich behalten.
Heiler-Epic, Runi-Epic, DF-Event.
Hast ja was zu tun.
Summoners, Hall-Explorer, Diamond-Explorer.
Ach, hier steht es doch.
Moment.
Es ist noch 24.
24.
20 Minuten DF-Event.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was da abgeht.
Aber ich logge mal kurz auf einen anderen Char,
dass ich am DF-Event teilnehmen kann.
Was auch immer im DF-Event passiert.
Ich habe absolut keinen blassen Schimmer.
Gucken wir uns das Ganze doch jetzt mal an.
Guck mal, die Franzosen sind am Start hier.
French BG.
Des LFG.
Le Lube.
Ich kann kein Wort Französisch.
Ich kenne nur die MMO.
Die MMO.
Begriffe, die die Franzosen immer um sich werfen.
Die schreiben ja auch nicht LFM, LFG.
Die schreiben immer Des LFG.
Und es gibt so einen universellen Term, wo ich auch keine Ahnung habe, wo der herkommt.
Und zwar, irgendwie schreiben alle Leute AFK-Bio, wenn sie aufs Klo müssen.
Nur die Deutschen, die Deutschen schreiben AfKlo.
So.
Ist mein Chatfenster hidden?
Ich glaube nicht, ne?
Jetzt aber.
Bio-Break.
Okay, ähm.
Wo, wo sind die Leute alle im DF?
Ich, ich laufe mit den Franzosen da jetzt runter.
Auf.
Let's, let's go.
Darkness Falls.
Ich sehe hier überhaupt nicht die DF, die DF-Events.
Ich glaube, ich glaube euch einfach mal jetzt, dass.
Okay, das geht.
Okay, das kann ich ablehnen.
Daily brauche ich jetzt nicht.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen sehe ich das DF-Event überhaupt nicht.
Wo sind die?
Ich laufe jetzt runter.
Mir egal.
Die Franzosen haben keinen Bock loszulaufen.
Also anscheinend ist DF-Event.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet, was da überhaupt abgeht.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich jetzt gefarmt, wenn ich nicht aufpasse.
Ich schaue mal.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich herausbekomme, was DF-Event meine.
Was, was DF-Event meint.
Reshade einschalten.
Ich würde, ich würde ja gerne mit den Franzosen da runtergehen.
Wie ist denn deine Meinung zu Web-Development mit C-Sharp?
Maui mag ich nicht.
Auf.
Franzosen.
Let's go.
Maui und Blazer mag ich nicht.
Also Maui mag ich null.
Blazer.
Muss ich, muss mich noch überzeugen.
Aber.
Soll ich mal faken, dass ich französisch bin, ob die mich aufnehmen in die Gruppe?
Ich schreibe jetzt einfach des LFG, weil ich weiß, dass die Franzosen immer so Gruppe suchen.
Und dann, dann tue ich so, als bin ich French.
Dann nehme ich die Franzosen vielleicht mit.
Also wie gesagt, Maui mag ich gar nicht.
Ich warte auch immer noch auf den Tag, wo ich bei Microsoft im Blog lese, dass Maui eingestellt wurde.
Es ist die Hölle.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Maui ist wirklich Schrott.
Xamarin war schon Schrott und wurde nie richtig gut gemacht.
Und Maui ist ja im Prinzip das gleiche, nur unbenannt.
Franzosen können nicht sprinten.
Wenn ich jetzt noch wüsste, wo unsere BG ist.
Das wäre halt enorm nice.
Also die mit killen auf jeden Fall schon mal in DF was.
Ich renne jetzt einfach mal mit den Franzosen weiter und gucke, ob da irgendwas sich tut.
Wo ist denn die BG aktuell?
Was die erste App wurde mit XF geschrieben.
Was ist denn XF?
Fight.
Okay, anscheinend geht richtig was ab gerade in DF.
Ich weiß bloß nicht wo.
Ach, Xamarin Forms ist XF.
Ah, verstehe.
Ich hoffe, die viben jetzt nicht, während ich gerade auf dem Weg dahin bin.
Ich hau mal mit drauf.
Bin mal nett.
Was würdest du sagen, ist ein großer Unterschied zwischen Xamarin und Maui?
Also soweit ich das gesehen habe, ist Maui ja quasi nur ein rebrandedes Xamarin.
So, ist hier die BG?
Wenn die schaffen es nicht, hier vorbeizulaufen, ohne Mobs zu pullen?
Doch, schaffen sie.
Ist hier unten was?
Es ruckelt schon ein bisschen.
Ich glaube, da unten geht was.
Da unten stehen schon Hips rum.
Okay, da unten stehen schon Gegner rum.
Das sieht aus wie ein Gegner, der Stickloss hat.
Irgendjemand, spielt jemand von euch auch auf Eden und hat eine Ahnung, was das DF Event eigentlich genau ist?
Ich bin nämlich gerade eingeloggt und habe festgestellt, es ist DF.
Guck mal da.
Oh shit.
Ich verpiss mich mal.
Okay Franzosen, let's go.
Macht ihr das mal.
Nope.
Die sterben jetzt gleich.
Keck Wade.
Und tschüss.
Oder? Sterben die?
Oh fuck, Alter, wie viele Hips.
Mon KS.
Das sind ja 3 Milliarden Hips gerade gewesen.
Wo sind denn, wo ist denn unsere BG eigentlich?
Wo ist unsere BG?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo unsere BG ist.
Oh fuck.
Okay Leute, ich glaube, ich bin, ich glaube, ich bin dead, gell.
Wenn jetzt hier ein Mob steht, bin ich, bin ich gefickt.
Wenn wir, wenn wir Glück haben, wenn wir Glück haben.
Guck mal hier.
Kann ich mich hier irgendwie verstecken oder so?
Ja.
Kann man auch kämpfen in dem Spiel?
Wenn man nicht sterben will, sollte man aber nicht gegen 40 Gegner kämpfen.
Hätte einer, ich hätte ja den, den einen fast one-shotted gerade.
Okay, ich, ich checke.
Stick, stick, stick.
Ja, ich würde ja gerne sticken, wenn ich wüsste, wo ihr seid, Alter.
Okay, hier sind bestimmt noch ein paar Hips, hm?
Muss ich aufpassen, dass ich da nicht reinlaufe.
Okay, die Hips sind da unten.
Ey, ich kann allein halt hier überhaupt nichts machen.
Die Franzosen sind geweibt, sind dead.
Ich versuche halt irgendwie zu unserer BG zu kommen.
Ja.
Ah, vielleicht, okay, vielleicht kann ich den einen oder anderen ableachen.
Lass mal kurz gucken von hinten.
Heck, wait.
Oh, ne.
Das war jetzt gerade ein echter Gegner, by the way.
Wenn ich gerade one-shotted habe.
Gucken, dass nichts von unten kommt.
Sobald Gegner kommen und ich hier Mobs am Arsch habe, bin ich eh dead.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Dass ich das Viech vielleicht halbwegs schnell kaputt kriege.
Auf Mann.
Okay, wir probieren jetzt mal was, Leute.
Wir probieren mal was.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich es überhaupt schaffe zu unserer Mit-BG.
Ich könnte versuchen, ein paar Hips zu killen, die versuchen runterzugehen in DF.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Einzige, was man noch machen könnte.
Okay, ich werde invited.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo der Dude ist.
Was ist denn da unten?
Sieht man das?
Ist das ein Ordi?
Oder was kämpft denn da?
Kennt ihr das?
Man sieht es nicht.
Man kriegt es auch nicht angeklickt.
Das ist ein Ordi.
Ja, Ordi kann ich one-on-one nicht nehmen.
Moment.
Ach, hier ist unsere BG.
Die sind gar nicht da unten.
Ich bin viel zu weit vorne.
Sag ihm das doch mal, Mann.
Ja, da kann ich jetzt nicht durch.
Aber hier ist unsere BG.
Lull, Alter.
Hier, da sind sie doch.
Euch habe ich gesucht, Jungs.
Euch habe ich gesucht.
Hallo, Jungs.
Let's go.
Ich habe auch einen BD dabei.
Das ist richtig gut zum RPs leachen.
Einmal TWF rein.
Und wenn wir den Fight gewinnen, dann gibt es Fett.
Donks.
Schau mal mit drauf.
Will mal nicht so sein.
So, also, was wir gesehen haben, ist, vorher sind die bestimmt an die 100 Hips hier runter
gerusht.
Und ich vermute mal, dass unser Ober-Malacca-BD...
Ober-Malacca-BG-Anführer versuchen wird, die jetzt zu killen.
Schauen wir mal.
Na, die Quest brauche ich nicht.
Das haben wir übrigens auch neu auf Eben, dass die BG-Anführer hier so ein Banner haben.
Schauen wir mal, wo die Hips sind.
Mal gucken, ob das was wird.
Bin gespannt.
Ich haue jetzt nicht drauf.
Ich mache mal kurz die Effekte aus.
Oh, da sind die Hips.
Da sind die Hips.
Oh, das sind richtig viele, Mann.
Das sind richtig viele.
Guck mal, wir sind...
Wir haben kaum Leute.
Haha.
Wir sind dead, Alter.
Ich glaube, wir sind richtig dead, gell.
Aber den können wir killen.
Bam.
Oder auch nicht.
Warum hauen wir denn jetzt ab?
MonkaS.
Okay, wir hauen ab.
Verstehe.
Wir wollen nicht sterben.
Der Beam ist neu, ne?
Ja.
Ich sheifle halt hier.
Oh, nein.
Da kann ich nicht rein.
Wenn ich da reingehe, bin ich direkt dead.
Wir haben keinen Heiler und nichts.
Wir können versuchen, ein bisschen Damage zu machen und uns zu verpissen.
Aber die Heiler von denen stehen um die Ecke.
Wir sind dead.
Oh, nice.
Top.
Alter sind das viele.
What the f***?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das sind einfach 30 Milliarden, Mann.
Dead.
Okay.
Das war jetzt...
BGLeaf.
Obdev...
Wir machen jetzt das, was ich die ganze Zeit machen wollte.
Ich mache jetzt Epic mit meinem Heiler.
Das hat ja so keinen Sinn.
Guck mal, das sind 30 Milliarden Mids.
Way too much.
Ich fange Epic mit Heiler.
Das hat keinen Sinn.
Ja, das DF-Event.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, was jetzt eigentlich das DF-Event ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Also was es bei dem DF-Event jetzt gibt.
Warum alle auf einmal wie verrückt nach DF rennen.
Du warst auch noch nicht?
Okay, ja dann.
Kein Plan.
Das waren so viele.
Letztendlich.
Normalerweise würde ich RVR, also gerade BG-RVR, würde ich auch nur mit Delay-Stream.
Oh, guck mal.
Markus Lanz ist am Start.
Nur mit Delay-Stream, aber in DF.
Und die waren so viel mehr.
Da ist es auch wiederum egal.
Wenn wir die beim gescheiten Boss erwischt hätten vielleicht.
Wie soll man mit der Invasion anfangen?
Oh, das wäre.
Nice.
Ja, auf Real Invasion oder Realm Invasion.
Da freue ich mich schon richtig drauf.
Und für uns sieht es gar nicht immer so schlecht aus, nachdem wir gestern endlich mal die ganzen Hips geklatscht haben.
Zumindest gestern Abend, da ich kurz in der BG war.
So, wo bin ich in meiner Epic stehen geblieben?
Zeig mal hier.
Ich muss nach Haggar.
Alles klar.
Ah, ich glaube, ich brauche nur noch zwei Steps für die Epic.
Easy.
Nice.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, in 20 Minuten, 20, 30 Minuten durch.
Sehr gut.
Excellent.
Dann wollen wir mal.
Jemand aus der Gilde am Start?
Ja.
Das haben wir.
Kann ich mal in Guild fragen, ob irgendjemand Epic machen will.
Also, wir müssen Final, was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Oh, die Skull Epic.
Gut, die kann ich als Highlighter.
Ja, definitiv.
Vielleicht kann ich die alleine machen.
Okay, das habe ich noch nie probiert, ob ich die alleine machen kann.
Potenziell kann man die als Heiler wahrscheinlich alleine machen.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Also, wenn man die als irgendeinen Char alleine machen kann, dann als Heiler.
Epic bin ich dabei.
Ab Skull.
Ja, nice.
Auf geht's.
Der Rux macht mit.
Ach so, die sind auch in TG.
Okay, dauert noch zwei Minuten.
Wir haben noch einen aus Gilde, der mitmachen will.
Skull ist doch da, wo du bei den Morvals das mitmachst.
Ja.
Das Item aufheben musst, korrekt.
Korrekt.
Ich laufe schon mal hin.
Ich laufe schon mal hin und mache TP.
Hast du Solo hingekriegt als Shami?
Als Shami Solo stelle ich es mir schwierig vor, weil die casten halt, wenn sie geroutet sind.
Als Heiler, ich glaube, Heiler ist so ziemlich der einzige Char, der das Solo machen kann.
Weil du kannst theoretisch einfach alle dort sleepen und den Skull aufheben gehen und schnell wieder abhauen.
Ich meine, als Shami ist es, als Shami würde ich sagen, ist es theoretisch.
Theoretisch möglich Solo.
Aber da brauchst du schon ein bisschen Glück, dass sie nicht so schnell spawnen und dass die an der richtigen Stelle laufen und sowas.
Äh, wohl nach moderner.
So, Endu-Trank.
Ähm, warum sehe ich meine Spells nicht?
Ah, Effekts.
Effekts, all.
Ich habe die Effekte, Zauber-Effekte ausgeschaltet.
Ja, ich muss meinen Heiler respecken.
Während ich da hinlaufe.
Und auf meinen Gilden-Member warte, dass der umlockt oder bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was der eigentlich machen will.
Müssen wir mal kurz in den Skill-Planer für Heile.
Wir sind zufällig in der gleichen Gilde, nice.
Ey, ich bin, ich bin da auch erst gestern oder so, nee, vorgestern noch irgendwie so reingejoined, weil ich mir gedacht habe, ey, na super.
Okay, das ist halt auch so ein Ding, als Heiler kannst du sogar vergessen.
Da musst du, musst du, musst du nicht ankommen.
Musst du, musst du, renn einfach weg.
Kannst eh nix killen, als Heiler.
Ja, ich bin da auch erst reingejoined, weil ich mit einem Heiler von denen öfters zusammen groope im RvR.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ey, eine deutschsprachige Gilde wäre doch mal wieder was.
Auch wenn ich eigentlich von solchen Gilden normalerweise nicht viel halte, weil, muss ich erklären, das ist eine Gilde, wo jeder inviten kann.
Und meistens läuft das nicht so gut.
Ich habe damit nicht so gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Aber die Leute machen bis jetzt echt ganz guten Eindruck.
Vor allem hat man doch immer ordentlich Leute.
Leute on.
Ich meine, wir haben, ja, wir haben, ich weiß gar nicht, wo man das sieht.
Guck mal, ich meine, das ist montags morgens.
Wir haben zwei Seiten voller Leute.
Naja, okay.
Nicht ganz zwei Seiten voller Leute.
Äh, wir haben, oh, GCU kann man machen.
Oh, laden wir den mal ein.
Und ich mache TP.
Äh, TP.
Du hast einen Season 1 Char, hast du noch nicht gelevelt?
Also, es bietet sich an, die Season 1 Chars in Season 2 weiterzuspielen, weil du behältst deine RPs.
Zwar bist du immer noch an dem Limit für RPs.
Aber wenn du in Season 1 einen RR6 Char hattest, ist der jetzt auch schon wieder, sobald du 50 bist, RR5.
Das ist eigentlich mega, mega...
Ich finde, das haben die richtig gut gemacht in Eden.
Also, ich muss sagen, aus meiner Sicht ist Eden der beste Server, den es bisher gegeben hat.
Eden macht vieles einfacher, was nervig war.
Hat aber noch genug Wiederspielwert.
Und gerade dieser...
Ja...
Oh, jetzt habe ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Ähm...
Ja, also Eden hat jede Menge Verbesserungen.
Es hat weiterhin Wiederspielwert.
Aber du hast halt immer noch den Anreiz, jede Season weiterzuspielen, weil du deinen Char weiterspielen kannst und die RPs behältst.
Mit Limit.
Dass du nicht Instant RR10s oder so hast.
So, dann wollen wir mal.
Ach, guck mal.
Da machen das zwei andere auch gerade noch.
Da machen auch noch gerade zwei andere Epic.
Warte mal, ob die...
Warte mal, ob die bei uns in Gruppe wollen.
Was ist denn das?
Valk und doppelt Valk.
Okay.
Da kann ja nicht viel schief gehen.
Okay, ich entweite die mal, die anderen.
Das ist halt auch was, was ich in Daog mag.
Daog ist halt kein anonymes Dungeon-Finder-RPG.
Oder MMO.
Das finde ich halt richtig geil.
Let's go.
Final Trial.
Wir müssen Skal machen.
Mit dem Team können wir fast...
Wenn die hohen Chills Back haben, können wir theoretisch sogar Wassram machen.
Okay, die wollen killen.
Der Step ist mega easy.
Man muss bloß aufpassen.
Wenn man mehr als drei Gegner gleichzeitig aggro, dann killen die einen.
Weil die super eklige Dots haben.
Ist der Rux 50 jetzt?
49,5 wahrscheinlich.
Wäh, dann bin ich echt expense Velouch.
Heut
Wasitschkole- thing.
Ich habe Vסrim vs Vwend, wie auch immer der heißt, ich hab den als Skalde schon gedankt.
Okay, weiter.
Auf geht's, Leute.
Lets go.
Let's go.
Auf.
Auf. Oh, der Rux hat LD. Fuck. Schlecht. Okay, let's go. Let's go. Let's go, Leute. Okay. Ey, Leute, ihr solltet mal ein paar Mobs killen, anstatt hier sinnlos die Quest abzugreifen, ne? Ich sag's ja nur. Alter. Alter. Diese, die Noobs, man. Guckt's euch an. Die sollen halt mal was killen, anstatt einfach nur sinnlos rumzustehen.
Er hat's immer gefickt. Nice. Sehr gut. Sehr schön. Nice. Tja, und die ticken, die Dots ticken nämlich bei jedem Ding und interrupten.
Oh, Gott, diese Leute immer. Ich raste aus, man. Wie scheiße kann man sein, Alter? Die hätten die Mobs einfach nur einzeln killen müssen, man. So schwer ist das doch nicht.
Oh, Gott. Alter, die sind so dumm. Die sind alles so dumm. Ich fass es nicht. Die sind alle so unfähig.
Die spielen das seit fucking 20 Jahren, man. Die stehen einfach hin und killen nix.
Ich darf nix schreiben, sonst raste ich aus, ja.
Wo ist das Problem? Reingehen, Gegner killen und dann holen sich alle diesen komischen Skull und gut ist?
Aber ihr habt's gesehen. Ich hätte es als Heiler... Wir hätten es zu zweit machen sollen. Wir hätten es zu zweit machen sollen.
Wir hätten es zu zweit machen sollen. Zu zweit hätten wir es besser geschafft als zu viert, man.
So, mal gucken. AG ist das TP.
Ey, wir hätten es echt zu zweit machen sollen. Das war wieder echt ein Musterbeispiel von... Man spielt das Spiel seit 20 Jahren, aber hat nix gecheckt, Alter.
Okay, hoffentlich stirbt Rux nicht. Rux wird PR'd.
Okay, abregen, nochmal neu. Easy.
Ey, wo ist Rux hin? Rux ist weg.
Da ist er wieder.
So, meine Quickbar ist halt auch ein bisschen verkackt.
Für PVM-Gedöns brauche ich kein Instant-CC. Machen wir mal so. Kann ich die Single metzen? Auf geht's.
Moment, auf welcher Seite sind wir überhaupt? Nee, wir sind hier schon richtig.
Auf geht's.
Sobald ihr anfangt zu dotten, jetzt hat man halt gelitten.
Einfach schön killen, der Reihe nach.
By the way, ihr seid Nahkämpfer. Ihr dürft ruhig dahin.
So, den da jetzt.
Geht doch.
Oh, next.
Auf!
Und der da jetzt.
Die müssen gar nicht so viel Schiss davor haben.
Die können einfach rein und Damage machen.
Ist halt das Ding, als Nahkämpfer musst du halt ran, um Damage zu machen.
Okay, nice. Next.
So, die hier hinten CC'en wir jetzt.
Okay, jetzt steht alles. Und jetzt killen wir alles.
Einmal initial und dann ist easy.
So, und jetzt können wir das Ding aufheben.
In Combat, in Combat, in Combat, in Combat.
Please, lass mich. Jawoll.
Ich hab's.
Okay, das darf man aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht.
Wo ist das Vieh?
Wo muss ich hin?
Hallo?
Sichtlinie, please.
Jetzt muss der Rux noch hin.
Okay, let's go.
Wir haben's.
Äh, Final Epic, Showskull, King Eric, okay.
Jetzt müssen wir zurück zum König.
Und dann geht das.
Gucken wir mal gleich, ob wir...
Oh, ne, shit.
Nix wie weg.
Die Viecher sind aus dem CC rausgekommen.
Okay, wenn wir sterben, ist nicht schlimm.
Ey, wir sterben, ist nicht schlimm.
Wir haben die Quest fertig.
So, kann sich das Viech mal...
Kann das mal abhauen, please?
Ey, wetten, die lassen...
Die lassen mich hier und lassen mich jetzt verrecken.
Nice, GG.
Beste Teammates überhaupt.
Ich verpiss mich jetzt.
Kann das...
Kann der Mob sich mal bitte verpissen jetzt?
Was ist das hier?
Äh, jetzt.
Nice.
Okay.
Ja, solche heal uns.
Und jetzt kann ich hoffentlich zurückporten.
Okay, wir müssen zum König.
Was denn?
Mach's gut.
Gooper.
Gooper-Gear.
Der Bind...
Der Beinpunkt hier ist sehr suboptimal.
Man muss immer doppelt porten.
Man portet ins Tutorial-Gebiet, portet in die Stadt, immer mit Ladescreen dazwischen,
portet in den Thronraum und dann portet man raus und portet wieder...
Das ist ja...
Das ist ja Ladezeiten des Throns.
Ich verstehe übrigens auch gar nicht, warum das Spiel so lange Ladezeiten hat.
Das ist uralt.
Also es gibt wohl einen Bug in Verbindung mit Windows Defender.
Dass man im Windows Defender Ausnahmen eintragen muss.
Und das Ganze dann schneller lädt, weil der Windows Defender wieder Probleme macht.
Aber wer hätte das gedacht, dass der Windows Defender Probleme macht?
Aber ich wollte bisher noch nicht im Windows Defender irgendwelche Ausnahmen hinzufügen,
weil...
Weil...
Theoretisch, dadurch, dass die einen eigenen Launcher haben, für den Free-Shard,
und wer weiß, wie sicher die ihre Software-Repos und sowas haben, wo alles herkommt,
und Updates gezogen wird,
nicht, dass der Launcher die Game-DLL austauscht durch irgendwas, weil irgendjemand nicht aufgepasst hat,
Zugangsdaten geleakt hat, was auch immer, und man sich irgendein Virus einfängt,
und...
Kann ja nicht...
Vorsichtig genug sein.
Okay, letzter Epic-Step.
Letzter Epic-Step, dann gibt's endlich die Rüstung.
Pog.
Also, ich bin Heiler, damit geht das schon mal easy.
Ich hab auch genug Mana.
Mit Lagerfeuer.
Das Ding ist...
Dum-dum-dum-dum...
Ah, geil, muss ich.
Das Ding ist, wir könnten...
Also, theoretisch, theoretisch kann das ne, ne Shield-Walk tanken, das Ding.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das ne Level 46er...
Mit Level-Gear-Shield-Walk tanken kann.
Also, vielleicht...
Suchen wir uns gleich noch ein paar...
Ich verweile mich.
Ich frag mal im Chat, ob jemand sucht...
Ja, Zwerge, lasst mich in Ruhe.
Ich weiß, ihr mögt mich nicht.
Oh!
Wir können danach direkt...
Das ist ja nice.
Wir können danach direkt CL5 machen.
Oh, fuck, ich renn hier mitten durch Gegner durch.
Ist ganz doof.
Ich glaub, die casten.
Was ist denn nur mit casten los?
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal zum Spot rennen, wo das Viech spawnt.
Runter müssen wir zu dem Viech.
Wer hat...
Okay, Zurg.
Dauert noch ein bisschen.
Bis die, bis die starten.
Und, ist start.
Okay, Westrom ist da.
Nice.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, fuck, ich bin dead.
Das Viech ist brutal.
Die machen übelst Damage.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe...
Okay, ich hab noch mal ein Instant am Start.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall, ich muss auf jeden Fall rennen, dass das Ding nicht mich wieder ancastet, sobald mich das...
Ich bin doch nicht dead.
Warte mal, wir müssen übrigens da runter.
Ich lauf gerade mega pepega, Alter.
Meinen Nachnamen muss ich noch umbenennen.
Pepega.
Dass jeder, jeder Bescheid weiß.
Bin ich denn jetzt überhaupt im Final Step?
Go Ian Wood, slay Wasram.
Ja.
Ian muss ich lang.
Wasram.
Wasram slayen.
Ich hoffe, ich verpass jetzt.
Ich hoffe, ich verpass.
Ich verpasse jetzt nicht, ähm, den CL5-Dungeon.
Ich versuche nämlich gerade zwei Sachen gleichzeitig zu machen.
Einmal Epic.
Ist er das hier oben?
Nee.
Ich würde gerne einmal Epic machen.
Das Viech spawnt hier irgendwo.
Einmal Epic und dann CL5.
Hier, Wasram, da ist er doch, oder?
Jawohl, hier.
So, den müssen wir killen, dann ist die Epic vorbei.
Ähm...
Aber wir können probieren, ob ich das hinkriege.
Ich hab noch ne...
Ich hab noch ein Lagerfeuer für extra.
Wir müssen uns beeilen.
Wann wollen die denn starten?
Auf, Leute, macht hin, Alter.
Wie viele?
Okay, 23 Leute haben sie für die BG schon am Start.
Das reicht nicht.
Die müssen noch mehr sammeln, deswegen...
Die Leute sollen mal hinmachen.
Die anderen disbanden nicht.
Da denkst du echt, die Leute haben noch nie das Spiel gespielt, Mann.
Wir haben es eilig.
Ich muss umlocken, Leute.
Ich muss umlocken.
Als haben die das Spiel noch nicht gespielt, Mann.
Die müssen disbanden.
Ich invite sie und gut ist, hast früher auf Dartmoor gespielt.
Bei dem Namen klingelt irgendwas.
Nein, auf live hieß ich komplett anders.
Ich glaub, PogChamp hat sich damals auch keiner genannt, oder?
So, BG counts.
23, okay.
Das andere startet nicht so wirklich.
Die kriegen es noch nicht auf die Reihe.
Äh, ich frag mal kurz.
Von meinen Leuten sind keine da.
Okay, wir kriegen vielleicht noch ein paar Leute dabei.
Ah, wir kriegen einen Warrior.
Nice, dann ist easy.
50er Warrior.
Ja, jetzt ist die Sache geritzt.
Eats.
Ah, damit packen wir das.
BG counts.
24.
Ich muss danach direkt umlocken, Leute.
Direkt.
So, die other guys.
Kann ich die...
Okay, die anderen haben es noch nicht gecheckt.
So, invite, invite.
Wie hieß der andere Typ zum Inviten?
Okay, der andere hat es sogar ausgelockt.
Keine Ahnung, die haben es wieder nicht kapiert.
Alles klar.
Let's go.
Easy.
Ich sollte mir vielleicht mal einen ordentlichen...
Heal auf die, auf die Leiste ziehen, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Mending.
Was habe ich denn da hier?
Sowas da vielleicht.
Irgendeinen Heal, wo ich nicht sofort...
Mana...
Mana los bin.
Ach, easy haben wir doch gleich geschafft.
So, 26 Leute für...
Champion Level Dungeon.
Das reicht auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ich müsste eigentlich einen relativ...
effizienten Level 33er Heal haben.
Der hier, der ist gut, glaube ich.
Der braucht nicht viel Mana.
Ja, 75%.
Eats, Eats, Eats, Eats.
Also ja, ich habe Dartmoor Midgard mal was gespielt früher.
Hieß aber ganz anders.
Ich habe hauptsächlich Stonehenge Albion gespielt.
Lay on his hip und Salisbury Midgard.
Und dann später US Classic Server Midgard.
Aber wie gesagt, ich hieß da...
Ich hieß auf live komplett anders.
Damals gab es noch keine Twitch Emotes.
Wie hieß du?
Auf Dartmoor.
Vielleicht kenne ich dich ja noch von früher.
Falls du sagen willst.
Also ich...
Ich halte mich da immer zurück mit meinen alten Everwohnern.
Nee, sagt mir nix.
Sagt mir nichts.
Okay, Viech fast tot.
49%.
BG für CL5 hat 29.
Nice.
Das ist richtig gutes Timing.
Nahkampfhunter.
Ich glaube, das kannst du...
Ich weiß nicht, ob du Eden spielst.
Ich glaube, das kann man auf Eden sogar, wenn es unbedingt sein muss.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du es spielst.
Aber am besten ist es natürlich Kombinationen.
Aber das heißt, du stehst auf Schleicher-Klassen.
Das ist ja überhaupt nicht meins.
Wenn es nach mir geht, könnten sie alle Schleicher rauspatchen aus dem Game.
Aber ich glaube, wirklich gut funzt das nicht.
Aber ich kenne mich mit Schleicher auch echt nicht aus.
Hat mich nie interessiert.
Okay.
Die wollen 55 los.
Was ein perfektes Timing, Leute.
Epic mit Heiler fertig.
Die wollen 55.
50 los für den CL5-Dungeon.
Bis dahin habe ich sogar noch die Epic abgeholt beim König mit dem Heiler.
Exzellent, exzellent.
24% das Viech.
Früher konnte man auch Solo schleichen.
Das kannst du ziemlich...
Also du kannst immer noch so, aber es ist halt enorm viel los.
Gerade an den Hotspots triffst du dann immer irgendwelche 10er-Schleicher-Gruppen und sowas.
Die treten da immer in geballter Ladung auf.
So, wir haben es geschafft.
Epic fertig.
Gibt es eine ordentliche Rüstung.
So, ist die Epic jetzt auch wirklich...
Ask the King for your Reward.
Nice.
So, genug Platz im Inventar haben wir auch.
Exzellent.
Dann suche ich jetzt ja gleich mal für den Huni eine Gruppe.
Ich muss mit dem Huni, glaube ich, noch zum König vorher.
Und die...
Chat, kann ihr euch nicht erinnern?
War ich mit dem Huni schon beim König und habe die 15er-Quests abgeholt?
Ja.
Nicht.
Da muss ich mich beeilen.
55 wollen die los.
CL5-Dungeon.
Is band.
Okay.
Nehmen wir uns das jetzt mal schnell.
Zack.
Okay.
Rüstung.
Inventar-Space ist genug.
Finish.
Okay.
Äh.
BG-Leader.
Nee, wer hat das?
Zug.
Oder so.
Alles klar.
55 wollen die los.
Achso, ja, passt mal auf
Hier, guckt mal, jetzt sehe ich mit der Rüstung
Nicht mal ganz so verkackt aus, also die hier ist es nicht
Guck mal, Healer, Healer
Epic Rüstung, zack
Hut lasse ich mal weg, zack
Zack, zack
Zack, sieht doch schon gleich ein bisschen besser aus
Oder? Mal ganz so verkackt
CRM
LFG
Ich log mal kurz um
So, ich muss jetzt auf den Huni umloggen
Und ganz schnell
Zum Dungeon flitzen
Ich bin mir unschlüssig
Ob ich vorher zum King muss oder nicht
Realm Calls, das ist die Epic
Schauen wir mal
Ich habe noch 4 Minuten Zeit
Account
So, machen wir mal hier den
LFG Spam
Ich brauche nicht unbedingt
Eine Gruppe für CL5
Aber wenn ich nicht in Gruppe
Bin für CL5, muss ich auf jeden Fall gucken
Das Hulu
Hulu macht eine Gruppe auf
Besser man, Hulu
Ah, wir haben sogar einen Port, sehr schön
Wahrscheinlich Mulan
Alle haben ihren Port, Mulan
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich noch zum König muss
Vorher
Unschlüssig
Mulan coming up, okay
Gucken wir mal, ob ich die annehmen kann
Wenn ich die annehmen kann
Dann sehe ich das gleich bei den Quests
Wenn nicht, muss ich mich sehr stark sputen
Dann muss ich noch zum König mit dem schwätzen
Aber ich glaube, es geht mit
50 einfach so
Sehen wir gleich
So, da ist die erste
Ah, nice
Okay
Accept
Sehr schön
Wir haben keinerlei Heals
Wir haben kein
Okay, das ist
Das ist ja eine Group Setup, Mann
Donnerkrieger
Skalde, Rune Meister, Shadowplate
Rune Meister, Savage
Rune Meister, Shadowplate, Rune Meister, Savage
Okay, das ist echt
Super mieses Group Setup
Aber ich will mich mal nicht beschweren
Auf der anderen Seite
Nicht wild
Wir dürfen einfach kein Damage nehmen
Einfach kein Damage
Easy, just don't take damage
Okay, ich kann meinen
Group BT anmachen, dann habe ich Glück
Und wir nehmen ein bisschen, vielleicht Glück
Wir nehmen ein bisschen weniger Damage
Ist das überhaupt
Moment, ist das überhaupt
Group?
Schon?
Runes, Level, 26
Absorbs the damage of a thing
Geht das automatisch wieder?
Ja, Pulse, hier, Pulse
Sollte jetzt eigentlich wiederkommen, klar, das BT
Ja, ja, ja, Funst
Okay, das ist eigentlich ein mega nicer
Mega nicer Support
Support Spell
Man bekommt ein Schild
Was einen Nahkampftreffer
Absorbiert
Was sich alle 10 Sekunden wieder automatisch
Oder ich glaube ich sogar
Alle 5 Sekunden sogar
Oder alle 5 und nicht 10 Sekunden
Alle 10 Sekunden automatisch refreshed
Das ersetzt zwar kein Heiler
Ist aber
Sehr praktisch, gerade bei High Level Mobs
Die richtig hart hitten
Okay, check
Jetzt wird es langweilig, aber glücklicherweise nicht lang
So für eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten
Wir müssen jetzt durch den Dungeon durchzergen
Alles schön
AE
Anhieten
Auf Diamonds and Demons
Die Quest kann ich hier auch erledigen
Muss man alles taggen
Alles anhitten
Was geht
Los
Das war richtig gutes Timing
Erst
Die Heiler Epik
Und jetzt direkt CL5 mit dem Rooney
Dann brauche ich eigentlich nur noch
Die
Epik mit dem Rooney machen
Also quasi das was wir gerade gemacht haben
noch mal mit dem Rudi und alles offline auf geht's wie üblich dark pvm ziemlich
easy einfach hinstellen ae spammen jetzt mache ich das was der Rudi am besten
kann einen Knopf drücken für drei Stunden am Stück mehr mache ich jetzt
nicht und schon instant win aber ich muss die Effekte ausmachen
epileptische Anfälle wobei ich lasse die Effekte anders für euch netter
zuzugucken gut unser Shadow Blade hat es ein bisschen
verkackt er ist zu spät da kommt jetzt nicht mehr rein weil du kannst es auch
so was was es auf live da auch nicht gibt du kannst town portals und
binstone porten so gibt es gibt es den da auch nicht
normalerweise
und man kann diese town portals allerdings nur verwenden wenn die Gruppe
nicht im fight ist und wir sind gerade im fight dementsprechend kann unsere
Shadow Blade da nicht rein nicht mehr rein porten und spätestens wenn wir den
ersten Boss gelegt haben macht es auch überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr hier rein
zu porten. The Kings Champion hier das ist die Quest
genau oh oh ae ae ich brauche auch brauche mobs hiervon jawoll okay ich habe jetzt
gesagt ich brauche auch brauche mobs hiervon jawoll okay ich habe jetzt
gar nicht in chat geguckt das schleichen finde ich auf jeden aktuell
sehr anstrengend deft die schleicher sex unterbinden wollen können dann und alle
klassen die nicht schleichen können die schleicher leichter entdecken oder finde
ich gut wenn du mich fragst bin ich sofort dabei sobald du in einem
einhandradius bist vorbei das ganze ja das ist mir das ist mir tatsächlich auch
schon aufgefallen ich habe schon also gerade auf ihnen
habe ich erstaunlich viele schleicher schon aus dem styles raus gekloppt weil
ich den gesehen haben gerade wenn man mit der gruppe durchläuft dann ein
einer der group sieht eigentlich immer irgendein schleicher wenn man durch
engpässe durchläuft ja glücklicher weise sind die
meisten leute halb afk in gruppen und machnicks ja aber das ist mir auch
immer noch aufgefallen ja wenn du mich fragst ich mag schleiche
überhaupt nicht und alles was die machen um schleicher abzufucken ist mir recht
ich verstehe natürlich dass es kacke ist wenn man selbst gerne schleicher spiel
dass wir das dann nicht so geil findet
hey everybody rammt uf undMak desire to get mastery xD
auch die erster sitschky game wo winekler gemeldet 03 mal runter geht
Für mich ist das gut. Alles, was Stelzer irgendwie nervt oder schlechter macht, ist mir recht. Zumal gerade Assassins auf Eden ziemlich OP sind, wenn man denn, muss man dazu sagen, wenn man denn Auto-Hotkey benutzt und Auto-Hotkey ist nicht verboten. Auto-Hotkey macht Assassins ziemlich OP. Du kannst quasi jeden Schlag neu vergiften, die Waffe.
Normalerweise konntest du als Assassin Gift auf deine Waffen machen und dann hast du halt einmal geschlagen, da wurde das Gift angewandt und gut ist. Und du kannst quasi jetzt mit Auto-Hotkey kannst du Gifte rotieren aus dem Inventar raus. Was richtig krass ist. Also du kannst gefühlt kaum noch One-on-One gegen einen Schleicher gewinnen.
Ich spamme jetzt einfach AE und gut ist. Wie sehr da ich meine... Ach Quatsch, ich habe ja hier gar keine Epic. Die Epic muss ich ja gleich noch machen, auch mit dem Runi.
Ja, das wäre tatsächlich cool, wenn du bei LD noch die Credits bekommen könntest. Wobei das oftmals funktioniert, jetzt schon. Weil du halt bei LD noch bis zu 20 Sekunden teilweise im Game bist und wenn der Boss halt dann umkippt, dann kriegst du den Credit noch.
Wenn du halt gerade draußen bist, hast du Pech. Das haben sie ja bei Relikten, haben sie das übrigens auf Eden schon gemacht. Wenn du bei einem Relikt-Rate dabei bist und du bist in der Zone zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo das Relikt aufgehoben wird, dann kriegst du den Credit beim Einsatz.
Egal, ob du zwischendurch LD hast oder nicht. Finde ich eins ganz gut.
Exzellent sozusagen. Brauche ich hier noch welche? Erstmal, ich hitte einfach mal alles an, was es hier gibt. Ja, davon brauche ich noch welche. 4 von 10, 5 von 10. Next. Go, go, go.
Ich will hier nicht länger drin bleiben, weil es notwendig ist.
Der Hauke PVE ist immer so.
Müdend.
Oh nein, die Mobs brauche ich auch noch.
Also wer anspruchsvolles PVE in Dark machen will, es gibt ein paar Sachen auf Eden, die man semi-anspruchsvoll nennen könnte.
Das erste ist Sobekite oder wie auch immer man das genau ausspricht.
Mit 8er-Kub, das ist tatsächlich eine der wenigsten Instanzen, die es gibt.
Das reine Group-Content kannst du gar nicht mit mehr rein.
Wobei, wenn man es ein paar Mal gemacht hat, der Anspruch sich in Grenzen hält.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht Brain-AFK und Durchzerren.
Dann kannst du die ein oder anderen Thor-Encounter machen, die allerdings nur Skins bringen auf Eden, sonst nichts.
Ich glaube, im eigenen Realm kannst du die Shapeshift-Effekte noch benutzen.
Aber ansonsten sind Artefakte und sowas reine.
Guckt es euch an! Guckt es euch an, wie sie die falsche Richtung laufen!
Guckt es euch an! Meine Güte, Alter, die Leute sind so...
Jetzt mal ehrlich, ne?
Ich habe es heute schon fünfmal gesagt.
Viele Leute spielen das 20 Jahre und checken immer noch nichts.
Das ist unglaublich, teilweise.
In Dark ist es halt echt so, wenn du dich auf andere Spieler verlassen musst,
die nicht zu deiner Gruppe gehören, mit denen du öfters spielst,
oder von denen du weißt, dass die was taugen, dann bist du verlassen.
Wie man eben bei dem Epic-Step eindrucksvoll gesehen hat,
ich cc alles als Heiler selbst, ich kann nichts machen,
und die Nahkämpfer stehen halt drinnen und denken sich so,
ach nee, ich mache mal kurz meine Quest-Objective und renne wieder raus.
Spezialisten, alle so.
Habe ich die schon?
Mal hier kurz...
Darkness Falls Explorer...
Ich habe...
Okay, Umbrot Warrior brauchen wir.
Crawler und Hulks brauche ich noch.
Hulks Crawler...
Überschaubar.
Nein, das brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Habe ich 10 von 10.
Alles gut.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich glaube, da kommen gleich noch welche.
Ja, Hulks kommen immer noch.
Auto Hot, hier ist so eine strittige Sache.
Ich verwende es auch nicht.
Aber ich werde es verwenden.
Sobald ich einen Anwendungsfall für habe, wo ich sage,
ey, damit würde es wirklich deutlich einfacher zu spielen oder effektiver zu spielen.
Zum Beispiel, für meinen Heiler werde ich es wahrscheinlich benutzen.
Du kannst mit Auto...
Ich meine, wenn du das Spiel nicht gecheckt hast und nicht weißt,
was du wie wo machen musst, bringt dir Auto Hot Key auch nichts.
Also es ist ein heiß diskutiertes Thema.
Für manch einen ist es Cheaten.
Für manch einen ist es...
Es ist quasi Next Level, Dark Skills, wie auch immer.
Ah, fuck.
Die Viecher brauche ich.
Hat mal wieder keiner Aed.
Also beim Heiler werde ich es auf jeden Fall benutzen.
Zumindest werde ich es ausprobieren, ob ich es auf jeden Fall benutzen werde.
Am Ende war es einmal hingestellt.
Wäre jetzt auch fast falsch gerannt, absichtlich um die Mobs hier zu balken.
Ah, hier, jetzt.
Ae, gebe ihm.
Jawoll.
Schön gesperrt.
Beim Heiler kannst du nämlich wirklich coole Sachen machen.
Du kannst zum Beispiel Single Mats und D-Mats auf eine Taste legen.
Was Quickbars spart, Cubines spart, Platz spart und sehr angenehm ist.
Okay, habe ich jetzt 10 von 10?
Nein.
Einer hat resisted, okay.
Ah, da vorne.
Nein!
Leute, wenn meine Gruppe ja nicht komplett AFK wäre,
dann könnten wir da vorne jetzt reintanken.
Wir könnten...
Okay, please, please, nicht pullen, nicht pullen.
Fünf, vier, drei, zwei, eins und frei.
Let's go.
Ah, super.
Haben wir nichts abgekriegt.
Doch, 10 von 10.
Aber unser Shammy hat es gepackt.
Ja, es ist halt erlaubt.
Und dadurch, dass es erlaubt ist, kann man halt auch nicht sagen, es wäre gecheatet.
Ich kenne die Diskussion.
Für viele ist es ja tatsächlich sowas wie gecheatet, aber ich denke mir, hey, es ist erlaubt.
Was nicht erlaubt ist, sind...
Schleifen in Auto-Hotkey.
Also, du kannst beispielsweise nicht sagen, ich switche meine Auren und Songs immer wieder durch.
Was ich aber eh für total unsinnig halte.
Selbst wenn das erlaubt wäre, würde ich es nicht machen.
Weil du bekommst...
Also, selbst mit maximaler Duration auf deine Songs, glaube ich, kannst du nicht alle Songs abhaben.
Deswegen macht man einfach die Songs an, die passen gerade und fertig.
Du brauchst gar nicht alle Songs.
Also, entweder...
Gerade, wenn man Skalde spielt, du hast immer Speed an.
Plus X.
So, X ist in der Regel defaultmäßig Damage-Add.
Oder bei einem längeren Fight Mana oder...
Oh, die Grappler. Grappler brauche ich unbedingt.
Grappler müssen Aed werden. Jawohl.
Schön reinsperren hier.
Nice.
Ja, also entweder lässt du Mana laufen.
Oder...
Damage-Add, Default oder Resist.
So war es eigentlich.
Rest braucht man selten.
Dafür würde ich kein Auto-Hotkey benutzen.
Selbst wenn es sinnvoll wäre.
Also, selbst wenn man es machen könnte.
Selbst wenn es erlaubt wäre mit Schleife, würde ich es nicht machen.
Weil ich glaube, selbst wie gesagt, mit Max Spell Duration kriegst du nicht alle Songs permanent ab.
Und das ist dann irgendwie auch sinnlos.
Weil, was bringt es dann?
Dafür kann man andere nette Sachen machen.
Also, wie gesagt, gerade auf Supportern, die Tasten doppelt belegen, finde ich sehr praktisch.
Dass du beispielsweise, sagen wir mal jetzt, Single Target Sleep und Demerz auf eine Taste legst.
Dann kannst du nämlich entweder, sagen wir mal auf 2, dann kannst du den Typ anklicken und 2 drücken.
Dann wird der Demerz und du klickst den Gegner an, drückst 2 und dann wird gemetzt.
Das finde ich sehr praktisch.
Und nachdem man da im Prinzip immer noch alles selbst machen muss, finde ich das gar nicht so verwerflich.
Also, ich werde es mir auf dem Heiler angucken und wahrscheinlich werde ich es auf dem Heiler auch verwenden.
Oh, kann das sein, dass ich aus Versehen gefühlt hier den halben Raum gerade aeht habe und wir haben keinen Heiler bei uns in der Group?
Ah, nix wie weg.
Nix.
Ich halte mich mal ein bisschen zurück.
Ich will das hier nicht abkratzen.
Wir haben nur einen Chammy.
Chammys können zwar nicht schlecht heilen, aber gerade großartigen Burst Damage und auf die komplette Group sind Chammys jetzt nicht die besten Heiler.
Ja, für Nahkampfangriffe ist Outdoor Hotkey genau für diese eine Sache sinnvoll.
Für Backup Styles.
Ohne die Backup Style Funktionalität im Game benutzen zu müssen.
Alles mit einer Taste, ja.
Dass du mit einer Taste quasi Side-Stun-Any-Timer machen kannst.
Und ganz ehrlich, würde ich das machen?
Also, hätte ich einen Char, wo das sehr sinnvoll ist, ich würde es wahrscheinlich auch benutzen.
Aber das ist das Einzige, was du mit Nahkampf-Chars machen kannst.
Aber schon, ist schon...
Man kann das alles auch von Hand machen.
Es ist nicht so, als dass das irgendwie großartig was bringt.
Der könnte genauso gut einfach zwei Tasten jedes Mal drücken.
Au.
Ist ein...
Also, in der Dark-Community schon lange Zeit recht umstrittenes Thema.
Ich denke, auf ihn ist die Frage halt, ja, eher eine persönliche.
So, will man es selbst benutzen oder ist da für einen persönlich die Grenze überschritten?
Weil offiziell ist es ganz einfach.
Offiziell ist Outdoor Hotkey erlaubt.
Und solange du keine Schleifen machst.
So, wo ist Hulu?
Hul-Lul-Lul.
Hul?
Wie heißt der Typ?
Hul-Lul-Lul.
Besser.
Guck mal.
Ja, richtig echter Malacca.
Auf Live-Servern ist es nicht erlaubt.
Sicher?
Okay, auf Live-Servern ist es die typische, typische Sache.
Es steht in den Bedingungen drin wahrscheinlich.
Man darf keine Makro-Programme benutzen.
Aber sie werden wahrscheinlich auch nicht einen gebannt haben auf Live, weil er Makro-Programme benutzt.
Ich hab mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Auf Live, jeden, den die aktuell auf Live bannen, ist Geldverlust so.
Und die machen mit Dark eh schon immer viel Geld.
Wahrscheinlich bannen die auf Live einfach gar keinen mehr.
Selbst Radar, selbst detektete Radar-User werden wahrscheinlich auf Live nicht mehr gebannt, weil es Geld kostet.
Generell hat Dark halt auch keine Anti-Cheat-Erkennung.
Du kannst das nur selberseitig feststellen, dass irgendwas halt passiert, was normalerweise so mit einem malen Client nicht möglich ist.
Weiter geht's.
So, die Hälfte haben wir durch, Leute.
Nur noch, nur noch circa Viertelstunde Resident Sleeper.
Bis der Raid vorbei ist.
Und dann bin ich CL5.
Bedeutet als nächstes, ich guck mir mal nebenbei, jetzt sind wir mal mutig.
Ich sticke mal Hulu Malacca und gucke mal kurz in meinen Scharplaner für den Heiler rein.
In der Hoffnung.
Ich finde eine gute BG-Spec.
Achso, hab ich überhaupt alle Quests mittlerweile?
Ein Hulk und drei Crawler.
Okay, ich muss da noch ein bisschen aufpassen.
Wir machen erstmal die Quest voll, bevor ich Scharplaner gucke.
Das hab ich alles, hab ich alles.
Weil ich trau meinem restlichen Team nicht zu, die Mobs zu taggen.
Crawler gibt's auf jeden Fall vor Legion.
Und Hulks müsste es gleich beim nächsten Boss geben.
Also, ich hab mir überlegt, das wär mal was für's Stream.
Portal Revolution erscheint nach Freigabe durch...
Ach ja.
Ach, das ist...
Ich hab schon gedacht, sie hätten es wirklich geschafft, mal einen dritten Teil zu produzieren.
Aber das ist ein Mod.
Aber gerade im Half-Life-Universum gibt's enorm viele gute Mods.
Guckt euch Black Mesa an.
So ist es offiziell, dass die Community...
Nice.
Da hätte ich echt Bock drauf auf einen Portal-Mod.
Zack.
Wenn's ein Community-Mod ist...
Eigentlich, wisst ihr was?
Was 2024, wisst ihr was mega geil ist?
Die werden sicherlich nicht die Sprecherin von Kladdus bekommen haben.
Aber...
Durch AI kannst du heutzutage wahrscheinlich, ohne dass du den Sprecher dafür brauchst und die Sprecherin dafür brauchst,
das fast zu 99% original nachmachen.
Die haben das bestimmt mit AI-Kladdus-Stimme.
Oh, Hulks.
Hulks.
AE.
Ja, 10 von 10.
Nice.
Jetzt fehlen mir nur noch drei Crawler.
Müssen wir mal gucken, dass ich vor Legion alles tagge.
Hulks da drüben?
Ja.
Ich guck mir den Mod mal an.
Ich kopier mir das mal rüber.
Habt ihr übrigens schon gehört?
Nicht so Poggers Bahnstreik am Mittwoch.
Und ich muss Mittwoch nach Frankfurt mal gucken.
Es könnte auch sein, dass mein Chef sagt, wir verschieben das alles.
Ey, wir müssen den Boss da drüben killen, Leute.
Wo rennt ihr denn hin?
Wo ist denn der BG-Leader?
Ist der auch hier lang gerannt?
Äh...
Wo ist der BG-Leader?
Oh, Crawler!
Crawler!
Nice.
Okay, ein Crawler.
Einer weniger.
Wir müssen den Boss da aber noch killen jetzt, ne?
Crawler!
Schnell!
AE!
9 von 10.
Und?
Und 10 von 10.
Jawoll, Quest fertig.
Nice.
Excellent.
Wir haben aber den Boss vergessen.
Und zwar...
Wir müssen...
Wo ist die Quest?
Ne.
Oh Mann, ich bin...
Ja, Kings Champion.
Den haben wir nur nicht gekillt.
Wir müssen nochmal zurück.
Den Boss killen.
Aber wie ist das denn rechtlich, wenn die Stimme AI generiert ist?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber nachdem Valve das erlaubt hat, ist es zumindest Copyright-technisch, was Half-Life angeht und Portal angeht, kein Problem.
Inwieweit man die Stimme von anderen Leuten kopieren darf und ob man ein Urheberrecht an seiner eigenen Stimme hat, weiß ich nicht.
Man würde so spontan sagen, ja, sicherlich.
Aber das ist ja alles immer nicht so einfach.
Okay, da hinten kommt der Boss.
Der wird jetzt kurz angeboltet und dann verpisse ich mich.
So, ich hab Damage gemacht.
Jetzt ist alles gut.
Au.
Auf mich anzucasten, Kacknoob.
Ey, wo willst du hin?
Gehst du weg?
Was soll das?
Jetzt mal seriously.
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
Was sehe ich hier überhaupt?
Was ist das?
Was sehe ich hier?
Also ich sehe vor lauter Effekten schon mal nicht so viel, aber was soll das für ein Viech überhaupt sein?
Ich kann das nicht zuordnen.
Was ist das?
Hatten die...
Hatten die Grafik-Designer keinen Bock, oder?
Ich erkenne es nicht.
Hat jemand eine Idee, warum Edgar At Home keine Werbung blockiert, obwohl diese eingeschaltet ist?
Blockliste...
Ach nee, sehr entschuldigt.
Kommt drauf an.
Smartphone ist teilweise schwierig.
Smartphones umgehen oftmals dann den DNS, der von DHCP zugewiesen wird.
Und dann funktioniert das.
Wird denn dein DHCP überhaupt verwendet?
Wird denn überhaupt dein AdGuard als DNS-Server verwendet?
Kannst du das sonst?
Sonst geht es natürlich nicht.
Und viele Seiten sind mittlerweile auch pfeifert und lassen sich nicht mehr so austricksen, so einfach mit DNS-Blocking.
Mit DNS-Blocking lässt sich ja nur...
Also mit DNS-Blocking lässt sich ja nur Werbung umgehen, wenn Werbung und Content von unterschiedlichen Servern kommen.
Also sagen wir mal, wenn du so ein bekanntes Ad-Netzwerk verwendest und das ist geblockt, okay, dann geht das.
Aber dazu muss zwingend der DNS verwendet werden, der Ad-Blocker-DNS benutzt werden als DNS.
Und es muss halt was sein, was über ein bekanntes Ad-Netzwerk ausgeliefert wird.
Oder zumindest von einer anderen Domain sein, als der Content, den du sehen willst.
Sonst funktioniert es nicht.
Und wahrscheinlich ist auf den Seiten, wo es bei dir nicht funktioniert, das nicht gegeben.
Achso.
Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
K.
feldzug oder sowas könnte man vielleicht sagen aber es trifft sich so genau was
heißt was raid shadow legends raid was heißt raid auf deutsch überfall also um
das jetzt mal auf deutsch zu sagen bitte lasst diesen überfall bald vorbei
sein klingt aber erstens total falsch und
zweitens trifft es den sinn auch nicht laut kugel razzia lasst diese razzia bald
vorbei sein also ich würde es eher als feldzug oder so übersetzen dass das hat
noch ein bisschen mehr den ursprünglichen sinn bleibt noch ein
bisschen mehr erhalten schlachtzug schlachtzug ist auch gut ja
ja ich ist da war ich mit feldzug doch gar nicht so weit vorbei
ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
ja wenn wo das das schlachtzug nennt dann ist gut hat das mmo auch audio ja
ich habe es leise gemacht hört man nichts mehr von den sounds
ich habe es leise gemacht weil die sounds mich nerven man müsste noch ein
bisschen was hören im hintergrund ja dass man nichts hat ich muss ich ich
checke das jetzt gerade mal auf meinem handy bisschen was hören müssen man
eigentlich doch klar hört man hört man ich habe es extra gerade um handy
gecheckt
das hat auch sound aber auf auf hier so einem bg raid hörst nicht viel außer
sinnlose zaubers im hintergrund du hörst zum beispiel wenn ich meine balls kaste
das hörst du ja da macht so ein feuergeräusch aber ich habe die sounds
absichtlich leise weil die dark sounds sind von 2001 es gibt so lustige habe ich
letztens schon erzählt gibt lustige story wie die sounds überhaupt zustande
gekommen sind in dem game es war wie gesagt das spiel wurde 2001 oder
2000 2001 entwickelt relativ relativ mit relativ enger deadline also die das
ursprüngliche kogens des games und damals gab es ja noch keine stopf photos
seiten und uns sound sei und egy generated sounds und sowas und die hatten
das problem dass sich damals gebraucht haben für gegner und effekte oder dem
spiel und da haben sie sich damals stock audio cds gekauft und deswegen hören sich viele sound
in dem spiel auch so falsch an weil die halt irgendwelche sounds nehmen mussten
die auf diesen stock audio cds drauf waren ja da hattest du dann ehrlich
gesagt ich persönlich kenne so cds nicht mehr aber da hattest du halt so die die
random sounds schlechthin drauf so keine ahnung lama scheißt auf baumstumpf
oder so weiß weiß ich was man dafür was man dafür sounds auf so einer stock
audio cd drauf hat und die sounds haben die im endeffekt für das game genommen
später haben sie natürlich ein bisschen verbessert aber viele der alten sounds
sind da halt noch drauf und dass das sind zum großteil am anfang waren das
sounds deswegen ihr müsst euch die mob sounds teilweise an also entweder haben
das irgendwelche leute dort selbst ganz schlecht mit schlechtem audio equipment
gemacht oder sind wirklich noch sounds von diesen stock audio cds next wie
viele wie viele sachen müssen ich habe ja gesagt es dauert
noch viertelstunde aber wir sind lahm wir brauchen noch wir brauchen noch ein
boss und dann den final boss okay ja sagen wir so vielleicht fünf bis zehn
minuten dann ist das endlich durch der nachvertonung im film ist ja noch was
anderes das ist ja quasi fast schon eine wissenschaft für sich vieles was man du
hast schon recht vieles was man im film sieht ist überhaupt nicht das was man hört ja also wenn du da beispielsweise
irgendjemand im film siehst er sich gerade einen anzug anzieht und du diesen sound hörst dabei dann
ist das nicht unbedingt das sound vom anzug den er sich anzieht sondern leute die das halt so
nachvertonen haben mit sounds die sich halt besser anhören als der anzug sich wirklich anhören gefühlt
lauft ihr die ganze zeit im kreis alles sieht gleich aus das liegt daran dass alles gleich
aussieht und wir tatsächlich im kreis laufen guck dir das mal an wir haben hier unten angefangen und
sind einmal im kreis gelaufen und laufen jetzt hier wieder wir haben jetzt hier ein bisschen mehr
ein kreis gelaufen und jetzt laufen wir hier zum final boss und dann ist vorbei ja aber du hast
recht ersten sieht alles gleich aus und zweiten zieht es nicht nur gleich aus sondern wir laufen
auch im kreis der dungeon ist ja nicht groß da sind ja im prinzip hier nur ja so ein größerer
ein größerer ring quasi und dann hier der hier in der mitte der gang unten sobald wir sobald wir
den den kreisel grind verlassen wirst du auch sehen sieht es anders aus doppelt verwirren ja
es sieht alles gleich aus und wir laufen jetzt hier in den kreiselgrind und wir laufen hier in den
kreis aber sobald wir den den den kreisel kreislauf verlassen wirst du sehen es sieht auch ein
bisschen anders aus guck hier hast du die boss räume immer das halt so ein kreis uns fehlt jetzt
noch der hier der mit dem super easy auszusprechen den namen barbjot danach kommt der nächste tanke
glücklicherweise nicht ich glaube damit ich glaube dann war es das mit dann erst mal danach muss ich
muss ich die
frontier steps für die huni epic machen dann noch mal die letzten zwei epic steps die wir eben schon mit dem heiler gemacht haben da muss ich noch mal schnell den chartplaner für den heiler gucken ich muss ein template für den huni raussuchen dass ich heute abend gescheit spielen kann damit ich meine ich habe genug currency ich kann einfach alles an items kaufen und ich hoffe dass mal noch ein paar leute an start kommen dass wir noch ein bisschen rvr machen können aber gerade
sind keine leute da ich habe gerade extra noch mal ins discord geguckt kein bock auf tg
er ist gerade tg das halte ich jetzt nicht aus noch mal einen tg raid hinten drauf außerdem habe ich keinen charmair der das braucht ich habe mehr als genug currency den jetzt hier zu
equippen und den und den heiler zu equippen wobei der heiler da kann er eh keine 50er items anziehen er bleibt ja 49 5
so hier boss killen please
man sieht von dem boss noch nicht mal was wo ist er denn hier da da ist ok da erkenne ich jetzt sogar was es sein soll das ist irgendein fisch ok ich erkenne nicht was es sein soll irgendein fisch und es heißt fabiotre alles klar es muss letztendlich ist es auch wurscht weil das hat keine story hier oder sowas wobei streng genommen hat es eine story aber ich habe keine ahnung
es muss gebasht werden dafür dass ich gleich fünf champion levels bekomme das
ist das wichtige dabei der rest ist mir egal
theoretisch hat es sogar eine story aber ich kenne niemand der die story kennt
weil in dog niemand quests liest und auf eden glaube ich die meisten sachen gar
keine quest texte haben ja aber selbst auf live niemand liest die story
wird das für die nostalie gespielt das wird für pvp gespielt
das ist das beste game was es gibt das beste mmo wenn man pvp spielen weil es
gibt kein besseres aus meiner sicht und das obwohl es 20 jahre alt ist 23 jahre
alt ist 22 jahre alt ist ich habe ich habe nie quest texte gelesen ich habe
nie quest texte gelesen selbst auf live nicht warum weil es schon mal eine
sache hat die sonst
kein mir bekanntes anderes MMO hat, beziehungsweise so gut macht.
Nämlich, ihr werdet vielleicht Parallelen zu Elder Scrolls Online erkennen, wenn ich euch das jetzt erzähle.
Weil du drei verschiedene Reiche hast.
Du hast einmal dieses Reich hier mit dem Baum, einmal die mit dem Hammer und einmal mit diesem Kelch.
Ich spiele in Midgard, das sind die mit dem Hammer.
Das ist quasi so an nordische Mythologie und Wikinger und Gedöns angelegt, äh angelehnt.
Dann hast du die mit dem Baum, das ist Hibernia, das ist so an keltische Sachen angelegt.
Dann hast du Albion, das sind die mit dem Kelch.
Da haben die, da haben die, die Roleplayer früher immer im RVR geschrieben.
Für den Kelch, voran und so komisches Zeug.
Roleplayer sind eh ganz eigene Spezies an Gamern.
Seht hier ein mächtiger Zauberer, er steht mit dem Feuer im Bunde.
Weil du drei verschiedene Reiche hast, äh wir sind noch nicht fertig, ne?
Ich sag's nur mal.
Leute, wir sind noch nicht fertig.
Ich möchte nur noch anfügen, dass wir noch nicht fertig sind, auch wenn wir gerade eine Quest abgegeben haben.
Aber wir haben zumindest schon mal einen Hut bekommen, der besser ist als mein Molvik-Hut auf jeden Fall.
Was haben wir denn hier für einen Hut?
Wir haben einen Hut für eher Heiler und einen Hut für...
Das ist eher der Heiler-Hut, ne?
Die Decks, Decks, mehr Decks, mehr Decks, schneller casten, wichtig.
Dann haben wir noch einen Gürtel, der auch gar nicht so übel ist.
Den ziehen wir erstmal an.
Und noch einen Bracer, der riesen Pierce hat und Decks increase.
Auch nice.
Und das war's.
Jetzt haben wir glaube ich schon mal...
Gar nicht mal so schnell.
Schlechte...
Okay, Spirit-Rezis sind ein bisschen wenig.
Gar nicht mal so miese Stats für einen Level-Armor-ausgerüsteten Huni.
307 Decks.
Ich hab noch nicht mal...
Doch, ich hab Speck...
Aber keine Bases.
Ich hab keine Bases.
Warum hab ich keine Bases?
Okay.
Deswegen hab ich so wenig Decks, weil ich keine Base-Buffs hab.
Ich muss mal kurz meinen Buff-Trank trinken.
So.
Naja, mein Mollvik-Hut hab ich gemeint hier.
Mollvik.
Das ist dort, wo ich den...
Bei dem NPC, wo ich den gekauft hab.
Guck mal.
Euch fällt auf, wir haben uns...
Wir haben den Kreis verlassen.
Es sieht jetzt anders aus auf einmal.
Ja.
So, es gibt drei verschiedene Reiche.
Jedes Reich hat komplett unterschiedliche Klassen.
Manche Sachen überschneiden sich ein bisschen.
Aber im Prinzip sind es drei komplett unterschiedliche Reiche.
Inklusive Grenzgebiet, Heimatbereich.
Und die...
Dadurch hat das Game eine nie erreichte Dynamik im PvP.
Weil selbst wenn du ein Reich hast,
das zur Zeit mehr Spieler eingeloggt hat und alles wegzerkt,
du hast immer noch den Fall,
dass in einem Fight, wo quasi...
Sagen wir mal, es gibt einen Fight.
200 vs. 80.
In der Regel zu 99% gewinnen die mit 200.
Bei solchen Riesen-Riesen-Fights.
Realistischere Zahlen.
Nehmen wir mal realistischere Zahlen.
Du hast 100 vs. 60.
Ja.
Zu 99%.
Gewinnen die mit 100.
Aber wenn die mit 60 clever spielen und das so drehen,
dass vielleicht das dritte Reich noch am Start ist,
auch mit 50,
dann kannst du auch mit 60 160 killen.
Wenn du es gescheit machst.
Da musst du dir halt einen guten Fight aussuchen.
Zum Beispiel ist es immer sinnvoll,
wenn...
Sagen wir mal...
Die Leute aus Albion sitzen in irgendeinem Festungsturm
und die Hips zergen die um
und du wartest den Moment ab,
bis gerade das Tor vom Turm kaputt geht,
alle in den Turm rein stürmen
und dann rusht du hin.
Dann hast du 50 im Turm von einem Reich,
60 vom anderen Reich draußen
und 100 dazwischen,
die quasi gesandwiched werden.
Und durch diese Dynamik aus 3 Realm,
PvP,
ist eigentlich jeder Tag anders
und es wird nie langweilig.
Obwohl man oberflächlich sagen könnte,
ja man macht ja immer das gleiche,
aber in jedem Game machst du oberflächlich betrachtet immer das gleiche.
Es ist nie langweilig.
Und vielleicht erkennt ihr die ein oder anderen Parallelen
da dran zu Elder Scrolls Online.
Das liegt daran, dass einer der...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob es einer der Hauptentwickler von Dark war,
aber ich glaube einer der Mitgründer damals von Mystic Entertainment,
der hat Elder Scrolls Online maßgeblich mitgebaut,
aber selbst da haben sie es nicht so gut hingekriegt.
Auf welchem Chart spielst du auf Eden?
Es gibt ja nur einen nennenswerten.
So, jetzt machen wir dieses fette Viech da kaputt.
Weiß.
So, und gleich haben wir es geschafft.
Wenn ich jetzt...
Wir haben alles gekillt
und jetzt zum Final Boss.
Prage, prage, dass es die Leute nicht wieder verkacken.
Also hier, ich spiele auf Eden.
Also falls du auch früher gespielt hast,
früher gespielt hast und Bock hast,
es ist super simpel.
Du lädst dir den offiziellen Dark Client runter.
Spiel, bitte laden.
Du lädst dir den offiziellen Dark Client runter,
updatest den, also lädst runter, startest den,
dann lädt er sich die neuesten Sachen runter
und dann startest du den Eden Launcher,
gibst den Dark Folder an und drückst auf Play.
Fertig. Ganz easy.
Ich glaube, das kriegt jeder hin.
Wirklich nicht ganz schwer.
Eats AF.
Was musst du beim Final Boss beachten?
Was ist deine Aufgabe?
Das ist Dark PvE.
AE-Damage, Spam und warten, bis er umkippt.
Wenn wir von etwas anspruchsvollerem PvE reden würden,
sagen wir mal, ich würde jetzt einen Krupp-Dungeon machen,
gibt es ja einen recht relativ anspruchsvollen hier auf Eden
und ein paar Artefakt-Encounter,
die mit kleiner Gruppe auch recht anspruchsvoll sein können.
Dann wäre meine Aufgabe jetzt,
nein, jetzt in dem Fall ist es halt blöd,
weil hier ist AE-Spam und Ruhe ist,
dann wäre meine Aufgabe, je nach Fight,
entweder Gegner Single-Target zu CCen,
dass sie sich nicht mehr bewegen können,
oder ein Damage zu machen und sie umzupusten.
Weil ich bin gerade Main-Range-Damage-Dealer von diesem Reich.
Hier muss ich gar nichts machen.
Hier muss ich einfach nur AE-Spam und warten,
dass die restlichen Leute von der BG den umzergen.
Easy as fuck.
Guck, ist schon fast tot.
Und dead.
Easy.
Das ist Dark PvE.
Das ist aber auch so was, wo hier...
Okay, Tor, alles klar.
Das ist aber auch was, was extra so gemacht ist,
dass jeder Voll-Depp es auf die Reihe kriegen kann.
So, wir haben es geschafft.
Ich glaube,
wir können direkt, wir können direkt zum König und das Ganze abgeben, oder?
King's Champion.
Return to King Eric.
Guck mal, Hulu hat schon ein Portal am Start.
Dann returnen wir doch mal.
Wo zum Teufel sind deine Spells?
Ja, zwischen den 30 anderen Spells.
Ach so, habe ich Effekte nicht angehabt?
Kann sein, dass ich Effekte nicht angehabt habe.
Weil es dazu neigt, zu ruckeln, wenn Effekte an sind.
Selbst auf dem NASA-PC.
Von 2024.
Ach so.
Äh, das hier sind meine Spells.
Ich kann es dir gleich mal zeigen, was die Spells machen.
Huni ist eines der einfachsten Klassen überhaupt.
Du brauchst vier Tasten und gut ist.
Wenn du das mit einem Heiler vergleichst,
der irgendwie acht Quickbars braucht,
oder so, um alles unterzubringen,
ist Huni easy as fuck.
Ich kann die Spells gleich mal zeigen.
Ich habe mir den Shire hier auch hauptsächlich gemacht,
damit ich schön abends im Zerg mitlaufen kann.
AE-Spam.
Und gut ist.
So, except...
FINISH!
Jawoll!
Jetzt gibt's Champion Level.
Für den kleinen Pox-Champ.
Und wenn ich Champion Level 5 bin,
deswegen habe ich diesen ganzen Krempel hier auch gerade mitgemacht,
das war so...
Was kann das denn? Kann das was?
Bonus-Armor-Faktor!
Auf jeden Fall Resis sind nicht verkehrt.
Habe ich noch genug Decks?
Oh, mehr.
Mehr als genug Decks.
Mehr als genug Constitutions.
Eigentlich ist mein...
Also, für das, dass es einfach nur Level-Gear ist,
ist es gar nicht mal so beschissen.
Gut, jetzt kriege ich einen Stab.
Dafür habe ich das eigentlich gemacht.
Guck, dass ich meinen
klassenspezifischen Stab kriege.
Jetzt habe ich hier so einen...
Fox-Death.
Der leuchtet sogar.
Und er hat einen Mana-Restore-Spell drauf.
So.
Um jetzt mal zu der...
Cast-Bar zu kommen.
So.
BG Leaf.
Dispense.
Sollst mal die ganzen Buffs wegklicken.
So.
Okay.
Ich muss jetzt die Runi-Epic-Frontier-Steps noch machen.
Wir sind stehen geblieben.
Bei, da kann ich dir auch gleich die Spells zeigen.
Weil, wie gesagt, Runi ist wirklich idiotensicher.
Du brauchst drei Knöpfe.
Und machst übelst Damage.
Ich würde sagen,
Runi ist...
Also, es gibt in jedem Reich
so einen Caster, der echt idioten...
Für alle geil ist, ja?
In Albion ist es Feuer Wizard.
Da musst du im Prinzip nur drücken.
1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1.
Okay, vielleicht mal ein Bolt.
1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1.
Machst übelst Damage.
Hier ist es Runi.
Wobei, Runi noch ein bisschen mehr kann.
Und in Hip.
Was ist in Hip?
Da ein Button-Caster.
Ich glaube, die haben gar keinen so richtig...
Vielleicht Eng noch am ehesten.
Wobei, der auch ein Pet hat.
Ich glaube, in Hip gibt es gar keinen so richtig krassen Ein-Button-Caster.
So, was muss ich jetzt machen?
Okay.
Ich hoffe, ich werde jetzt nicht weggesnackt.
Im PvP-Gebiet.
Also, meine Quest sagt,
ich muss nach Odin's Gate
an die Docks gehen.
Und...
Dort einen Mob killen.
Pass auf, ich werde jetzt Stream-Sniped.
Und wenn nicht,
selbst wenn ich gekillt werde,
werde ich einfach sagen, ich wurde gestream-sniped.
So, Buffs abgeholt.
Buffdrang rein.
Ja, passt alles.
Ach Quatsch, was mache ich denn hier?
Da muss ich hin.
Also, meine Spells sind folgendes.
Ich muss dir das an einem Mob zeigen.
Sonst ist das...
Das ist bescheuert.
Und jetzt im PvP-Gebiet muss ich ein bisschen
sinnig laufen, dass mich nicht gleich
irgendwas aufspießt.
Was hier an der Stelle gerne passiert,
gerade als Caster in Level-Rüstung
bin ich quasi mehr oder weniger
One-Shot von jedem halbwegs sinnvoll
ausgerüsteten Gegner.
Und gerade hier an den Docks
ist immer richtig viel los.
Auf Eden muss man übrigens
sich keine Gedanken mehr machen,
wenn man Laterne anmacht nachts.
Das haben die ausgeschaltet,
dass die anderen Leute das Licht sehen.
Da ist das Viech.
So.
Ersten beiden Spells sind Range-Damage
mit besonders hohem Damage
und besonders hoher Reichweite.
Dritter Spell ist Single-Target-Damage.
The Dead.
Ich glaube, jetzt hat man übrigens auch mal
die Spelleffekte gesehen.
Gut.
Jetzt muss ich zurück zum König.
Das sind wir heute ganz schön oft.
Und dann kann ich dir...
Ich zeig dir die Spells mal.
Ich zeig dir die Spells mal
an einem Trainings-Dummy.
Ich glaube, da ist ganz gut erkennbar,
was was ist.
Also, Rooney ist wirklich idiotensicher.
Ich finde, Rooney ist auch ein guter Einstiegs-Charme,
wenn man Bock hat auf Caster.
Rooney wird immer gebraucht,
weil jeder braucht Range-DPS-Caster.
Gerade wenn du BG spielst.
Also, BG ist meistens sowas wie
50 Leute gegen 50 Leute und sowas.
Da spielt niemand ohne Range-IE-Caster,
weil Punkte halt.
So.
Also, 5 Level 50er Trainings-Dummy.
Was ich an Spells habe, ist folgendes.
Also.
Erster Spell.
Range-Damage mit 1875 Range.
Das ist weit.
Die normalen Spells sind eigentlich
einheitlich alle nur 1500er Range.
1500er Range ist ungefähr...
Ungefähr so.
Bisschen weiter vielleicht noch.
1500er Range ist so.
Moonwalk, ja.
Und 1800er Range ist so.
Was sehr praktisch ist, weil du kannst normale Damage-Dealer halt mit den High-Range-Dingern
Two-Shotten, wenn die Pech haben, ja.
Also, das sind zwei super High-Damage,
super schnell castbare, hohe-Range-Damage-Spells.
So, das ist der erste.
Das ist der zweite.
Die machen übelst Damage.
Jetzt an dem Trainings-Dummy nicht so sehr.
Der hat auch ein paar Riesen.
Die machen übelst Damage.
Und wenn die krippen, kannst du gegnerische Caster und Low-Life-Targets Two-Shotten.
Manche sagen sogar, sie haben schon Leute One-Shotted mit einem Bolt.
Dafür, dass es nicht allzu OP ist, wie du siehst,
gehen die Dinger allerdings auf einen Cooldown von 20 Sekunden,
nachdem man sie eingesetzt hat.
Die machen übelst Damage.
Dann habe ich ein Single-Target DD.
Also, Single-Target Damage.
Du siehst den Unterschied.
Der macht jetzt...
Nur 318.
Die anderen machen 650 oder irgendwas.
Und deswegen braucht man auch ganz viel Decks als Caster.
Damit man schneller castet.
Ganz einfach.
Also, so 340, 350 Decks sollte man haben.
Witzigerweise, schneller casten geht nicht durch Geschwindigkeit hier,
sondern durch Quickness, sondern durch Geschicklichkeit.
Weil, da auch Logik.
Also, Single-Target hier.
DD.
Dann habe ich einen Area-Effekt.
Ich drücke jetzt die 4.
Area-Effekt.
Ranged.
Damaged.
Das sind diese Sperre.
So.
Und das war es eigentlich schon, was so ein Huni hat.
Ich habe noch Near-Sight geskillt.
Auch ganz praktisch.
Ja, Massive-Grafik.
Das verkürzt um 45% die Range anderer Caster und Bogenschützen.
Also, wenn ich...
Wenn ich z.B. jetzt da vorne irgendeinen, den Typ da sehe,
der hat übrigens 2300er Range,
wenn ich da vorne jetzt diesen Dude sehe
und denke mir, oh, fuck, Alter, der killt mich jetzt gleich,
wenn ich da rankomme,
dann caste ich Near-Sight drauf, so.
Gehe ich hin, caste Near-Sight drauf.
Und jetzt hat er viel weniger Range als ich.
Das heißt, ich kann da hingehen
und kann den ancasten,
kann den damagen,
kann dann weglaufen und er kann nichts machen,
weil ich viel mehr Range habe als er.
So, Near-Sight.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Spezialität,
man kann Crown-Targets setzen.
Das geht beispielsweise auch,
wie euch vielleicht auffällt,
wenn hier was dazwischen ist.
Wenn hier jetzt die Hütte dazwischen ist,
sagt er, Target not in view.
Target not in view.
Was ich aber machen kann ist,
ich kann mein Crown-Target hier hinsetzen
und diesen Spell nehmen
und da caste ich immer
auf diesen Punkt,
egal ob ich Sichtlinie hin habe oder nicht.
Das ist für
Fights an Festungen und so gut.
Wenn man beispielsweise in Innenhof
Damage machen will oder irgendwie
auf die Zinnen
Damage machen will, was wo du keine direkte
Sichtlinie hin hast.
Das macht aber auch nicht so viel Schaden hier.
Range, Area,
Damage ohne Sichtlinie.
Das ist, dass ich ein bisschen mehr
aushalte, Absorb und Armor-Faktor
Schilder.
Das hier absorbiert einen Nahkampfangriff
und das hier ist, dass ich schneller rennen kann.
Das wars an Spells. Achso!
Stimmt. Dann habe ich noch einen Root.
Das kann ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen,
weil das sich nicht bewegt.
Angenommen das hier wäre ein Tank, der auf mich zurennt.
Das wäre ein Tank, der auf mich zurennt.
Dann könnte ich den rooten.
So, zack, root.
Und dann kann er nicht mehr weiterlaufen.
Für, haltet euch fest,
für eine Minute.
Eine Minute 13 Sekunden
kann er nicht mehr weiterlaufen.
Das ist aber nur halb so wild,
weil wenn er Resistenzen hat gegen
äh
Body, wenn er Bodyresistenzen hat,
dann zählt es dann auch nur 50%
und Tanks kannst du eh nicht gescheit CC'en.
Also, realistisch betrachtet
auf einen ordentlich geskillten
Tank, der auch
sich Tank nennen kann, hält das hier vielleicht
10 Sekunden.
Und dann kann er sich wieder bewegen.
Kann man davon befreit werden?
Ja, das ist mit Dark und CC
so eine Sache. Von Root kannst du nicht befreit werden.
Du kannst
nur von Sleep befreit werden.
Sleep kannst
du heilen, Stun kannst du nicht heilen
und Root kannst du nicht heilen.
Aber Root ist meistens nicht so schlimm,
weil du weiter casten
kannst.
Und, also
wenn das hier jetzt ein gegnerischer Caster
Bogenschütze oder sowas wäre, dem wäre das egal, ob der
gerootet ist, der kann trotzdem auf mich schießen.
Und,
äh, jeder, jeglicher Damage
bricht das CC aber.
Echt, mit wem
kannst du Root heilen?
Es gibt
keinen Deroot oder sowas.
Du kannst
Dead oder sowas backen.
Oder, ähm...
Ach, stimmt! Du hast recht!
Das hab ich gar nicht dran gedacht. Ja, hast recht.
Ja.
Ja. Und, und
tatsächlich, ich glaube sogar, es gibt
ein paar RR5-Fähigkeiten,
die anti-CC mäßig sind.
Der Skull hat auch irgendeine anti-CC-Geschichte
auf RR5. Stimmt, da hab ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Ja, ja, ja. Stimmt, Mann.
Das ist aber auch was, was es früher tatsächlich
nicht gegeben hat. Das haben die ja später eingeführt.
So, und das war's. Das war's eigentlich.
Äh, da gibt's noch eine kleine Spezialität, die
ich aber nicht benutze.
Man kann sein Ziel
debuffen. Ich zeig euch das mal. Guck mal hier.
Jetzt mach ich kaum Damage drauf.
So gut wie nix. 266,
resisted,
240, 208,
so. Ich mach kaum Damage drauf, okay?
So, ziemliche Varianz. Jetzt debuff ich
den und mach nochmal den gleichen
Spell drauf.
350, 668,
233, 567.
Also die Varianz ist halt trotzdem
groß, weil ich das nicht geskillt hab.
Aber ich kann
Kälteschaden, Hitzeschaden
und Materieschaden um
50% die Resistenzen senken.
Lohnt sich bei mir allerdings für mich
selbst nicht, weil
das hier kommt aus
der Darkness-Skill-Linie und
Darkness hab ich nichts geskillt.
Ich hab Runecarving
und Suppression geskillt.
Runecarving ist das für die Bowls.
So. Und das war's.
Mehr hat der Runi nicht.
Ich hab noch ne
ne, wie heißt das?
Realm-Mobility.
Da kann ich auch ein Crown-Target setzen
und dann TWF casten.
Sieht dann so aus. Dann kommt hier sowas.
Und alles was da drinne
steht, bekommt
ein bisschen Damage. Wie ihr seht,
alles was da drin steht und feindlich ist,
bekommt Damage. Der Damage ist aber gar nicht
so das Ding, sondern die werden auch
geslowt. Die laufen 40%
glaub ich langsamer da drin.
Das ist auch sehr praktisch, gerade für irgendwelche
Belagerungssachen, weil es auch durch alles durchgeht.
So. Das war's.
Mehr hat nen
Runi nicht. Also Runi ist eines der most
straight
forward und
unproblematischsten Klassen im ganzen Spiel.
Ah, ich muss
zum König jetzt wieder.
Runi finde ich ist auch ne super
Einstiegsklasse.
Runi ist ne super Einstiegsklasse.
Also ich finde,
das Spiel hat ein paar
gute Einstiegsklassen, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich habe im Chat gesehen,
dass ein paar Leute tatsächlich gerade
runterladen und sowas.
Lasst euch mal zwei Sachen gesagt
sein. Erstens, ihr müsst
ein bisschen reinkommen. Dark ist nicht sonderlich
einsteigerfreundlich, weil es halt keine Sachen gibt,
die einem das erklären.
Es sind halt auch viele Sachen nicht sonderlich
attraktiv. Ja, zum Beispiel, dass Geschicklichkeit
Castspeed ist und nicht Geschwindigkeit
Castspeed ist.
Was eigentlich keinen Sinn macht, aber es ist halt so.
Also man muss sich da ein bisschen dran gewöhnen.
Das ist aber auf Eden kein Ding, weil ihr auf Eden ganz viele
Übungsgebiete habt,
wo ihr da relativ schnell reinkommt.
Aber man darf
nicht komplett abgeschreckt sein von
bisschen clunky
Bedienung. So.
Und dann...
Ah ja, das habe ich ganz vergessen zu erwähnen. Stimmt, was das hier ist.
Das hier ist ein Spell, den habe ich
gar nicht gezeigt. Das hier ist ein
Spell für
Anti-Nahkampf.
Da kriegt man...
Kann man sich so eine...
Wie heißt das?
Ein Runic Ward geben, der absorbiert
einen Nahkampftreffer.
Ne, neue Models mag ich nicht.
Neue Models mag ich nicht.
Gecox, habe ich dich nicht gerade
in...
Am Trainingsdummy gesehen? Du bist doch gerade an mir
vorbeigelaufen, oder?
Ne, neue Models mag ich nicht.
So, und du hast das gleiche
noch. Das gibt es für mich Single Target.
Das hast du noch für
Gruppe, was sich alle 10 Sekunden
erneuert.
So.
Ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
Hm.
Kurz auf meinem Skalbe was schauen. Ach ne, da steht noch
DF, oder?
Ist der noch DF?
Wenn der noch DF ist, dann lasse ich den auch DF
geparkt.
Der ist noch DF. Ne, den lasse ich DF geparkt.
Dann gucke ich später, ist egal.
Ich wollte gerade was in meinem Vault gucken,
aber ich will den nicht aus DF rauspacken.
Weil...
DF ist nicht uns.
Spielst du mit neuen Models?
Also ich mag die neuen Models nicht.
Dass ihr es mal gesehen habt,
passt mal auf, neue Models.
Das ist das alte Model, das sieht halt wirklich aus wie 2001.
Dann gibt es neue Models.
Wo geht denn das überhaupt einzuschalten?
Skin Choice.
Ne.
Was ist das denn überhaupt?
Hier.
Genau, ich habe alles auf Classic geschaltet.
Schalten wir mal auf Catacombs.
Und jetzt sieht es so aus.
Sieht auch nicht wirklich besser aus, oder?
Sieht halt ein bisschen
moderner aus jetzt.
Reicht
eine Grafikkarte für das Game ganz knapp.
Ganz knapp.
Sieht halt ein bisschen moderner aus.
So sieht
mein Huni aus in den
neuen Models.
Ich finde, ich mag die neuen Models nicht.
Schwer zu sagen.
Ich finde, die sind nicht so
im
Geister der alten Models.
Ich mag die alten Models mehr.
Classic Models.
Aber, um mal auf die andere Sache
zurückzukommen.
Solo-Stelzer.
Und weil ich
gesehen habe, dass ein paar Leute
gesagt haben, ich lade mal runter.
Also, wie gesagt, lasst euch nicht so sehr
dadurch schocken, dass es ein bisschen
schwierig ist, da reinzukommen.
Dark hat viele Sachen so, du weißt
es oder du hast verloren.
Man muss sich da dran gewöhnen, aber meistens
hast du es, wenn du es gesehen hast, checkst du es schon.
Aber viele Sachen sind halt nicht
klar, wie gesagt. Also, jemand, der
neu ist, der weiß zum Beispiel nicht, was
die Sachen hier zum Beispiel machen.
Es gibt auch keine gescheite
Erklärung ingame dafür, was Stats
angeht. Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist
es aber so, wenn du einen Char anlegst,
haben die zumindest halbwegs,
halbwegs sinnvoll
vordefinierte Start-Stats.
Das war ja am Anfang auch nicht so.
Und wenn du damals gefragt hast,
hey Hersteller, wie soll ich
meinen Char skillen, da haben die dir Ratschläge
gegeben, da war es verskillt am Ende.
Ja, und es gibt ganz
viele kleine Sachen so in Dark, wo man
sich dran gewöhnen muss. Zum Beispiel,
ich wollte das ja immer
zeigen, zum Beispiel die
Casting und Interrupt-Mechanik.
Ist halt auch so ein Ding, das ist
man aus moderneren Games
gar nicht gewöhnt.
Äh, fertig?
Hagal! Okay,
also kommt jetzt dieser Krempel.
Ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Da müssen wir uns irgendeinen,
uns irgendeinen 0815-Mob
schnappen und uns mal hinten
lassen. Ja.
Das habe
ich den Leuten versucht auch
zu erklären, dass das Game mal einfach das beste
best Game ever ist, weil man PvP-Games
mag. Und gerade durch den
dynamischen Ansatz ist quasi fast
kein Tag wie der andere.
Okay, äh,
zack.
Und es hat sicherlich ja auch noch mehr Aspekte.
Es gibt Leute, die stehen eher darauf, das Spiel solo
zu spielen. Es gibt welche, die
flitzen gerne in
mit 80 plus Mann
rum und zergen alles
weg. Du hast Leute, die spielen gerne
Duo. Du hast Leute, die spielen gerne
mit 3, 4, 5 Mann. Du hast Leute,
die spielen gerne als Achtergruppe. Du kannst
eigentlich alles in dem Spiel
machen, wie du gerade Bock hast.
Sofern du, sofern du, und das ist halt die
Voraussetzung irgendwo, sofern du
PvP ein bisschen was abgewinnen kannst.
Aber ich muss sagen, ganz ehrlich,
die übelsten
Casuals in Dark
spielen PvP. Das ist das einzige
Game, was ich kenne,
das selbst die 0815
nicht Snoops überhaupt dazu
gebracht hat, PvP zu machen.
Also die Leute, die WoW spielen
und den ganzen Tag nur craften,
oder den
40. Chart
winken oder so, anstatt es mal irgendwie
PvP zu machen,
spielen in Dark PvP. Also
ich habe noch kein Game
erlebt, wo wirklich jeder
PvP gespielt hat.
Selbst die Oma
spielt da PvP. Ich meine,
die spielt jetzt bestimmt kein irgendwie
King of the Hill mit Achtergruppe oder sowas,
aber die,
ich meine, wenn ich gucke,
was für Leute da teilweise abends in der
Midgard-BG dabei sind. Ich glaube,
der Älteste ist 75 oder so.
Also, das sind die richtigen
Opas am Start.
Sogar nicht spielen PvP. So, was ich euch
zeigen wollte, wir brauchen mal einen Mob, der nicht ganz so viel
Damage macht, please. Irgendwie.
Irgendwas Blaues oder Grünes
oder so, ja. Also ich, ich,
ich versuche mal, was zu
zeigen, was so die Caster-Mechanic
in Dark halt...
Braucht das was?
Decks? Bonus-Decks?
Ah, Resi-Pierce.
Das weiß ich gar nicht,
ach, das hat auch Decks-Bonus.
Nö, dann, dann schmeiß ich den in den Vault.
So, normalerweise ist man es ja gewohnt,
so, aus
neueren MMOs und Games,
wenn man auf Gegner zaubert,
dann, ich muss mal gucken, dass ich den jetzt nicht kille,
so, ich zauber jetzt auf den Gegner,
so, und irgendwie habe ich den nicht tot gekriegt,
bis der an mich ran ist.
Da kriegst du epileptische Anfälle, wenn
du dir den Gegner anguckst. So, und jetzt ist das
Problem, der macht ja ziemlich Damage,
wenn er an mich rankommt.
Guck mal hier, wenn der mich hittet,
hat jetzt dreimal vorbeigehauen,
oder einmal hat's gebraucht. Guck mal, der macht ja ganz schön Damage.
Und normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen, ah ja,
ich cast jetzt einfach so lange weiter,
bis der Gegner tot ist. Das Problem ist, ihr seht's
vielleicht schon, ich kann nicht casten,
solange der Gegner an mir dran ist.
Das heißt, als Caster musst du wegrennen,
und dann kannst du wieder casten.
Und das ist
nicht nur gegen Monster so,
das ist auch gegen Spieler so.
Und das ist so
ein ganz eigenwilliges System,
wo ich auch schon
wo ich auch schon viele Leute im
Advice-Chat und so gesehen hab, so
ich bin Level 1 Shummy
und krieg keine Gegner tot und sowas.
Und da musst du ihnen halt sagen, ja, du musst Damage machen,
ein Stückchen Kite und Damage machen und sowas.
Oder am besten mit Gruppe spielen.
Also,
ich wollte eigentlich die Quest abholen.
Also ich hab nicht 25 Jahre
am Stück gespielt, ich hab
ultra viel gespielt, früher,
bis ungefähr
2000,
ganz knapp 2010.
Inklusive OS-Server dann auch, als sie
der Classic-Server in EU dichtgemacht hat.
Danach hab ich, hatte ich keinen
Bock mehr, aber als
dann immer mehr Free-Shards aufgekommen
sind, hab ich wieder angefangen.
Ich weiß nicht, was der
erste Free-Shard war, den ich ausprobiert hab
in Dark, könnte Dings gewesen
sein, wie ist das, äh, ähm,
nicht Origin, äh,
Genesis, glaub ich war das.
Das war 2015 oder sowas.
Und seitdem bin ich eigentlich auch
permanent auf Free-Shards am Start.
Ich, ich, ich cryne das vielleicht nicht unbedingt
jetzt ein ganzes
Jahr durch, weil gerade wenn die Spielerzahlen
droppen und sowas,
irgendwann, irgendwann hab ich dann auch
keinen Bock, da irgendwie großartig,
aber du kannst,
eigentlich gerade mit dem Season-Ansatz
von Eden, find ich, find ich super, äh,
super nice gemacht, kannst theoretisch
ein halbes Jahr immer schön Dark
cryen. Dann machst du ein bisschen Pause
und dann spielst du wieder ein halbes Jahr.
Find ich, find ich super.
Also, ein Monat vom halben Jahr
ist schon rum.
So.
Mist, ich bin Solo, jetzt muss ich da hinrennen.
Das ist ja kacke.
Ich hab nen, ich hab nen
Char in TG stehen, wo ich porten
könnte, aber...
Any need, oh, ich brauch
TG-Port. Heilolga.
Heilolga hat nen Port.
Heilolga, beste.
Heilolga, porte mich nach TG.
Excellent, Poggers.
Ich hoffe,
ich hoffe Heilolga
kann sich...
Oh ne, Heilolga hat ausgelockt.
Jetzt ist er offline.
Na super.
Any need Port und lockt aus.
Och geil.
Machen die Epic?
Machen, machen die Epic?
Die machen aber wahrscheinlich den
Skull Step. Jetzt muss ich da hinrennen,
da hab ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ne, ne, ich mach kein TG.
Ich wollt nach TG porten,
um da wieder rauszugehen, um den
Quest Step, äh, Quest Step zu erledigen.
Jetzt muss ich da hinrennen.
Ich hab nen Char in TG
geparkt, dass ich da relativ
easy Leute hinporten kann, aber das
Dumme ist halt, ich kann mich selbst mit nem anderen Char
auf meinem gleichen Account nicht hinporten.
Die Musik ist nice.
Das ist keine Dark-Musik, das ist ne
Fantasy Village
Playlist von Youtube.
Weil Dark eher nervige Sounds hat.
Ja, ich wollte euch noch was zeigen
und zwar, weil jetzt ein paar Leute gesagt haben,
sie wollen nichts runterladen, mal angucken.
Also wie gesagt, erstmal lasst euch nicht so sehr abschrecken
von
vielleicht der ein oder anderen Unzulänglichkeit.
Auf Eden ist es schon deutlich besser,
wie es früher gewesen ist.
Lasst euch auch nicht abschrecken von manchen
Dummschwätzern im Chat. Das ist ganz normal.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was die Leute haben
in nem 20 Jahre, 25 Jahre alten Game
immer.
Gibt's schon ein paar weird Leute.
Gerne komplett sinnlos.
Gibt's
schon ein paar komische Leute.
Gerade
wenn dann irgendwelche neuen Leute im Chat
fragen um Hilfe und dann kriegst du ne
total bescheuerte Antwort so.
Zum Beispiel, letztens hat irgendeiner gefragt
so, ich bin Level 1 Shummy und krieg
keine Mobs tot. Das Problem war halt,
weil er immer unterbrochen wird,
weil er die Interrupt-Mechanic
von Dark noch nicht kannte.
Und dann haben halt wirklich Leute zu ihm
geschrieben, ihr Just-Delete-Character
und sowas. Wo du halt denkst,
Alter, wie kackspastig muss da eigentlich drauf sein?
Irgendjemand, der offensichtlich
das Game neu spielt,
willst du nicht, dass Leute das neue Game ausprobieren
oder was? Und dann feiern
sie sich im Chat auch immer noch übelst dafür ab.
Man muss sich überlegen,
dass die Leute, die spielen das Game 25 Jahre
lang. Die haben das Game schon gespielt,
wie die Jungen waren. Das heißt, die waren damals
ungefähr, sagen wir mal, 16 bis 20,
so wie ich, und die sind heute 40.
Warum musst du mit 40 Leuten,
warum musst du mit 40
auf nem Free-Chart
in nem MMO
irgendwelche Neueinsteiger
verarschen, um dir dann geil
vorzukommen? Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Das ist auch so ein Ding in Dark,
es gibt so ne,
es gibt schon ein paar sehr weirde Leute.
Was aber irgendwie in jedem
MMO ist. Und in Dark
kommt dann noch dazu, dass du
so viele Möchtegern-Elite-Leute hast.
Also ich meine, dass nicht Leute, die wirklich gut
in dem Game sind, die sind
meistens gar nicht so unumgänglich,
sondern so Leute, die
eigentlich übelst reinzacken,
aber so tun, als sind sie die übelsten Pros.
Die gehen mir immer auf den Sack.
So, eigentlich wollte ich euch
jetzt noch was zeigen, für alle, die sich doch überlegt
haben, sich das mal anzugucken, nämlich
was gute Einstiegsklassen sind.
Problem ist nur,
ich muss jetzt mal gucken, dass ich nirgends wo reinrenne,
sonst bin ich dead.
Trimakurs, Alter, das hab ich schon ewig nicht mehr gehört.
Die alten Dark-Videos mit
640x480 und 5 FPS,
gell?
Ich hab nen Fight gestern aufgenommen in der BG.
Irgendwie 180
Mids gegen 200 Hips und sowas.
Das ist glaube ich auch das, was neue Leute
cool finden. Ich glaube nicht, dass
die meisten Leute
das tun.
Damals hatten die Nightwish immer im Hintergrund
genau. Oder, oder auch
der beliebteste Song ever
bei irgendwelchen Montages,
könnt ihr euch vielleicht früher auch noch dran erinnern.
Down with the Sickness. Kennt ihr das noch?
Bei jeder Montage war
das drauf.
Oder, oder
Let the bodies hit the floor.
Das war auch früher immer bei jeder Montage dabei
oder bei jedem Video.
Vielleicht hast du vorhin schon was geschrieben und ich hab's bloß nicht gesehen.
Hast schon gelevelt.
Das war jetzt auch Dark-Speak,
was keiner versteht.
Es gibt in Dark ne Klasse, die
nennt sich Donnerkrieger und in Deutsch wird der immer Döner
genannt. Hast du nicht?
Okay. Wie gesagt, wenn du willst, sag Bescheid.
Skalde ist 50 für Speed.
Ich kann auch was mit dir leveln. Können wir ein bisschen
im BG bashen.
Aber ich hab eigentlich jetzt alles, was ich
haben will. Ich hab meinen Skalde, ich hab meinen Shami,
ich hab meinen Runi jetzt, der braucht
noch ein bisschen Equip.
Den Heiler fürs BG.
Und den BD zum Farmen.
Also eigentlich hab ich alles am Start.
Du warst im Urlaub. Moment, Moment.
Ist nicht der Urlaub
die Zeit, wo man eigentlich
sowas macht?
Oder meinst du im Urlaub
so wirklich im Urlaub, also so
so irgendwie an der frischen Luft
im Urlaub so irgendwas?
Das ist schon ganz schön cringe, wer das macht.
So richtig Urlauber.
Ja, ja, ja.
Sachen gibt's.
Jetzt seht ihr die Spells auch mal
an normalen Mobs.
Also ihr seht, die zwei Balls two-shotten
den Gegner fast schon.
Also gucken wir uns mal kurz, während ich
auf meine Balls warte.
Dog.
Classes.
Classes and Races.
Ne, ich will eigentlich die
Classen annehmen.
Okay, die offizielle
Seite ist ja mal wieder
mega hässlich.
Ist da nicht irgendein Wiki?
Ja, doch. Besser. Wiki.
Ja, das ist eine viel bessere Übersicht.
Auf, gib ihm.
Habe ich schon irgendwas gespeckt,
um noch ein bisschen mehr Damage rauszuholen?
Ah ne, ich hab nichts mehr frei.
2L2
6.
Wild Power oder sowas schon.
Wild Power 3. Gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Muss ein bisschen Damage machen.
Wind und TWF1.
Ja gut, mehr kannst du mit 2L2 auch nicht machen.
Wo bleiben denn die Crits?
Crit-Chance
ist gar nicht so, gar nicht so klein
gerade. Also ich habe eine Crit-Chance von
9 plus 5.
14%.
14% Crit-Chance.
Ziemlich gut. Für so low,
für so low RR-Rank.
Aber ihr seht das,
sobald es ein Crit, okay das könnte ein Crit
gewesen sein.
Ja, guck mal, Crit.
Ihr kennt, der hat hier
578 gemacht
und nochmal 529 Crit.
Der ist einfach geplatzt beim zweiten Bolt.
So sieht das also aus, wenn die Bolts
Critten. So.
Aber, jetzt wollte ich eigentlich
euch was zeigen. Also falls jetzt wirklich irgendjemand
Bock hat und denkt, ey, mal gucken.
Vielleicht ist das ja was, was mir Spaß macht.
Dann
gibt es ein paar Klassen, wo ich denke,
die sind ganz gut für den Einstieg.
Und es gibt auch ein paar Klassen, wo ich sagen würde,
die sind überhaupt nichts für den Einstieg.
Dann könnt ihr euch überlegen,
in welchem Reich ihr spielen wollt.
Wollt ihr Albion spielen?
Wollt ihr Midgard spielen?
Oder wollt ihr Hibernia spielen?
Ich kann mich theoretisch sogar mal
in den unterschiedlichen Reichen einloggen.
Also das hier ist Midgard.
Da ist alles relativ
schneebedeckt.
Und
ein bisschen trister.
Das orientiert sich so ein bisschen an Norwegen
und sowas.
Dann Albion.
Orientiert sich eher an mittelalterlichem England
und Hibernia, wie gesagt, mittelalterliches
so Schottland, Irland
so in der Richtung. Also ist sehr grün
alles.
Und wenn ihr euch für ein Reich
entschieden habt, ihr habt Glück.
Auf Eden kann man
alle drei Reiche spielen.
Auf Live war das so,
man musste sich
auf einem Server für ein Reich entscheiden.
Man konnte zwar Server wechseln und dort ein anderes Reich spielen.
Aber auf einem Server
war man festgelegt. Hier ist es
so, du kannst im Prinzip in allen Reichen
spielen.
Was du nicht machen kannst ist,
von einem Reich PvP
ins andere Reich PvP direkt wechseln.
Da hast du glaube ich 60 Minuten
Timer. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
60 Minuten Timer. Was aber auch sinnvoll ist.
Ja.
Weil es halt Endgame PvP ist.
Und du hast
ein Loyalty
Bonus. Also wenn du
PvP nur in einem Reich spielst,
sammelst du quasi jeden Tag
1% Bonus.
Punkte.
Also 1% Bonus sammelst du jeden Tag.
Und
irgendwann hast du dann bis zu 50% Bonus.
Und bekommst dann
50% mehr
Punkte für PvP.
Wenn du in dem Reich weiterspielst.
Finde ich gut gemacht.
Die verbieten einem nicht woanders zu spielen.
Aber es hat gewisse Anreize.
Was du ohne Probleme machen kannst ist,
alle 3 Reichen PvE,
Character Leveln und Battle Crowns
spielen.
Da passiert
deiner Loyalty
nichts.
Das heißt ihr könnt ohne Probleme
einfach alle 3 Reiche mal ausprobieren.
Was euch da besser gefällt.
Was euch optisch besser zusagt.
Ehrlich gesagt würde ich gar nicht so sehr nach Optik
der jeweiligen Realms gehen.
Sondern welche Klassen euch gefallen.
Jetzt wir.
Wir werden am Start
erzählen.
Ich würde ehrlich gesagt
tatsächlich ein bisschen nach der Klasse
gehen worauf ihr Bock habt zu spielen.
Und es gibt ein paar ganz gute Einstiegs.
Habe ich jetzt die eigentlich schon fertig hier?
Einen.
Einen muss ich noch killen.
Was die Loyalty sinkt im BG?
Ernsthaft?
Kannst du nicht BG spielen so viel du willst?
Loyalty sinkt noch nicht im BG?
Ich will es jetzt mal nicht ausschließen.
Also du hast ein 500
oder 250 RP pro Tag
die du in einem anderen Reich machen darfst.
Aber ich dachte das excludet
komplett Battlegrounds.
Wir müssen jetzt diese komischen Eier sammeln.
Ja also wahrscheinlich ist es am besten dort
zu spielen wo es eine Klasse gibt auf die man Bock hat.
Und
wir kommen uns das jetzt mal ganz
schnell an.
Und ich sag mal meinen Senf zu was ich für gute
Einsteigerklassen halte und was ich
als echt schlechte Einsteigerklassen
halte. Ich mach mal kurz hier mal
in den Town Portal hin falls ich verrecke.
Falls ich gerade im Browser bin.
Während ich hier irgendwie abgefarmt werde.
So ich glaub die Viecher muss ich killen jetzt.
Gleich mit nem Bolt?
Ah doch hier.
Bäm in Ass geboltet.
1 und direkt 1 von 5.
Also.
Gucken wir uns mal kurz die Klassen an.
Wir machen das ganz schnell.
Ich hab das in einem der letzten Streams schon erzählt.
Ich würde euch nicht empfehlen einen Nahkampfcharacter
als ersten
Char zu erstellen.
Nahkampf in Dark ist
eine Sache für sich. Da muss man
meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen
den Flow drauf haben.
Ich mag Nahkämpfer nicht als
Einstiegsklasse. Ich finde da muss man ein bisschen den
Flow drauf haben. Das Problem ist
Leute die Nahkämpfer spielen und neu in dem
Game sind, die haben extremen Tunnelblick.
Die sehen den Gegner und rushen einfach
und sind nur tot. Das macht keinen Spaß.
Und
also wenn du Nahkämpfer spielst
dann muss man ein bisschen checken wann man pushen
kann und wann man nicht pushen kann.
Und das checken
Leute nicht die neu sind.
Das checkst du beim zweiten oder dritten Char erst.
Wenn du ein bisschen PvP Erfahrung hast.
Musst du dir das mal angucken. Leute die neu sind
die sehen den Gegner. Stellt euch vor
hier. Stellt euch vor das hier wäre ein Gegner
und ihr seid Nahkämpfer. Die sehen den Gegner
sind in ihrer Gruppe. Ziehen die rum.
Attacke. Nahkampf. Gib ihm.
Und checken überhaupt nicht das die
Coup nicht hinterher kommt. Nicht mitgepusht wird.
Und eigentlich 18 Gegner um sie drum herum sind.
Und sie jetzt einmal angecastet werden und sind tot.
Also ich würde sagen ich finde
Nahkämpfer
nicht so sinnvoll als
Einstieg.
Letztendlich ist es wichtig eine Klasse zu nehmen
die euch anspricht. Aber ich würde sagen
so reiner Nahkämpfer
ist nicht unbedingt die beste
Einstiegsklasse. Und Armsman
ist ein reiner Nahkämpfer. Von der Armbrust
reden wir jetzt mal nicht. Armsman ist ein reiner Nahkämpfer.
Ähm
Kaba ist zum Beispiel finde ich eine ganz gute Einstiegsklasse.
Also wenn man Albion spielen
will ist Kaba ein ganz ganz nicer Einstieg.
Du hast ein Pet.
Das heißt du bist jetzt auch nicht immer komplett
verloren wenn mal ein Gegner an dich rankommt.
Beziehungsweise wir reden jetzt mal nur von PvE
an der Stelle. Wenn irgendein Monster an dich rankommt.
Du hast ein Pet.
Du machst mit der passenden Spec
relativ viel Damage und kannst auch sehr schön
in Zergfiles
leachen.
Insgesamt ist Kaba eine schöne Klasse.
Auch zum Einstieg
vielleicht nicht die beste.
Weil so ein paar Mechanics sind einem nicht ganz klar.
Ja zum Beispiel was macht solche?
Was macht Niersalm? Keine Ahnung man weiß nicht wie.
Ich muss debuffen, dass ich mehr Damage mache.
Aber ich finde Kaba ist, wenn man gerne
so ein bisschen Utility lastigen Caster
spielen will in Albion ist Kaba finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Cleric
ist eine super Einstiegsklasse meiner Meinung nach.
Wenn man auf Support steht.
Loyalität. Loyalität bringt
mehr RPs.
Und ich glaube und da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher.
Sogar mehr Currency. Ich glaube du kriegst mehr Currency
und mehr
auf jeden Fall
mehr RPs.
Wenn du in dem Realm RPs machst.
Wo du hohes Loyalty hast.
Achja und du kannst dir irgendwann
sogar so Loyalty Skins
kaufen.
Wenn du lange genug dabei warst.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was das Cap ist bei Loyalty.
50?
Oder gar 100?
Boah ein einfach
Schön dass du da bist.
Du hast heute ein
außergewöhnlichen
Tag erwischt.
Normalerweise halten sich die Gaming Streams
in Grenzen und vor allem
keine super 20 Jahre
alten MMOs.
Das ist nicht für jeden was.
Aber ich musste heute eh
viel Kreiselcrime machen und da
dachte ich mir ich mach das mal on stream.
Habe ich das jetzt eigentlich fertig?
Ne ich habe immer noch eins von
fünf. Na geil.
Aber wir machen das jetzt erstmal
kurz mit den Klassen weiter.
Wenn es Gaming ist dann in letzter Zeit.
Ich hätte echt mal Bock wieder auf
eine Runde Battlefield 2042.
Gerade jetzt
mit was ich, ich habe die letzte
Season mir noch nicht mal angeguckt.
Also wie gesagt
ganz praktische Einstiegsklasse wenn man
Albion spielen will und ein bisschen
Bock hat auf so Utility lastigen
Caster der aber auch gut Damage machen kann
und ein Pet hat. Ist eine schöne Allround Klasse.
Ich mag Cupba. Cupba ist eines meiner Lieblings
Klassen in Alb.
Ja tatsächlich Berghoff 2042.
Cleric für alle Leute.
Die gerne Support spielen ist Cleric
eines der besten
Klassen im ganzen Game.
Man muss Bock auf Support haben.
Support heißt
Gruppe heilen, Gruppe buffen
und ein bisschen
Support
Casting so. Ab und zu mal
Gegner stunnen und minimals
Damage vielleicht ab und zu machen.
Aber also mini, mini Damage.
Wobei man sagen muss von
allen Heilern kann der Cleric theoretisch noch am meisten
Damage machen. Aber
wenn man, wenn man auf
Support steht ist Cleric eines
der besten Einstiegsklassen und eines
der wichtigsten Klassen die es in Albion gibt.
Main Buffer, Main
Heiler
Buffscheeren, ja also super.
Also wenn man Bock auf Supporter hat
ohne den keiner spielen kann
ist Cleric genau das
richtige für euch. Also ich hab
live auch gerne gespielt
und ich hab sogar hier auf Alb eingelevelt.
Also für mich auch eines
der schönsten Klassen im Game.
Und auch eine super Einstiegsklasse.
Wenn man auf Support steht, ja. Wenn ihr jetzt jemand seid
der nur Spaß am Game hat, wenn er hohe
Damage zahlen hat. Warum leuchtet's denn
da oben rot? Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen.
Und da leuchtet's gelb?
Warum leuchtet's da rot?
Sekunde, das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Da war ich noch nie. Warum leuchtet's
da rot? Werden das leuchtet gar
nicht mehr rot wenn ich da ankomme?
Das ist bestimmt G-Bait.
Die verarschen mich bestimmt. Wahrscheinlich kommt man hier jetzt gar
nicht hoch.
Doch.
Sag mal, soll die Textur Vogelkacke sein?
Ich mein das ernst.
Weil hier sind so viele Vögel.
Soll das Erde mit Vogelkacke sein, die Textur?
Ich erkenn's nicht, weil die so...
Okay. Hier ist einfach random.
Hier ist einfach random rot.
Alles klar, habt ihr gut
gemacht, Dark Level Designer.
Warum ist hier rot?
Man weiß es nicht, es ist einfach rot.
Ist unbekannt, warum's da rot ist.
Aporets
Wohnung.
Also ich wär jetzt...
Da wär ich jetzt als letztes draufgekommen.
Bestimmt. Da läuft der
Insi-Modus. Für mehr als die hohe...
Für mehr als zu dieser Textur
reicht der Insi-Modus halt nicht, ja?
Es gibt
hier irgendwo an einem dieser Säulen auch
die mit Abstand schlecht
aufgelöstete Textur. Hier.
Im ganzen Game. Guckt euch das an, Alter.
Hahaha.
What the fuck?
Was bin ich sehend?
Was ist das?
Man weiß
nicht so genau.
Da war
Doom Hi-Rez dagegen.
Wir machen das gleich mit den Klassen weiter,
wenn ich die Mobs gekillt hab, weil
ich steh hier
mitten im Gebiet, wo quasi
Viecher rumlaufen,
die mich killen, wenn ich grade im Browser bin.
Deswegen machen wir die
jetzt mal platt.
Null Prozent, ja.
Drei von fünf. Zwei brauchen wir
noch.
Und dann müssen wir die
Quest im PvP-Gebiet machen.
Da hoffe ich, dass ich nicht
abgefarmt werde.
Nehm ich mir am besten noch ein paar
Leute aus der Gilde mit.
Weil Solo Huni mit Level Equip
ist halt jetzt nicht
so geil.
Cannot use while in combat. Bin auch geil,
kann ich in Combat. Lügt nicht, Game.
Und jetzt fünf von fünf,
please?
Ne, vier von fünf.
Ach ja, wir müssen aus welchen Gründen auch immer Eier
von den Viechern sammeln.
Und wie sammelt man Eier von den Viechern?
Natürlich, indem man sie killt. Logisch.
Wer kennt's nicht?
Also,
man muss auch immer seine Hühner umnuken,
wenn man Eier von denen will.
Vier von fünf, da kann ja mal
was droppen jetzt.
Just MMO-Logik.
Troppen, please.
Troppen, fünf von fünf. Jawoll, fünf von fünf.
Okay, geschafft.
Und jetzt muss ich zurück nach Hagal.
Sehr schön. Machen wir doch.
Minecraft China droppen auch beim killen.
Ah, okay.
Wissen wir ja. Wenn das in Minecraft so ist,
dann ist das die Referenz. Dann ist klar.
Aber ich mein, Minecraft war auch
früher. Dann versteh ich das schon.
Ey, die Leute sind teilweise
so wir im Kopf.
Man kann die so geil trollen.
Wenn du hier
im Chat schreibst,
so nach dem Motto
World of Warcraft war das erste
MMO.
Daog hat sich auch so vieles davon abgeguckt.
Dann hast du gleich Leute, die ankommen.
Ah, du erzählst Scheiße.
World of Warcraft war doch viel später.
War doch irgendwie 2005.
Und Daog war doch 2001.
Und was erzählst du für einen Blödsinn?
Und da musst du einfach weiter.
Musst du einfach weiter schreiben, so nach dem Motto.
Ich weiß es genau.
Ich hab's damals zur Release gespielt.
World of Warcraft war zuerst.
Die flamen dich.
Die wollen dich quasi förmlich umbringen.
Allein schon, weil du sowas schreibst.
Die checken es nicht, dass das einfach nur dummes
Gelaber ist.
Das ist so der
so obvious Troll,
wo man eigentlich gar nicht drauf
einsteigen sollte.
Das ist genauso, wie ich's in Overwatch
immer, oder generell, wie man die Leute
in Overwatch immer trollen konnte.
Wenn du sagst, hier, sag nichts dazu,
wenn du nicht hohen MMR hast.
Also mindestens 2000 plus.
Und wer es nicht weiß, 2000 plus MMR
Match Rating in Overwatch ist glaube ich Platin
oder sowas. Das ist mega schlecht.
Da springen die total drauf an.
Generell kannst du online die Leute
übelst triggern, wenn du schreibst
World of Warcraft war das erste MMO.
Es gibt Leute, die meinen das legit ernst.
Die sind dumm, aber
...
Wenn ich sowas blödes schreib, dann nur um die Leute
bisschen zu ärgern.
So, ich muss mal kurz Licht anmachen.
Gut, dass ich mein Home Assistant hab
und dafür nicht aufstehen muss.
Decke, Licht an, perfekt.
Also, jetzt bin ich hier rausgeportet,
jetzt kann ich mal kurz was dazu sagen.
Also wie gesagt, wenn ihr Albion spielen wollt,
Kaba,
guter Einstiegs-Char,
wenn man so auf Utility Caster und
generell Range DPS steht.
Cleric, wenn man auf Support steht,
ist das ein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Gerade in Albion ist
ein super, super
Beginner, auch beginnerfreundlicher
Char.
Da lernt man auch viel über Mechanics in dem Game
als Supporter, weil du drauf
angewiesen bist, dass andere Leute was für dich machen.
Ist aber auch sehr rewarding,
wenn man es kann und ist nicht schwer zu spielen.
Also Cleric ist wirklich nice.
So, aber als nächstes
auf Deutsch nannte sich das
Ordensbruder, diese Klasse.
Kann man sich jetzt streiten drüber,
ob es eine gute Einstiegsklasse ist oder nicht.
Es ist vielleicht mit die beste PVE
Geldfarm-Klasse in dem Spiel,
aber ich finde
jetzt nicht unbedingt die allerbeste Einstiegsklasse.
Die ist mir persönlich nicht universell genug.
Infi, auf jeden Fall keine
Einstiegsklasse, es sei denn, man mag Schleicher.
Würde ich aber niemandem empfehlen, einen Schleicher anzufangen.
Keine Einstiegsklasse.
Heretic finde ich auch keine allzu gute
Einstiegsklasse, mag ich allgemein nicht.
Auch wenn die gerade
Zerg-Fights ziemlich gut ist.
Ich mag Heretic nicht als Klasse.
Mauler gibt es auf jeden nicht.
Mercenary ist
ein reiner
Nahkampf-DPS-Damage-Dealer.
Finde ich ist keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Minstrel ist auf jeden Fall
definitiv keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Die brauchst du zwar überall,
ist eines der wichtigsten und
also Minstrel ist eines der besten Klassen im Spiel.
Wenn nicht die beste
Solo-Klasse, aber
und die universellste Solo-Klasse
auf jeden Fall.
Und auch in Gruppen ultra beliebt, aber
nicht gerade easy zu spielen.
Also keine gute
Einstiegsklasse.
Necro, super PvE Farming
Char, aber auch keine
wirklich erste Einstiegsklasse
wie ich finde, weil sie
in Gruppen jetzt nicht so geil ist.
Necro ist nicht meins.
Pala. Pala ist so ein Ding,
ganz viele Leute, die neu sind in dem Spiel
mögen Pala.
Ich glaube es gibt zwei Klassen in dem Spiel,
die alle Noobs spielen. Das ist
das Problem.
Leute die in Albion anfangen
machen sich gefühlt 90% in Paladin
und Leute die in Midgard anfangen
machen sich zu 90%
einen Donnerkrieger,
weil Tor und Hammer und sowas.
Man muss sagen,
von den ganzen Nahkämpfern
ist Pala vielleicht noch
der bessere Einstiegs-,
aber ich finde auch kein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Du musst relativ
auf relativ viel achten
mit deinen Auren
Es ist ein Nahkampf-Char
und ich finde generell
Nahkampf-Chars für Einsteiger nicht so gut.
Also Pala geht noch.
Pala würde eventuell, wenn man unbedingt
so auf Ritter-Rüstung
und sowas steht und was in der Richtung spielen will
Pala ist auf Eden nicht übel.
Pala hat auf Eden
jede Menge neue Sachen bekommen.
Aber
zum Beispiel kannst du mit Pala jetzt wenigstens
nennenswert 2-Hand-Damage machen auf Eden,
was auf Live nicht ging. Nur wenn man so
ein Typ mit Ritter-Rüstung unbedingt spielen will,
dann Pala. Aber ich finde es kein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Ansonsten muss man sagen, ist Pala
ein ziemlich guter PvE-Tank.
Wenn nicht der...
Ja, vielleicht nicht der beste...
Also einer der besten PvE-Tanks.
Aber ich finde für den Einstieg ist nicht gut.
Reaver...
kann man sich drüber streiten.
Sag mal, vielleicht
kein komplett reiner
Nahkampf-Char, aber alles nennenswerte
was der Reaver gut kann ist Nahkampf.
Die anderen Sachen sind eher so nebenbei.
Du hast so ein bisschen glaube ich
so ein Range-Live-Tap und sowas,
den du alle, frag mich nicht, 10 Sekunden oder so machen kannst.
Aber ist nicht...
Also man kann nicht sagen, dass Reaver
irgendwie ein Range-Charakter wäre.
Also Reaver ist ein Nahkampf-Charakter
mit Schild und Peitsche,
der mit seinem Backstyle
übelst Damage macht.
Ist cooler als Off-Tank.
Hm. Aber auch kein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Scout auch kein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Zog?
Eines der besten Caster
im Spiel, wenn ihr mich fragt.
Allein schon von den Möglichkeiten, die du hast.
Aber auch kein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Zog ist, finde ich, für mich eines meiner Lieblings...
meiner Lieblings...
Klassen, die es in dem Spiel gibt.
Also auf Alp level ich eigentlich
immer als erstes Zog.
Zog ist ein bisschen
wie Heiler, nur ohne heilen.
Zog ist ein cooler...
Ist ein mega, mega Charakter.
Du kannst... Du hast ein Pet,
du hast einen ziemlich fetten Nuke.
Je nachdem, was du
specst. Aber auch der Base-Nuke
ist nicht schlecht, also Single-Target-Damage.
Und du hast halt massig
Möglichkeiten,
was du machen kannst als
Zog. Du hast super hohen Cast-Speed,
du kannst Gegner unterbrechen,
du kannst Gegner sleepen, du kannst Gegner
Area sleepen, Area routen,
Single-Target routen,
ihre Zauber vergessen lassen.
Ist mega.
Ist eines der besten Klassen, die es
gibt im Spiel, aber finde ich nicht
gut als Einstiegsklasse.
Da finde ich Kaba als
Einstiegs-Caster tatsächlich besser.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Zog ein guter
Einstiegs-Char ist. Debuffs hast
du neuer. Also Zog ist sehr komplex.
Und man ist wahrscheinlich
als Einsteiger relativ schnell überfordert
mit einer Zog. Turk kann man als
Einsteiger spielen, finde ich. Turk ist ziemlich
braindead, gerade im BG.
So ziemlich der OP-ste Char mit den
Eispads, den es im BG gibt.
Das kann man spielen als Einsteiger.
Das ist ne Klasse, die kann Pads
beschwören. Die hat kein einzelnes Pad,
wie beispielsweise ne Zog oder ne Kaba
oder ne Minne, sondern Turk kann
Elementarpads beschwören.
Du hast Erdpads,
Eispads und
Erdpads.
Die Eispads casten,
die Luftpads
stunnen, die Erdpads halten
bisschen mehr aus, rennen schneller und unterbrechen Gegner.
Dafür hast du nen ziemlich starken Nuke.
Aber,
ich finde, die beste Einstiegsklasse in Albion
so blöd es klingt, wenn man Caster spielen will,
ist wahrscheinlich,
vor allem die einfachste, ist Wizard.
Wizard hat den höchsten
Single-Target-Nuke-Damage
ohne Debuffs, jetzt mal außen vor.
Und ist
ähnlich wie der Runi
zu spielen.
Du hast zwei Bowls, theoretisch
kannst du sogar bis zu drei haben, aber
der dritte ist nicht so der Rede wert.
Du hast Bowls,
du hast Single-Target-Damage.
Sogar noch
mehr als der Runi.
Und Wizard ist
simpel, super
für Battle-
Group-Fights, also irgendwie
50 gegen 50.
Super AE-Damage, super Range-Damage,
super Bowldamage
und easy zu spielen.
Mit Wizard hast du ungefähr so
viel belegt, wie ich auf der Leiste hier.
Du hast quasi die Hälfte der Leiste noch frei.
Du machst richtig krass
Damage und du bist
eigentlich überall begehrt, wenn es um
Zerg-Fights geht, mit größeren
Gruppen, weil AE-Damage und Wizard.
Also wenn man einsteigen will
und einen Caster spielen will, in Albion,
würde ich sagen, wenn ihr reinen
DPS-Range-Damage-Dealer
spielen wollt, spielt Wizard.
Ihr könnt Wizard übrigens auch super leveln,
dann aber nicht mit Feuer, sondern mit Eis.
Oder Cover.
Wer so ein bisschen
Utility-lastige Sachen mit Pet machen will.
Das sind zwei Sachen, würde ich sagen.
Für Supporter, Cleric.
Für Pet-Caster, Cover.
Für DPS-Caster, Wizard.
Also ich würde empfehlen, die drei
zum Einstieg in Albion.
Da kann man nicht viel falsch machen.
Alle drei sind mega beliebt in Gruppen.
Du kannst super leveln und
die sind nicht so kompliziert,
dass du gar nicht mitkommst.
So, Midgard-Klassen.
Bersi.
Reiner Nahkampf-Char würde ich nicht
als Einstiegsklasse wählen.
Vermutlich.
Ich habe jetzt keine Benchmarks.
Ich habe jetzt keine Tests.
Vermutlich dürfte
der Bersi der Nahkampf-Char sein
mit dem höchsten Burst-Damage.
Eventuell der Savage.
Also in Burst-Situation.
Der Bersi kann sich
in einen Bär verwandeln.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Und dann ist jeder...
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es jeder Schlag ist.
Ich glaube, es ist ein Krit.
Bersi ist eine reine Dual-Wheel-Nahkampf-Klasse.
Der aber auch
Zweihand ausrüsten kann.
Überlegt euch, ihr seid
gebufft bis oben hin, habt gutes Equip,
holt eine Zweihand-Waffe raus
und schlagt
mit jedem Treffer einen Krit.
Also Bersi kann richtig gut
Damage und auch richtig krassen
Burst-Damage machen.
Wenn ich eines der höchsten
Melee-Damages im Spiel für kurze Zeit
würde ich vielleicht sogar sagen,
der höchste Melee-Damage im Spiel für kurze Zeit
konstant, so über 20 Sekunden
oder so.
Aber Bersi ist eine reine Nahkampf-Klasse,
die auch außer Nahkampf-Damage nichts kann.
Gar nichts.
Dafür kann sie das ganz gut.
Und trotzdem finde ich
für Einsteiger nichts, weil reine Nahkampf-Klasse.
Bone-Dancer.
Bone-Dancer ist eine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Bone-Dancer dürfte bei
Caster neben Rooney
wahrscheinlich mit die beste Einstiegsklasse in Midgard sein.
Weil Bone-Dancer
ist easy zu leveln,
kannst du super Solo spielen,
du kannst alles killen,
was es gibt in dem Spiel als Bone-Dancer
mit deinen Pets und
du bist sogar noch
semi-gut
was PvP angeht,
selbst in der Level-Spec.
Da kannst du ein bisschen Dot rumspammen
und alles vergiften und kriegst ein bisschen Punkte zwischendurch.
Ich würde für reines
FvR vielleicht später
umspecken oder für Zerg-Fights vielleicht
was anderes nehmen.
Aber als Einstiegsklasse ist Bone-Dancer wirklich gut
um so die Mechanics vom Game zu lernen,
weil du bist relativ safe.
Du hast dein...
Ich kann euch das sogar mal zeigen.
Ich hab ja nen Bone-Dancer.
Bevor ich jetzt hier labere,
ich kann euch auch die Hexe mal zeigen.
Ich muss ja aber einen Grund haben,
dass ich so viel Zeug gelevelt hab.
Ich log mal kurz auf den Bone-Dancer um.
Suppression ist easy, aber ich würde Bone-Army
zum Leveln spielen.
Bone-Dancer.
Ich porte jetzt mal irgendwo hin.
Wo ist ein paar...
Die Weihnachts-NPCs könnte man vielleicht auch mal
wieder entfernen so langsam.
So. Jetzt zeige ich euch mal,
warum Bone-Dancer ein super Einstiegs-Char ist.
Wenn es denn irgendwann mal portet.
So.
Achso, ich hätte mir vielleicht mal Speed holen sollen.
Weil Bone-Dancer
hat kein Speed.
Superschnell.
Ich flieg jetzt mal kurz wohin, wo es Gegner gibt,
um ein bisschen mehr auszuhalten,
die nicht One-Hit sind.
So. Aber wie gesagt, meiner Meinung nach
Bone-Dancer eines der besten Einstiegs-Charts,
die es in Midgard gibt.
Weil sie, weil er ein bisschen
fehlertolerant ist
in gewisser Weise, ja.
Gerade wenn man Caster spielt und man ist neu in dem Spiel,
gerade wenn ihr beispielsweise mit Wizard oder so
anfangt, dann ist halt das Ding,
Wizard kann halt außer Damage nix.
Dafür ist Wizard simpel zu spielen.
Aber sobald ein Gegner oder halt ein Monster
an euch ran ist, müsst ihr wegrennen.
Ihr müsst nix machen. Ihr müsst wegrennen und dann
euch umdrehen, den Gegner umnuken.
Das ist mit Bone-Dancer...
Wie hieß, wie hieß, wie hieß das?
Hieß der Knochentänzer auf Deutsch?
Glaub schon.
Äh, ich muss...
Mal kurz runterjumpen.
So.
Also, warum Bone-Dancer eines der besten
Einsteiger-Charts in dem Game ist.
Ihr seid nicht alleine, denn
ihr habt ein Pet.
Und ihr habt nicht so,
wie viele andere Klassen,
in dem Spiel, ein Pet.
Nein, ihr habt bis zu vier Pets.
Und auch keine super Low-Level-Pets,
sondern
doch so ganz
annehmbare
Pets.
So, ich werd das jetzt gleich mal beschwören,
wenn ich hier mal ein paar Gegner gefunden hab,
auf die ich draufhauen kann.
Ich bin halt, ich bin halt super, super
geschwind grad. Hab ich, hab ich nicht
die Bounty Points?
Ne, ich hab hier kein Bounty Points Speed-Ding.
Ah, ich werd vielleicht mal holen
sollen grad. Na gut.
Dann müssen wir jetzt noch eine Minute
in die Richtung laufen, bis ich ein paar Gegner gefunden hab.
Auf!
Beweg dich!
Gib Gas! Da sind, da sind welche.
Okay, da sind, da sind rote.
Also die sind schon relativ hoch.
So, und als Bone-Dancer hast du einmal
deinen Commander-Pet.
Zu dem Commander-Pet kannst du bis zu drei weitere
Pets beschwören. Moin!
Anki, kannst du drei weitere Pets
beschwören?
Ich mach jetzt mal reine Nahkampf-Pets.
Dann kannst du deine eigenen Pets buffen.
Mehr Nahkampf-Damage, mehr Stärke.
Hab ich jetzt? Drei beschworen.
Dazu kannst du noch, wenn du Champion-Level
geskillt hast, kannst du sogar
noch deine Pets
Single-Target buffen.
Das
erspare ich mir jetzt mal,
weil das eine halbe Stunde dauert, bis ich gefühlt hier alle Pets
mit diesen Buffs versorgt hab.
So. Und dann
gehst du zum Gegner hin,
pullst den Gegner raus mit deinem Instant,
schickst die Pets drauf
und freust dich, dass du so viel Damage an roten
Gegnern machst.
Und wenn du Bock hast, kannst du sogar noch Dots drauf
machen.
Und er ist weg. Easy.
So. Und sollte dein Pet mal
sterben, oder
irgendwie low-life sein,
kannst du sogar noch selbst heilen.
So. Und aus dem Grund
Zeit-Bowndancer quasi alles.
Selbst, selbst wenn du drei rote
drei rote Mobs pullst oder so, ist das kein Ding.
Dann sagst du, hups, hups, ich hab
jetzt ein bisschen zu viele gepullt.
Da routest du mal einen, dann kann er sich nicht bewegen.
Der Typ kommt, da schickst du dein Pet drauf
und hier den nukest du um.
Du hast ja zusätzlich auch noch, darf man nicht vergessen,
du hast gar nicht so schlechten Single-Target
Damage als Bowndancer.
Also als Bowndancer bist
du Damage-DPS-
Caster,
AE-Dot-Spammer und hast
viele richtig gute Pets.
Und du hast
auch nicht so viele Skills, dass du nicht mehr
durchblickst, was du alles machen kannst.
Und dementsprechend finde ich, ist Bowndancer in Midgard
eines der wirklich richtig guten
Einstiegsklassen. Und
dazu kommt, Bowndancer ist gut
für Geldfarmen in PvE.
Vielleicht
eines der besten im Spiel, wenn's
um Money,
Money machen geht in dem Spiel.
Und er ist easy zu spielen.
Und es ist ein Caster mit ein bisschen
Abwechslung, weil du deine Pets hast.
Du kannst deine Pets auch umstellen.
Du kannst deinen Pets sagen, hier, ich will, dass
sie unterschiedliche Targets angreift, dass sie
das gleiche Targets angreift.
Du kannst sagen, hier, ich will, dass der Typ mit
Zweihandschwert rumrennt. Guck, jetzt hat er Zweihandschwert
und machte noch mehr Damage auf die Gegner.
Und so spielt sich Bowndancer mehr oder
weniger von Level 1 an.
Nur der Unterschied ist, dass ihr nicht gleich von Level 1 an
3 Pets haben könntet. Das gibt's erst später.
Und Bowndancer verzeiht relativ viel,
wenn ihr mal nicht aufgepasst habt.
Bowndancer ist ein super Farm-Char. Bowndancer
ist ein super Char in Battle-Crowns. Bowndancer
ist ein guter Char im
im RVR.
Also, besser, eines der besten
Einstiegs-Chars in Midgard, Bowndancer.
Danach gibt's Heiler.
Und ihr bedenkt euch jetzt vielleicht, ey, guck mal,
ich war noch so ein großer Fan
von dem Heiler in
Albion, quasi Clary,
als Einstiegs-Char. Ich würde
sagen, Heiler in Midgard nur bedingt
als Einstiegs-Char.
Du kannst Heiler auf zwei Arten spielen.
Du kannst Heiler auf
Heiler-Art spielen, oder
du kannst Heiler auf, sagen wir mal,
auf Hexe spielen.
Also als Main
Heiler, oder als
Main, sagen wir mal,
Main-Interrupter
Schrägstrich-Damage-Vermeider.
Und
wenn du Heiler als Main-Healer
spielst, ist das kein Ding.
Das ist ein sehr guter Einstiegs-Char,
genauso wie Cleric.
Das ist so eine Mischung aus
Buffen und Heilen.
Das ist ein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Da muss man sich auch nicht so viel Gedanken machen.
Aber, wenn du den als CC
spielen willst, oder als Main,
wie kann man das
jemandem erklären?
Wenn du Heiler nicht auf Heilen
speckst und auf Buffen, sondern auf diese
dritte Linie, dann bist du halt dafür zuständig,
dafür zu sorgen, dass die Gegner eigentlich kein
Schaden an dir machen können.
Und das ist eines der stressigsten und anspruchsvollsten
Sachen, die es in dem Spiel gibt.
Also ich würde sagen,
Heiler ist die schwierigste Klasse
im Spiel.
Wenn man sie so speckt.
Manche Heiler sind besonders abgedreht.
Mein Battleground-Heiler zum Beispiel,
der ist Tree-Spec.
Beziehungsweise speck ich
Tree-Spec, dann kannst du von allem ein bisschen was.
Dann fallen dir die Hände ab.
Also wenn du Heiler,
wenn ihr einen Char spielen wollt,
der sehr schwierig
zu meistern ist, dann ist Heiler
auf dieser Skillung euer Ding.
Aber als Einstieg auf jeden Fall nicht geeignet.
Definitiv nicht.
Du musst nahezu jede Dark Mechanic
wissen, dass du Heiler gut spielen kannst.
Wenn ihr Heiler
auf Buffen und Heilen speckt,
würde ich sagen, ist es
ähnlich zu empfehlen, wie ein
Clary zum Einstieg.
Wenn auch immer noch ein bisschen komplizierter,
wie ich finde, als ein Clary.
Ist aber auch ein ganz guter Einstiegs-Char,
wenn man eben nicht auf diese
ich brauche fünf Hände zum Spielen
Skillung geht.
Aber primär würde ich sagen,
dann vielleicht eher einen Clary,
wenn man auf Albion Bock hat.
Dark ist immer noch Bestgame, Bestgame einfach.
Wir gucken uns gerade die Character-Klassen an,
weil ein paar Leute gesagt haben,
sie wollen sich runterladen und
spielen. Wollte ich gerade mal ein bisschen
Senf dazu geben, was gute und schlechte Einstiegs sind.
Also Heiler, gute Einstiegsklasse,
wenn man auf Buffen und Heilen geht.
Sehr schlechte, wenn nicht die schlechteste
Einstiegsklasse im ganzen Game,
wenn man auf Puck geht, beziehungsweise
auf, wie nannte sich das auf Deutsch?
Die Skill-Linie befrieden, hieß das glaube ich.
Da haben sie
wieder zugeschlagen
bei der Übersetzung.
Nächster, Hunter,
keine gute Einstiegsklasse, Stelsa
gefällt mir nicht, Mauler gibt es nicht.
Runemaster, gute Einstiegsklasse.
Bisschen wie Wizard,
also
sehr vergleichbar mit Wizard, muss man eigentlich sagen.
Man könnte sagen,
Wizard und Runi sind
zumindest auf,
zumindest ein Feuer-Wizard und ein
Rune-Carving-Runi sind
obwohl sie
in unterschiedlichen Reichen sind,
sagen wir mal zu 80% die gleiche
Klasse, was du sonst
in Daog eigentlich nicht hast.
Bowndancer ist eine super Einstiegsklasse, ja?
Habe ich doch gerade gesagt.
Deswegen bin ich extra auf meinen Bowndancer gelockt.
Bowndancer ist eines der besten
Einstiegsklassen, gerade in Midgard.
So, wenn ihr sagt, ey,
also, Pet
und
Dots und so Zeug und so,
das ist alles nicht meins,
ich will eigentlich einfach nur einen Range-DPS-Caster,
der richtig gut Damage macht und im Zweifelsfall
auch mal Gegner 2 hittet,
dann müsst ihr Runemaster spielen.
Ist dementsprechend, habt ihr jetzt
auch schon oft genug gesehen,
ist dementsprechend auch relativ easy, ich lock mal wieder zurück.
Ihr seht ja hier meine Bowndancer,
Quick Bars, die sind mehr oder weniger alle voll.
Und
jetzt gehen wir mal auf meine,
gehen wir mal auf den Runi zurück,
den wir jetzt auch weiterspielen müssen, nämlich Epic machen.
Gehen wir mal, gehen wir mal auf den
Runi zurück.
Pox Champ.
Da werdet ihr sehen, da sind viel weniger
Quick Bars belegt.
Ja, viel weniger belegt.
Und Runi hat halt auch nur
im Prinzip diese 4 Spells.
Single Target Damage, Single Target Damage,
Area Damage.
Das ist was man wissen muss.
Im Prinzip wie der Wizard.
Also wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt
einen reinen DPS, Range DPS Caster,
der auch mal Gegner 2 shotten kann,
dann Runi, finde ich ist auch eine gute
Einstiegsklasse, wenn man auf sowas steht.
Savage,
ich sag mal,
auch wenn sich da die Spieler wahrscheinlich
jetzt aufregen werden und sagen, das ist doch was ganz anderes,
ist ein bisschen wie der Bersi.
Ohne Bersi zu sein,
ist eines der
Nahkampfklassen mit dem höchsten
Burst Damage im Game.
Ihr erkennt da vielleicht ein Thema.
Ursprünglich vom Designherr war Midgard eher so als
Nahkampf Realm gedacht.
Albion eher so als
Ritter und
Plattenrüstung und Hibernia
eher so als Magie Realm.
Es ist ein bisschen immer noch so, aber im Prinzip kannst du
eigentlich alle 3 Realms
auf unterschiedliche Arten spielen.
Also kannst du in Albion Nahkampf und Caster Gruppen machen.
Wobei, ähm,
ich sagen würde, eigentlich sind Alb-Caster Gruppen
schon sehr nice.
Du kannst in Hip Nahkampf
und Caster Gruppen spielen. Du kannst auch
in Mid Nahkampf und Caster Gruppen spielen.
Oder Hybrid Gruppen spielen, also
es geht beides.
Aber Savage ist insofern ähnlich wie Bersi
und das trifft die ähnlichen Sachen zu,
die ich gesagt habe zum Bersi.
Reiner Nahkämpfer
mit ein bisschen mehr Gimmicks als der Bersi.
Du hast ein paar Self-Buffs
und kannst ordentlich
Damage machen.
Ich spiele auf Iden.
Season 2, 3 Shards.
Also Savage ist keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Finde ich nicht gut.
Allein schon, weil es
Reiner Nahkämpfer ist.
Valkyrie, sehr stark.
Ja, ich denke, es hängt davon ab.
Es ist eine der
am wenigsten interessanten Klassen
für mich.
Ich spiele meistens nicht so
viele Melee Klassen.
Aber es ist schön, dass sie
die Catacombs-Klassen haben.
Ich verliere den Warlock.
Warlock wäre
sehr pock.
Aber vielleicht haben sie
den Warlock in Season 3.
Weil auf einer
der
früheren Iterationen
von Iden
es hieß Celestials,
hatten sie den Warlock.
Es sieht aus, als hätten sie
schon einen Warlock implementiert.
Aber sie wollten ihn nicht
in Season 2.
Ja, ich würde gerne
einen Warlock haben.
Okay, Leute.
Also wie gesagt, Savage keine gute
Einstiegsklasse.
Reiner Nahkampf-Char, gleiches Problem wie immer.
So, nächstes.
Shadowplate, Stelzer, vergesst's.
Auch keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Shami! Gute Einstiegsklasse.
Wenn ihr Bock drauf habt,
einen Heiler zu spielen,
der auch super nervig für die Gegner sein kann,
dann ist, und wie das passt,
ich habe sogar einen Shami am Start,
um euch was zu zeigen.
Weil ich ja irgendwie
einen krassen PvE-Grind gemacht habe die ganze Zeit.
Ich kann euch auch noch einen Shami zeigen.
Wenn ihr es jetzt mal auslockt.
So, Shami.
Wenn ihr Bock habt drauf, einen Heiler zu spielen,
aber euch ein Heiler
mit Buff-Heal
ein bisschen zu sehr Support ist,
dann ist vielleicht der Shami
für euch.
Der finde ich jetzt auch eine super Einstiegsklasse,
weil jeder braucht einen Shami in der Gruppe.
Weil, Main Buffer
in Midgard.
Main Buffer in Midgard.
Aber,
als Shami kannst du enorm nervig sein.
Porten wir mal wieder hier hin.
Als Shami kannst du enorm nervig sein.
Du hast ordentliche Kettenrüstung,
das heißt du hältst ein bisschen was aus.
Du kannst ganz passabel heilen
als Shami.
Du kannst super buffen.
Also du hast
einen ganz brauchbaren Single-Target-Heal hier.
Siehst du hier.
407 Punkte geheilt.
Das ist schon ganz okay.
Aber, was den Shami ausmacht ist,
du hast richtig gute Buffs.
Deswegen braucht jeder
in der Gruppe einen Shami.
Du hast richtig gute Buffs.
Du hast wichtige Resis.
Also, dass man mehr Resistenzen hat
hier gegen Hitze, Kälte
und Meta-Damage ist es glaube ich.
Braucht auch jede Gruppe.
Und du hast Endu,
dass die ganzen Nahkämpfer mehr Ausdauer haben.
Sehr wichtig.
Das sind die Dinger, jeder will einen Shami haben.
Und das Schöne am Shami ist,
im Vergleich zum Heiler,
du hast noch ein bisschen
Damage und du hast vor allem
den krassesten Nervfaktoren
im ganzen Spiel.
Du hast ein Ball, wo ein bisschen...
Oh, ich hab die Effekte aus. Kann das sein?
Du hast einen Bolt,
macht natürlich nicht so viel wie der Huni.
Hast einen Bolt,
kannst du Damage machen.
Du hast einen Dot, kannst du Damage machen drauf.
Und mit CL
hast du sogar noch ein bisschen Nahkampfschaden.
Also du kannst als Shami
auch ein bisschen was killen.
Aber das ist nicht unbedingt die primäre Aufgabe des Shamis,
was zu killen.
Die primäre Aufgabe vom Shami ist Support,
also quasi Sekundärheiler,
Buffen und Nerven.
Und ich glaube, es gibt
wenig, wenige Charakter,
also wenige Klassen in dem
Spiel, die so krass nerven können wie ein Shami.
Du kannst Buffs entfernen
von Gegnern.
Kannst Gegner,
wie soll man das auf Deutsch nennen,
verseuchen oder so.
Dann sind 50% weniger
effektive Heals aufsehen. Du kannst
Dotten, du hast eine E-Dot,
du hast eine E-Seuche. Du bist einfach
mega, mega nervig als Shami.
Also wenn man so
einen Hybrid haben will aus
Heiler, primär Buffer
und ein bisschen
DPS und Nerven,
ist Shami richtig gut. Und ich finde,
Shami ist auch eines der besten
Einstiegsklassen in Midgard.
Shami ist super.
Alle brauchen Shamis
und
ich finde, er macht auch mega Bock zu spielen.
Haben wir DF? Oh, wir haben DF!
Leute, ich erzähl
euch weiter. Ich sticke mal kurz.
Ich geh mal kurz
in DF rein.
Und...
Ja, wir haben DF.
Ich geh mal kurz in DF rein und greif ein paar Siegel ab.
Während ich hier eh nur rumstehe und am
Schwätzen bin.
Moment, was mach ich denn hier überhaupt?
Ja, DF.
Nein.
Dann machen wir weiter.
Skalde,
wenn ihr unbedingt einen
Nahkampfcharakter als euren ersten
Held spielen willst,
bist du gerade im BG, wenn ich richtig... Nein.
Ich bin gerade in SI gewesen.
Jetzt bin ich zurückgeportet
in unsere Grenzfestung
und geh nach DF.
Und in DF warte ich
bis... oder falls
die irgendwie
raiden wollen oder so. Da kann ich ein bisschen
Currency abgreifen, während ich eh nur am Schwätzen
bin. Ja.
Echt? Nach welchem BG sah's
aus? Vielleicht
ein bisschen Kartal Valley
an der... auf
der Mid-Seite. Vielleicht.
Aber...
Die Textur plopps.
Also Shami kann
ich euch wirklich nur wärmstens empfehlen.
Es hat auch einen riesen Vorteil Shami zu
sein, ja. Wenn ihr
Gruppen sucht... Ich bin gerade in die Battlegroup
gejoint. Leute.
Wie viel haben wir? 29 sind nicht so
viele. Ich warte
mal. Passt mal auf. Bis wir...
Ich zeig euch das gleich. Ihr
müsst in ne Battlegroup gehen und schreiben
Shami looking for group.
Es dauert 5 Sekunden.
Dann habt ihr 5 Group Invites.
Oh, da ist noch ein Upland.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich bleib mal kurz in DF
bis es losgeht.
Ja. Also dementsprechend
kann man Shami super empfehlen als Einstiegsklasse.
So. Skalde, wenn ihr
unbedingt nen Nahkämpfer spielen wollt. Also wenn ihr
euch jetzt selbst von meinem
Gelaber hier nicht habt
ausreden lassen, eine
Nahkampfklasse als eure
erste Klasse zu spielen.
Und ihr unbedingt mitkarrt spielen, dann
spielt in Skalde. Skalde ist easy.
Skalde ist gebraucht, weil Speed.
Und
Skalde ist zwar
Nahkämpfer, aber hat immer noch ganz gute
so Escape-Options, dadurch
dass du Speed hast. Ich würde es euch
trotzdem nicht unbedingt als
allererste Klasse
empfehlen. Aber wenn ihr einen
Nahkampfheld, also in
Nahkampfklasse spielen wollt,
dann nehmt Skalde in mit.
So. Spiritmaster
Ich persönlich finde Spiritmaster
eigentlich nie sonderlich
geil. Ist überhaupt nicht meine Klasse.
Ist ein Caster mit nem Pet.
Der ziemlich gut
Close-Range-Damage
machen kann. Oder auch Range-Damage.
Der im BG ziemlich
stark ist.
Gerade weil du Kobold wählen
kannst als Rasse und
recht hohen Cast-Speed auch
kriegst ohne gescheite Items.
Also
wenn man eine Pet-Klasse spielen will
zum Start in Midgard, gibt es ja nicht
viel zur Auswahl. Bone Dancer und Spiritmaster.
Dann würde ich immer Bone Dancer
vorziehen als Einstiegsklasse
versus Spiritmaster. Spiritmaster ist nicht schlecht.
Es gibt Leute, die schwören total auf
Spiritmaster. Und gerade im
größeren PvP
gibt es immer ein paar Groups, die
sich in Türme hocken mit Spiritmaster
und die verteidigen wollen. Ich bin
kein Spiritmaster-Fan. Ich sage es euch
ganz ehrlich. Wenn ihr diesen Style
mögt von Spiritmaster,
dann
würde ich eher
einen Ench spielen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall
keine super komplizierte
und miese Einstiegsklasse. Ich mag Spiritmaster
nicht. Ich sage es ganz ehrlich.
Ich werde eingeladen.
Guck mal, ich habe noch nicht mal
gefragt
nach
Gruppe und ich werde schon
eingeladen. Aber ich will jetzt
noch gar keine Gruppe.
Den größten Fehler,
den ganz viele Darknoobs
machen,
ist, sie fangen
mit Donnerkrieger an.
Weil
Donnerkrieger
Tor und Hammer und Blitze
und das finden alle total geil.
Und alle Darknoobs, die in Midgard
anfangen, die
Ich gehe wieder aus Group raus.
Ich warte jetzt, bis sie DF
gehen, während ich hier am Labern bin.
So, ich stelle mich auch mal auf AFK.
Also, viele Leute, die
neu in dem Spiel sind und Midgard anfangen,
die wollen Donnerkrieger spielen. Warum? Hammer,
Tor, Blitze und so und ganz furchtbar
geil.
Ich finde nicht, dass Donnerkrieger eine gute
Einstiegsklasse ist.
Manche werden sagen, ey, von allen
Tanks und so ist es auch die beste Einstiegsklasse.
Donnerkrieger ist ein
Nahkampf-Casting-
Hybrid,
der beides braucht,
der aber vor allem auch
ein bisschen Feingefühl
für die jeweilige Game-Situation braucht.
Donnerkrieger sind wahrscheinlich
die noobigste Klasse
in ganz Midgard,
die auch am meisten
gehasst wird, weil Donnerkrieger
dazu neigen, jegliches
CC mit nicht
Damage machenden Hammern
wieder zu brechen.
Also, wenn ihr beispielsweise
Hexe spielen oder Heiler spielt,
könnt ihr ja Gegner sleepen.
Und
das Problem ist,
das wird gebrochen durch Damage.
Und Donnerkrieger haben
einen Char-Plan
Arkaya.
Jetzt geht's aber los hier, Alter.
Dankeschön.
Übertreib mich, Arkaya.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Oder für die 10 Subs.
Dankeschön, hätte ich nicht mit gerechnet.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Sehr nice.
Ja, Donnerkrieger haben sowas hier
zum Beispiel. Direct Damage, AE
und, ähm,
sind das hier die Hammer?
Gar nicht so sicher.
Ich glaub, das sind die Hammer.
Zumindest ist das Problem an dem Damage
von Donnerkrieger,
es macht nicht viel Damage,
bricht jegliches CC und ist einfach nur abfuck.
Das heißt, als Donnerkrieger ist es sehr sinnvoll,
wenn man ein bisschen
Gefühl für das Game hat,
weil man muss
casten. Man ist gar kein
schlechter Caster. Man ist quasi
ein Tank mit Caster-Fähigkeiten.
Das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich...
Mir fällt, glaub ich, in keinem anderen
MMO ein,
so ein Hybrid wie Donnerkrieger, aber
es ist keine Noob-Klasse. Leider spielen
ihn fast alle Leute, die neu in Midgard
sind, machen sie als erste Klasse Donnerkrieger.
Aber ich finde, es ist keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Weil man ein gewisses
Gespür dafür haben muss in dem Game,
wann man was macht mit Donnerkrieger.
Und das hast du nicht, wenn du neu bist.
Hast du Tunnelblick. Ah, Gegner! Gib ihm!
Gib ihm! Gib ihm! Ah, Gruppe Gegner!
Hämmer rein! Hämmer rein! Und im Zweifelsfall,
wenn kein Mana oder man nicht richtig
casten kann, dann reinrennen und sterben.
Ich finde, Donnerkrieger ist keine gute
Einstiegsklasse.
Valkyrie
ist neu.
Gab es in Eden Season 1 nicht.
Ist ein heiler
Tank. Oder
nee, sagen wir mal, eher ein heiler
heiler
Melee
DPS
Hybrid. Ziemlich cool.
Gerade für größere
Fights. Du hast
Nahkampfangriffe, die aber Flächenschaden machen.
Also kannst du da super beispielsweise
in einem Turm Leute unterbrechen beim
Zaubern und sowas. Valk ist aber auch
so eine Klasse.
Du hast ziemliche Mana-Probleme als Valkyrie.
Ist eine super Klasse,
wenn man Duo spielen will. Ja, beispielsweise
Skald, Valkyrie und sowas. Super Duo.
Das macht aber niemand der Neues
in dem Spiel. Also ich würde auch sagen,
ich kühre keine allzu geile
Einstiegsklasse, weil
hauptsächlich Nahkampf.
Und auch von den
Sachen drumherum,
die man wissen muss, auch nicht
das Allereinfachste. Also würde ich sagen, ist nicht gut.
Warlock gibt es nicht. Warrior
ist die stumpfste
Nahkampfklasse im ganzen Spiel.
Warrior kann nichts außer drauf kloppen.
Warrior ist glaube ich so ziemlich
die einzige Klasse im ganzen Spiel,
die keine irgendwie
geartete Spezialität hat.
Ich warte bis
DF losgeht.
Jede andere Klasse hat irgendwie
irgendeine Spezialität.
Der Armsman,
der hat eine Armbrust und hat
ok, die Scheiße, die verwendet keiner, die muss ich nicht erwähnen.
Der Armsman hat die Möglichkeit
ähm
so helle Baden.
Was heißt denn Polearm auf Deutsch?
Polearm. Was?
Ostfriesisch?
Was?
Stangenwaffe. Stangenwaffe, genau.
Armsman kann als einzige Stangenwaffe
tragen und sowas. Aber der
Krieger, der hat nichts.
Krieger ist die langweiligste
Nahkampfklasse im ganzen Spiel.
Der kann... Moment, wo habe
ich denn meinen Scharplaner hier?
Es ist eine Nahkampfklasse,
deswegen fällt die schon mal für mich als Einsteigerklasse
raus, aber der Krieger
der kann nichts.
Ihr seht's, der hat ähm
kann Extraspecken,
Hammerspecken, Schwerterspecken, Schildspecken,
Parieren und Throwing Weapons, was niemand
verwendet. Nichts. Der hat nichts.
Das ist die, wenn du so willst,
die langweiligste Klasse,
die es gibt, aber
gleichermaßen einer der besten Tanks im Spiel
und
dadurch, und das haben sich die, das haben sich
die Hersteller auch schon, das hat sich der Hersteller auch schon gedacht,
der Krieger hat,
das wissen auch nicht alle,
der Krieger hat den höchsten Damage-Modifikator
im ganzen Game. Mit 2,3.
Der Hersteller hat sich gedacht,
die Klasse hat ja gar nichts.
Der müssen wir irgendwas
spezielles geben.
Also haben sie dem Krieger den höchsten
Damage-Modifikator gegeben. Das rettet
den Krieger meiner Meinung nach aber auch nicht.
Also wenn ihr einen ganz
stumpfen Fulltank spielen wollt,
der aber mit 2 Hand auch gut drauf
hauen kann, der aber sonst gar nichts
kann und super langweilig
ist meiner Meinung nach, dann Krieger,
aber allein schon weil's
Nahkampf ist, keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Akaya, Dankeschön, dass du
so viele Subs gegiftet hast
und dass du deinen Weg her gefunden hast.
Weiß nicht, hast du Twitch Empfehlungen oder über Youtube?
Heute bisschen was anderes, heute spiel ich
bisschen Oldschool MMO,
weil ich das eh gemacht hätte
und
okay, ich glaube die gehen echt nicht DF.
Ich mach, ich geh die Klassen hier fertig durch
und dann log ich wieder um und dann machen wir was, machen wir was anderes.
Wobei, ha, ich log jetzt schon um.
Die gehen nicht DF.
Ich log auf den Runi um,
weil ich muss, ich muss die Runi Epic weitermachen.
FVR, FVR, BG
FVR, das
mach ich heute Abend.
Wenn die anderen Leute am Start sind.
Jetzt werd ich mein Runi equippen.
Eigentlich wollte ich noch ein Template
noch ein
Template
für mein Runi austüfteln
heute oder irgendein fertiges nehmen.
Ich möchte jetzt nochmal,
bevor wir mit Midgard durch sind
und nochmal Subscribed.
Pok, sehr nice.
Dankeschön für die 11 Subs.
Bevor wir jetzt mit den
mit den Midgard Klassen durch sind
möchte ich nochmal kurz
zurückgehen auf
Heiler
und euch das mal kurz im Charplaner
zeigen. Oder bei der
Gelegenheit einfach auf meinen Heiler switchen.
Damit ich euch das mal kurz zeigen kann
was ich meine.
Das Heiler
eine gute Einstiegsklasse ist
oder die schlechteste die es gibt.
Je nachdem was man speckt.
Ich hab's ganz am Anfang des Streams schon mal kurz erzählt.
Der Heiler, das ist noch nicht die finale Speck.
Das ist übrigens, der bleibt 49 für immer.
Der Heiler, das ist für mich
Money Make Char
und Battlecrowned
Battlecrowned Charakter.
Der ist noch ein bisschen falsch gespeckt.
Der wird noch umgespeckt.
Das gibt noch 3 Punkte mehr, das gibt ein bisschen weniger
und dafür gibt's hier 18 dann. Egal.
Also das Ding ist
als Heiler, wenn du ihn so speckst
wie ich, nehm ich eben nicht als rein Buff Heal
ich hab nichts in Buffen
39 Heilen
36 Pack
auf Deutsch heißt diese Skilllinie
Befriedung. Wer auch immer sich
das so ausgedacht hat.
Du bist nicht nur Main Heiler
Du bist
Main Damage Vermeider als Heiler.
Und wenn ihr auf diese
Skilllinie geht
dann ist das der
meiner Meinung nach schwierigste Char im Spiel
und definitiv kein Einstiegs Char.
Ihr habt dafür alles was es an CC gibt.
Ihr habt Single Target Sleep
Single Target Stun
Area Stun
Single Target Root
Single Target Sleep
Single Target Stun
Area Stun
Area Sleep
Single Target Root
und wenn das noch nicht genug war
Instant Area Sleep
Single Target Stun
Also ihr habt alles was es an CC
gibt in diesem Spiel als Heiler.
Das sinnvoll anzuwenden
sich sinnvoll zu positionieren
und neben diesem ganzen Shit
noch zu heilen
ist mega anspruchsvoll
und wahrscheinlich
der schwierigste Char im ganzen Game
Dazu kommt ja noch
ihr müsst ja auch noch nebenbei
könnt ihr noch Attack Speed debuffen
ihr könnt noch Seuche heilen, Gift heilen
Leute wiederbeleben
neben Sleep heilen, ihr könnt Near Sight heilen, ihr könnt Gegner den Zauber vergessen lassen, den sie gerade zaubern.
Und nebenbei könnt ihr auch noch ganz gut heilen.
Ihr könnt quasi alles, außer Damage machen.
Aber das auf die Reihe zu bekommen in einem Fight, braucht da auch Kenntnisse.
Das geht nicht als Einsteiger, meiner Meinung nach.
Aber was geht, was ihr machen könnt, ist, diese Skill-Linie hier komplett weglassen, so wie das auch viele machen, weil denen ist das einfach zu stressig und zu anstrengend.
Die gehen bei Heiler nämlich nicht auf Pack, sondern die gehen auf so eine Mischung aus, sagen wir mal, mindestens 40 Heal.
Wobei ich ja persönlich fast sogar schon ein bisschen höher gehen würde, wenn man hauptsächlich BG spielt.
Wenn man BG spielt, kann man theoretisch, ja, kann man...
Kann man theoretisch auf 46 Heal gehen, wenn man BG spielt, dann hat man noch Grupp-Seuche-Heal.
Und den Rest steckt man in den Aug.
Zum Eingeschmack reichen 40 Heilen, aber...
Ja, wenn man nur BG spielt, könnte man sowas hier spielen.
Das ist durchaus okay.
Oder ihr geht halt mit Heilen ein bisschen runter, dass ihr die höheren Resis bekommt.
Was sehr sinnvoll ist, weil die niedrigen Resis braucht kein Mensch, da sind CL-Resis besser.
Die gelben.
Die werden schon ganz sinnig.
Ja, aber sowas könnt ihr zum Beispiel machen.
Oder sagen wir mal, irgendwie, 40, wie hoch kriegen wir das hier?
Und auf 36, ja, das ist schon ein bisschen besser.
Ja, aber wie dem auch sei, was ich eigentlich sagen will, ist, also sowas für reines BG-RVR könnte man sowas hier schon spielen.
Dann ist der Heiler wiederum easy zu spielen, weil dann seid ihr wirklich Heiler.
Ihr seid dann einfach primär Heiler.
Ihr habt im Prinzip eure ganzen Heal-Spells, eure...
Die ihr übrigens auch habt, hier.
Aber nicht die beste Version davon.
Das heißt, hier müsst ihr die gesamte Crawl-Control-Geschichte machen.
Plus das Heilen, was ihr hier machen müsst.
Und dann bekommt ihr noch einen weiteren Spell, der auch sehr nice ist.
Ihr bekommt Celerity.
Das kann ich nicht aussprechen.
Celerity ist ein Attack-Speed-Debuff für eure Tanks.
Immer sehr beliebt.
Aber im Prinzip ist das ziemlich simpel zu spielen.
Ihr müsst gucken, dass eure Gruppe am Leben bleibt.
Ihr müsst die heilen.
Ihr könnt solche Nier-Seiten und sowas heilen.
Und ihr werft ab und zu mal einen Group-Attack-Speed-Buff fertig.
Damit habt ihr so euren Heal-Orc-Heiler abgedeckt.
Also, das ist eine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Puck-Heiler ist wahrscheinlich die schlechteste Einstiegsklasse, die es gibt in dem Spiel.
So.
So viel zu den Midgard-Klassen.
Also, um das nochmal zusammenzufassen, wer Bock hat auf Midgard.
Bonedancer, super Einstiegsklasse.
Heiler, wenn es nur um Heilen und Buffen geht, auch gute Einstiegsklasse.
Rune-Master, wer auf Range, DPS, S-Fuck steht, super Einstiegsklasse.
Schamane, wie ich finde, eigentlich, ich stelle es mir zumindest vor als Einsteiger,
die etwas spannendere Einstiegssupport-Einstiegsklasse in Midgard als Heiler.
Also auch eine super Einstiegsklasse.
Für meinen Geschmack sogar noch ein bisschen besser als Heiler.
Und als letztes, was war es eigentlich?
Spirit-Master mag ich nicht.
Ja, und wenn ihr unbedingt einen Tank spielen wollt, oder unbedingt keinen Tank-Nachkampf spielen wollt,
dann spielt es geile.
Aber, das war es.
Das würde ich in Midgard empfehlen.
So, jetzt kommen wir zu Hip.
Hip ist das Reich, was ich am wenigsten gespielt habe insgesamt.
Und auch am wenigsten Ahnung von habe.
Aber ich meine, ich weiß trotzdem, was die Klassen machen, weil man spielt ja dagegen.
Übrigens, was euch jetzt vielleicht schon aufgefallen ist,
wir haben uns jetzt zwei von drei Reichen angeguckt.
Und euch ist vielleicht aufgefallen, dass keine der Klassen doppelt,
ach doch, Mauler, Mauler, aber gibt es auf Eden eh nicht.
Dass keine der Klassen doppelt vorkommt.
Und das ist auch eines der großen...
...nice Sachen von Daok.
Daok hat drei Reiche und komplett unterschiedliche Klassen.
Du hast ganz vereinzelt ein paar Klassen, die gewisse Überschneidungen haben.
Ja, zum Beispiel einen Feuer-Wizard und einen Rune-Master.
Die sind schon relativ ähnlich.
Aber es sind trotzdem auch ansonsten komplett unterschiedliche Klassen.
Und dementsprechend spielen sich auch alle drei Reiche schon auf ihre eigene Art.
Und Hip fühlt sich anders an.
Im Gameplay als Alp.
Und Alp fühlt sich anders an im Gameplay als Mid.
Das ist einfach so.
Und das ist halt was, das kenne ich aus keinem anderen Game.
So, aber kommen wir mal zu den Hip-Klassen.
Wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt Hibernia spielen, weil ihr auf grüne Wiesen und Bäume und sowas steht,
oder euch vielleicht, was wahrscheinlich die bessere Variante ist,
eine der Klassen aus Hibernia am besten gefällt,
dann werde ich erstmal meinen Senf zugeben, was ich für gute Einstiegsklassen halte.
Also, fangen wir gleich mal mit an.
Animist.
Dürfte wahrscheinlich...
Chat, mal die Frage an euch, wer von euch da auch spielt.
Gibt es eine Klasse, die mehr gehasst ist als Anis?
Ich glaube, Anis sind die meistgehasste Klasse im Spiel.
Niemand mag Anis.
Außer Anis-Spieler selbst.
Okay, und andere Leute aus Hip.
Aber sonst mag keiner Animisten.
Anis mag niemand.
Und das liegt daran, weil das ist eine...
Ich muss nur gucken, ob jetzt irgendwie wirklich nicht noch irgendwie DF oder so anfängt.
Nee, ist nicht.
Und das liegt daran,
weil Animisten eine...
Ich zeig's euch mal.
Ich zeig's euch mal im Chartplaner.
Eine Sache können, die niemand sonst in dem Spiel kann,
und das ist Pilzen.
Klingt jetzt erstmal dumm,
aber es ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Pilzen können die.
Die haben eine Skill...
Das hier.
Die haben eine Skill-Linie,
da kann man Pilze...
Nee, Moment.
Nee, das...
Ach, Quatsch.
Das ist immer, wie wenig Ahnung ich von Anis habe.
Ich hasse Anis.
Ja.
Du bekommst Pilze.
Animus-Pattern sind Pilze.
Du kannst quasi...
Dog...
Shrooms...
Guck hier.
Das...
Das ist ein Ani.
Du pilzt.
Du stehst rum und fucking pilzt den ganzen Tag.
Das ist das Ani-Gameplay.
Du pilzt.
Und ab und zu machst du mal ein bisschen Damage noch auf Gegner.
So.
Und dann rennst du zurück in deine Pilze.
Und deine Pilze killen alle Gegner.
Pass mal auf, das werden wir wahrscheinlich...
Hier, guckt es euch an.
Guckt es euch an.
Ani-Gameplay, Alter.
Ani...
Das ist so eine Cancer-Class, Alter.
Äh, guck.
Jetzt, sobald...
Sobald was auf ihn drauf geht,
rennt er zurück zu seinen hässlichen Pilzen.
Und die Pilze killen das alles für ihn.
Also Ani, ich weiß nicht.
Ani ist...
Jetzt mal...
Guckt es euch an.
Die...
Der muss nichts machen.
Da steht einfach nur noch die Pilze killen alles.
Guckt, guckt euch das an.
Das ist doch ein Witz, oder?
Guckt es euch an.
Der steht einfach in seinen fucking Pilzen und alles stirbt.
Ani, Alter.
Okay.
Ähm...
Also...
Ich...
Ich glaube, Animes ist die meistgehasste Klasse in dem gesamten Game.
Aber es ist...
Wenn man auf diesen Spielstil steht...
Also sehr...
So...
Summonermäßig...
Ohne, dass man die Pets jetzt...
Großartig kontrolliert steuern könnte...
Wenn man...
Wenn man so...
So Fire and Forget Summonermäßig spielen will...
Ist Ani eigentlich eine coole Klasse?
Ich hasse Animisten.
Ich würde den nicht spielen.
Aber...
Realistisch betrachtet, wenn man auf den Spielstil steht...
Ist das, glaube ich, eine echt gute Einstiegsklasse.
Aber nur, wenn man den Spielstil mag.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wer diesen Spielstil mag, aber...
Aber Ani...
Aber Ani ist...
Ani...
Ey...
Wenn euch das gefällt, spielt Animist.
Ist eine gute Einstiegsklasse auf jeden Fall.
Banshee, finde ich, ist keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Banshee ist eine der vielen Caster-Klassen in H.I.P.
Ich glaube, H.I.P. hat die meisten Caster-Klassen.
Ist eine Caster-Klasse, die sich hauptsächlich dadurch auszeichnet, dass sie viele Area-Damage-Spell-Effekte hat.
Und Banshee ist die einzige Gender-Locked-Klasse im Spiel.
Alle anderen Klassen können sowohl männlich als auch weiblich sein.
Banshee ist die einzige Klasse, die nur weiblich sein darf.
Man verwandelt sich da auch.
In irgend so was Gespenstermäßiges, wenn man Banshee ist.
Weirde Klasse.
Eigentlich ganz cool von den Fähigkeiten her.
Aber ich finde, keine Einstiegsklasse.
Ja, steht ja auch hier.
Hier, Ranged Area-Effekt.
Also, hat hauptsächlich...
Range-Damage...
Ähm...
Area-Damage-Effekte.
Meiner Meinung nach hauptsächlich eine Klasse für...
Zerg.
Beziehungsweise...
Battlegroup.
PvP.
FVR.
Da siehst du auch jede Menge Banshees.
Aber ich finde den nicht gerade...
Ich finde die zum Einstieg jetzt nicht so dolle.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Bade.
Definitiv keine Einstiegsklasse.
Bade ist so eine Mischung aus...
Nachdem ich euch das andere jetzt ja erklärt habe.
Bade ist so eine Mischung aus Heiler und Hexe.
Du bist quasi der Main Crowd-Controller in HIP.
Du musst aber auch gefühlt alles machen.
Brauch sehr tiefgreifende Kenntnisse der Dark-Mechanics.
Und ist quasi ein...
Healer...
Crowd-Control-Hybrid.
So ein bisschen wie Heiler.
Aber nicht wirklich Heiler.
Also...
Eher so eine Mischung aus...
Aus Hexe und...
Und...
Äh...
Aus Heiler und Minne oder sowas vielleicht.
Also...
Ich...
Kann man schwer klassifizieren.
Ihr seht, die Klassen sind alle unterschiedlich.
Ist...
Sehr schwierig gut zu spielen.
Und...
Von den Mechanics her und allem sicherlich...
Nichts...
Für Einsteiger.
Den...
Den würde ich in die ähnliche Kategorie wie Pack-Heiler schieben.
Eines der Einsteiger-unfreundlichsten Klassen überhaupt.
Zumal es als Bade auch sehr auf dich ankommt.
In Gruppen.
Wenn du es verkackst, ist die Gruppe meistens im Arsch.
Dementsprechend...
Würde ich sagen, Bade ist eindeutig was für fortgeschrittene Spieler.
Gar nichts für Einsteiger.
Blademaster...
Da sind wir wieder beim Thema...
Reine Nahkampf-DPS-Klasse.
Dual-Wheeled-Nahkampf-DPS-Klasse.
Also ihr merkt vielleicht, jedes Reich hat...
Eine Main-Tank-Klasse.
Und eine...
Off-Tank-Dual-Wheeled-DPS-Klasse.
Falls euch das aufgefallen ist.
Also es gibt beispielsweise...
Außer Alp.
Außer Alp, die haben zwei.
Alp hat Armsman und Pala als Main-Tank.
Und Mercenary als Dual-Wheeled-Off-Tank-Klasse.
Midgard hat Warrior als Main-Tank.
Und...
Savage und...
Bersie als Dual-Wheeled-Off-Tank-Klasse.
Und Hippheart...
Hero als Main-Tank.
Und...
Blademaster als...
Dual-Wheeled-Off-Tank-Klasse.
Nachdem ich ja schon gesagt habe, ich finde Tanks generell nicht gut für den Einstieg.
Würde ich das beim Blademaster nochmal unterstreichen.
Blademaster ist reine Nahkampf-Klasse.
Du hast nichts, was irgendwie ranged ist.
Das heißt, wenn du Fights falsch einschätzt und so.
Und auf einmal zwischen fünf Castern stehst.
Weil du das nicht gecheckt hast.
Weil du den Flow von Fights in Dark nicht kennst.
Bist du einfach tot.
Und du bist als Nahkampf-Klasse prinzipiell, wenn du Noob bist in dem Game, immer tot.
Wenn du einfach nur Tunnel-Blick-mäßig rein rennst.
Deswegen...
Kannst viel ausrichten als Nahkampf-Klasse.
Aber du musst ein bisschen wissen, wann und wie und wo.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall nichts für Einsteiger.
Blademaster ist tatsächlich noch relativ ähnlich zu einem Söldner.
Und zu einem Mercenary in Alp.
Ähm...
Man denkt jetzt...
Das muss ich vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen.
Man denkt jetzt bei Blademaster und bei Mercenary vielleicht so nur klassische Dual-Wheel-Nahkampf-DPS-Klassen.
Das ist so.
Aber die haben beide.
Deswegen reicht es, wenn ich hier jetzt mal den... Ach komm, wenn ich mal Blademaster zeige.
Die haben eine Spezialität.
Sowohl Söldner als auch Blademaster.
Die können nicht nur Waffen specken.
Und Dual-Wheel specken.
Nein, die können auch Schild specken.
Und gute Off-Tanks haben immer Schild gespeckt.
Und die haben nicht etwa Schild...
Das ist wieder so ein typisches Ding, wo man Dark kennen muss, weil das niemand checkt, der neu ist.
Es ist so, dass alle Off-Tanks, die Schild specken können, Schild specken.
Aber die specken nicht Schild.
Also die skillen nicht Schild, damit sie blocken können oder mehr aushalten.
Oder sagen wir mal, in den seltensten Fällen, damit sie blocken können und mehr aushalten.
Nein, die specken Schild dafür.
Du bekommst auf Level 42 für den Schild einen 9-Sekunden-Nahkampf-Stun.
Dann haust du dem Gegner quasi dein Schild vor den Latz und er ist 9 Sekunden betäubt.
Und da das ein Nahkampf-Stun ist, zählen dort auch keine Resistenzen rein.
Auch so ein Dark-Ding, was keiner weiß, wenn es nicht weiß.
Casted-Stunts zählen Resistenzen rein.
Melee-Stunts zählen keine Resistenzen rein.
Das heißt, wenn ich einen Heiler stunt, stehst du vielleicht 5 Sekunden.
Stunt dich einer mit dem Schild, stehst du die vollen 9 Sekunden.
Und in 9 Sekunden-Stun, wenn der Tangay schon an dir dran ist, bist du futsch.
Zumal das meistens noch nicht der Einzige ist, der auf dich draufhaut oder auf dich draufcastet.
9 Sekunden-Stun, du bist eigentlich in 99%, äh 7 Sekunden-Stun.
In 9 Sekunden? 9 Sekunden-Stun.
Du bist, du bist eigentlich immer tot.
Also was die, was gute Off-Tanks machen ist, die specken Schild auf 42,
klemmen dich, switchen zurück auf Dual-Wield und rasieren dich weg.
Wie Gillette Abdi.
Und deswegen muss man da auch halt ein bisschen die Einzelheiten kennen, dass man auf sowas kommt.
Aber bei Blademaster trotzdem keine, keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Das war doch mal vor 20 Jahren populär.
Ja, aber es sind immer noch viele Spieler auf dem Freeshard.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Ich wollte eigentlich mal eine Epic mit dem...
Ja.
Ich hab euch jetzt die Heiler-Sache gezeigt.
Ich wollte eigentlich mal eine Epic machen mit dem Rooney.
Dass ich das bis heute Abend noch irgendwie durchkriege.
Ich bin ja schon 5 Stunden am Start, alter Leute.
Lul.
So viel am Schwätzen gewesen.
Nehmen die noch Geld damit ein? Keine Ahnung.
Ich spiele auf dem Freeshard.
Ich spiele, oh fuck.
Wenn ich jetzt rausgehe, dann ist es...
Crash this game.
Ich spiele auf dem Freeshard.
Also wenn du auch spielen willst, kannst du kostenlos spielen.
Eben.
Musst du offiziell...
Ja, wir haben ja auch eine Anleitung, wie es geht.
Es ist easy.
Kriegt jeder hin.
Kannst du kostenlos spielen.
Ist seasonal.
Das heißt, es wird so ungefähr alle 10 Monate mal resettet.
Aber nicht alles.
Du behältst manche Sachen.
Ich finde, die haben das sehr gut gemacht.
Und wenn du mich fragst, ist Eden Season 2 der beste Dark Server, den es hier gegeben hat.
So, gehen wir zurück auf den Rooney.
So.
Klassenübersicht.
Weiter.
Machen wir mal schnell fertig.
Sehr gute Einstiegsklasse.
Champion.
Ehrlich gesagt...
Schrott.
Aus meiner Sicht.
Egal.
Ob für erfahrene oder neue Spieler.
Schrott.
Neue Spieler neigen vielleicht noch dazu, das zu spielen, weil sie denken, oh cooles
Konzept.
Ich glaube, Champion ist eines der am wenigst gespieltesten Klassen im Game.
Ich glaube, die meisten anderen, die werden noch so...
Du kannst ja auch fast alles irgendwie gebrauchen, ja.
Aber Champion ist eines der...
Tja.
Wenigst gespieltesten und auch, finde ich, unsinnigsten Klassen im Spiel.
Champion ist gedacht vom Hersteller als...
Off-Tank.
Der nicht primär nur DPS macht, sondern Gegner debuffen kann.
Aber nachdem Champion zwar richtig krasse Debuffs hat, aber nur Single-Target-Debuffs,
ist Champion eigentlich ziemlich useless.
Ich mag Champion nicht.
Und ich bin nicht der Einzige, weil Champion ist eines der am wenigsten gespielten Klassen
im ganzen Spiel.
Würde ich als Einsteiger definitiv nicht empfehlen und würde ich auch als Fortgeschrittener
definitiv nicht empfehlen.
Ich glaube, niemand spielt Champion.
Coole Klasse, aber bis jetzt noch nicht balanced worden, sodass man sagt, ey, den will ich
unbedingt haben.
So.
Truide.
Sehr gute Einstiegsklasse.
Als noch am Cryen, ja.
Truide, sehr gute Einstiegsklasse.
Truide ist der Haupt-, äh, der Main-Healer aus der Primary-Healer aus Hipp und der Primär-Buffer
aus Hipp.
Ähm, Truide ist ein bisschen mit Clary zu vergleichen in der Rolle als Main-Buffer,
Main-Healer.
Allerdings hast du noch ein Pet.
Ähm, Truide kannst du...
Truide ist eine super Einstiegsklasse.
Ich habe auch eine Weile Truide gespielt.
Macht auch mega Bock.
Würde ich sagen, gilt das gleiche wie beim Clary, wenn man wirklich auf Support-Klassen
steht.
Also, sodass man sagt, ey, ich komme damit klar, dass ich selbst nichts kille, sondern
ich meine Gruppe supporte und die killt was für mich.
Dann ist Truide super Klasse und auch super rewarding zu spielen.
Du hast, als Truide kannst du heilen, du kannst, äh, buffen und du kannst ein Pet beschwören.
Je nachdem, wie viel du da reinsetzt.
Mehr oder weniger ein gutes Pet.
Aber ganz ehrlich, die Truiden-Pets sind alle nicht so geil.
Ich weiß, es gibt auf jeden einen Truide, der spielt immer solo und der hat das höchste
Pet oder mit das höchste Pet und der spielt auch recht erfolgreich solo.
Aber die wenigsten Leute werden Truide solo spielen und ein hoher, ein hoher Truide mit
45 Pet, der kann weder heilen noch buffen, sondern nicht gut specken, den will in Gruppe
keiner haben.
Also insofern...
Ich würde Abstand von der Pet-Linie nehmen.
Als Einstieg mit Truide.
Ich würde mich da drauf fokussieren, dass ich ordentlich heilen kann, ordentlich buffen
kann.
Also quasi im Prinzip mindestens schnell Near-Side-Heal und die...
Und gelben Decks.
Gelben...
Ja, also mindestens...
Oh.
Ach, das geht gar nicht.
Das ist ja kacke.
Wie, das funzt nicht?
Ha!
Siehst du mal, wie wenig Plan ich von Hip-Klassen habe.
Man braucht es.
39 brauchst du für den Gelben.
Tatsache.
Okay, dann kannst du gar nicht den hohen Near-Side specken.
Okay, was ist denn da eine sinnvolle, sinnvolle Truiden-Speckung?
Ja, das braucht keiner.
Den Group-Instant könnte man...
Ja, hier kann man tatsächlich da ein bisschen variieren, ob man noch ein bisschen mehr Pet
haben will oder ein bisschen weniger Pet.
Aber sag mal, das ist das, was den Druiden halt auszeichnet, dass du nicht nur Main-Buffer,
Main-Healer bist.
Du hast zusätzlich noch ein Pet.
Du kannst also quasi, weil die Hips sind ja alle sehr naturverbunden, du kannst quasi
einen Luchs beschwören, einen Löwe beschwören, einen Wolf beschwören und so komisches Zeug.
Einen Baum beschwören, warum auch immer man Bäume beschwören kann in Dark.
Und du hast noch ein bisschen CC-Root und Instant-Root.
Und das grenzt sich, das grenzt sich so ein bisschen vom Clary aus Alp ab.
Ist aber trotzdem eine super Einstiegsklasse.
Wenn man gerne Support spielt.
Und zwar Full-Support.
Ohne da irgendwelche komischen Damage-Ambitionen.
Ist Druide.
Und wenn ihr Hip spielen wollt, ist Druide euer Ding.
Main-Buffer, Main-Healer.
Mit ein bisschen Utility, was Root und Pet angeht.
Kann man sehr viel Spaß dran haben.
Macht mir persönlich auch ultra Spaß und ist eine super Einstiegsklasse.
Nächstes Eldritch.
Ja, jetzt kommen wir in die Hip-Spezialitäten.
Ich muss immer mal gucken, dass die nicht DF starten hier ohne mich.
Also jetzt kommen wir in die Hip-Spezialitäten.
Was Caster angeht.
Also.
Ich finde, der Eldritch ist keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Weil das quasi der, nennen wir es mal mit dem Menta zusammen,
mehr der Damage-Otility-Caster in Hip ist.
Du hast Near-Side, du hast Seuche, du hast...
Okay, Singles, Targets, dann haben sie alle.
Du hast einen ganz guten Nuke.
Du kannst ganz gut Damage machen.
Aber dadurch, dass du nicht nur einen reinen Damage-Caster hast,
nicht nur ein reiner Damage-Damage-Damage-Eine-Taste-Eine-Taste-Damage-Damage-Damage bist,
musst du ein bisschen wissen, was du machst.
Und man sieht es ja auch hier an der...
Ja, hier sieht man es ja auch.
Ähm...
Du kannst...
Okay, Void.
Du kannst Void specken.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Void, sondern nicht beliebt ist.
Void ist quasi die Fire-Wizard-Variante in Hip.
Bolt, Damage und Nuke, Nuke, Nuke, Nuke, Nuke.
Aber...
Die...
Das ist sehr ähnlich zum Runi auch.
Aber da spielen, glaube ich, kaum welche.
Also...
Ich finde, das ist keine so gute Einstiegsklasse.
Weil du hast einige Möglichkeiten, was du machen kannst,
wo du gerade auch hier mit solchen schon wissen musst, was du machst.
Außerdem bist du jetzt nicht so, dass jede Gruppe unbedingt einen Eldritch haben will.
Weil in BG ist das kein Ding.
Ja, und auch viele Hip-Hybrid-Gruppen haben einen, gerade wegen der Seuche und sowas.
Aber...
Die Welt schreit nicht unbedingt jetzt nach, komm in meine Gruppe.
Komm in die Gruppe.
Ja.
Blicken die Geldscheine.
Ange, ähnlich gelagert.
Nur, dass ich finde, dass Ange noch eine ziemlich gute Einstiegsklasse ist.
Weil Ange ist simpel.
Ange macht zwei Sachen.
Hat einen Pet und macht Damage.
Ange ist eine gute Klasse.
Du kannst...
Also, das hier speckt niemand.
Das ist Buffs fürs Pet.
Da machst du restliche Punkte rein.
Ansonsten speckt das keiner.
Die meisten Leute specken Mana beim Ange.
Und dann ist das super straightforward.
Du speckst Mana.
Speckst den Rest in deinen Lightning-Nuke.
Und was du noch...
Also, so ungefähr.
Ich bin mir jetzt mit Ange-Specs aus dem Kopf auch dazu ganz...
Den Rest packst du noch in Pet und dann ist fertig.
So.
Ange-Skill fertig.
Und das ist eine super Klasse zum Einstieg, weil die ziemlich straightforward als Pet-Damage-Caster
zu spielen ist.
Es ist nicht ganz so simpel One-Button wie...
Es ist eigentlich eine ziemlich coole Einstiegsklasse.
Ja?
Ähm...
Es ist...
Es ist ein Caster, der sich ein bisschen anders spielt als der Rest, den wir bisher
als Einstiegskasten...
Als Einstiegsklassen hatten.
Es ist nicht so wie beim Fire...
Fire-Wizard.
Oder beim Huni.
Eins, zwei...
Dann D, D, D, D, D, D, D.
Nee.
Also, Ange musst du ein bisschen anders spielen.
Du hast zwei Varianten.
Deswegen finde ich auch...
Es ist eine wirklich coole...
Coole...
Ähm...
Einstiegsklasse.
Erstens bist du in Gruppen begehrt.
Für PvE.
Und in BG und sowas.
Gib ihm.
Obwohl du kein Range-AE-Damage hast.
Das ist vielleicht so der einzige Nachteil da dran.
Aber Ange ist beliebt.
Und das Coole an Ange ist...
Du kannst...
Also...
Enchanter.
Jeder sagt nur Ange.
Äh...
Das Coole daran ist...
Du hast ein Pet.
Du hast drei verschiedene Pets.
Du hast irgendwie ein Nahkraft-Pet, ein Caster-Pet mit...
Mit Snare und sowas.
Aber...
Du kannst...
Mega gut...
Ähm...
Ja...
Also...
Close-Range-Damage machen.
Wo man normalerweise denkt...
Hä?
Caster sind doch für Range-DPS.
Nee.
Ist nicht so.
Enchanter können Range-DPS...
Singletage...
Mega krassen Range-Target-DPS...
Äh...
Machen.
Und...
Close-Range-Damage.
Weil du bekommst hier...
Ups.
Ich hab übrigens Mist geskillt.
Hier bei meinem Ange seh ich grade.
Muss natürlich mal mindestens auf 48.
Rest brauchste net.
Du bekommst hier...
Äh...
Direct-Damage-PBAOE.
Du machst...
Ah ja.
Das ist...
Das ist heftig.
Guck mal.
Du...
Das ist ein...
Spell...
Mit nem Radius von 300.
Der allerdings...
Um dich...
Drumherum ist.
Also...
Du musst dort stehen...
Wo du willst...
Dass Damage...
Reinkommt.
Das heißt...
Du musst in die Gegner rennen...
Um Damage zu machen.
Wenn du aber...
In die Gegner stehst...
Und zwei Cars...
Zwei, drei Cars draus bekommst...
Ist alles tot.
Und das ist grade gegen Monster...
Gut.
Spieler die aufpassen...
Geht das so...
Geht das so semi-gut.
Wobei es...
Äh...
Viele Gruppen gibt...
Die versuchen das immer noch.
Ja.
Also es gibt...
Äh...
Im...
Im großen PvP...
Gibt es viele Gruppen...
Die versuchen...
Äh...
50, 60 Mann...
Battle...
Mit acht Leuten...
Versuchen die 50 Mann wegzubomben.
Ja.
Da wird reingerannt...
Versucht...
Zwei, dreimal zu bomben...
Mit zwei, drei Leuten...
Und dann fällt alles um.
Also kannst mit Eng...
Sowohl...
Super krassen...
Close Range Damage machen...
Als auch...
Und das ist grad das...
Was ich...
In Verbindung mit dem Pet cool finde...
Als auch...
Ziemlich guten Range Damage.
Weil...
Als Eng...
Bekommst du nämlich ein...
50%...
Debuff.
Und Eng...
Ist eines der wenigen Klassen...
In ganz Starhawk...
Die...
Ihren eigenen Damage...
Debuffen können.
Du bekommst hier...
Wie ihr seht...
Ihr bekommst ein Damage...
Du bekommst ein Resistenz Debuff...
Für Energie.
Weil...
Ist das wirklich nur Energie?
Ich mach das mal...
Hä?
Ist das doch...
Ist das nicht Hitze?
Äh...
Das stimmt nicht oder?
Ich glaube die Anzeige stimmt nicht in dem...
In dem...
Charplaner.
Weil Eng Debuff ist Heat...
Genauso wie sein Single Target Nuke.
Und deswegen ist es ein guter Einstiegs...
Deswegen ist es eine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Ah ja.
Kavu.
Muss sein.
Deswegen ist es eine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Du kannst deinen eigenen Damage Debuffen...
Übelst damit.
Du kannst super krass Nahkampf Damage machen.
Und du kannst Range Damage machen.
Indem du...
Den Gegner...
Resistenzen Debuffst.
Und dann...
Hier oben mit dem Nuke draufhältst.
Also deswegen...
Ich finde Eng ist eine tolle Einstiegsklasse.
Äh...
Ja.
Main Tank aus Hip.
Langweilig wie ich finde.
Hat einen kleinen Twist.
Kann...
Ähm...
Zwei Hand Waffen verwenden.
Inklusive Schilder.
Und Einhand Waffen.
Kann sich in...
Kann sich in den Elch verwandeln.
Wo du ein bisschen mehr Leben hast.
Aber...
Wo wir beim Thema sind.
Kann ich...
Kann ich eigentlich skippen?
Kann ich mir sparen?
Starten wir irgendwann nochmal mit DF heute?
Wenn nicht mach ich jetzt...
Wo mach ich...
Wo muss ich meine Epic weitermachen?
Ok.
Muss an Hagal porten.
Alles klar.
So.
Äh...
Wo wir...
Dabei...
Also...
Wie gesagt.
Nahkampf...
Klassen finde ich allgemein nicht gut geeignet.
Als Einsteiger.
Deswegen...
So wenig wie Armsmen.
Oder Krieger.
Oder Paller.
Normaler gibts nicht.
Menta ist ne super Klasse.
Finde ich aber auch zu kompliziert für den Einstieg.
Äh...
Du kannst hier nen Patch haben.
Du kannst...
Äh...
Ein bisschen heilen.
Und richtig gut DPS...
Äh...
Casten.
Plus ein paar Utility Spells casten.
Menta ist...
Glaube ich...
Bei den Castern.
Und du hast auch einen ziemlich guten AE dort.
Um...
Äh...
Im PvP Punkte zu farmen.
Ist ne mega Klasse.
Spielen auch viel.
Ich glaube aber...
Zum Einstieg...
Vielleicht...
Ein bisschen zu...
Zu viel auf...
Einmal was...
Du machen kannst.
Als Menta.
Du musst dich um dein Pet kümmern.
Du musst...
Ich meine...
Du kannst Menta auch einfach AE dort spammen.
Und die...
Und...
Halt die...
Halt die Klappe.
Ja?
Ich glaube aber Ensh ist der bessere Einstiegscharakter.
Kann man sich lediglich drüber streiten.
Menta ist super stark.
Eines der besten Caster die es gibt.
Vielleicht in dem Spiel.
Aber zum Einstieg...
Eher nicht so das.
Davon fragen wir auf welchem Server du spielst.
Eben.
Ich glaube...
Auf dem hier.
Ja auf dem hier.
Nicht auf Live.
Hey.
Ach auf...
Ach Moment.
Ich habe es nicht gelesen.
Sorry.
Du hast gefragt auf welchem Server ich auf Live gespielt habe.
Kannst du fragen.
Ich habe auf mehreren Servern gespielt.
Ähm...
Also hauptsächlich habe ich gespielt auf Stonehenge Albion.
Bisschen Lioners Hip.
Äh...
Klassik Server mit.
Und...
EU Klassik Server mit.
US Klassik Server mit.
Ein ganz kleines bisschen noch...
Dartmoor mit.
Und Logres Alp.
Aber...
Das...
Tatsächlich meine Zeit habe ich tatsächlich in Stonehenge Albion verbracht.
So.
Um das abzuschließen.
Menta.
Super Klasse.
Gerade auch auf jeden eines der beliebtesten Caster in Hip.
Und eines der besten Caster im Game.
Aber als Einstieg finde ich nicht so gut.
Nein.
Nightshade.
Schleicherklasse.
Nichts zum Einstieg.
Ranger.
Schleicher.
Bogenklasse.
Nichts zum Einstieg.
Veil...
Veilwalker.
Vielleicht eines der...
Uniquesten Nahkampfklassen die es gibt in dem Spiel.
Ist eine...
Ist...
Eine Nahkampfklasse mit Sensor aber nur Stoffrüstung.
Hasselmauler 50 Affa.
Beste.
Mann.
Dass ich das noch mal lieben kann.
Dass ich das noch mal lesen darf.
Hasselmauler 50 Affa.
Ja.
Das sind so die Dark Memes was...
Da gab es das Wort Meme damals noch nicht.
Also Veilwalker.
Hieß diese Klasse glaube ich Schnitter.
Du hast eine Sense.
Du hast aber selbst nur Stoff an.
Das heißt du bist nicht die aller tankigste Nahkampfklasse.
Du kriegst noch ein bisschen Absorb Buffs und so dass du mehr aushältst.
Aber man muss generell sagen Schnitter ist eine Nahkampfklasse die wohl mit am fragilsten
ist von allen Nahkampfklassen.
Aber Veilwalker macht Ultra Damage mit Positional Styles.
Das ist so eine...
Das ist eine ziemlich Unique Klasse in dem gesamten Game.
Du bist nicht sonderlich tanky, aber Nahkampf.
Du bist super krass Nahkampf DPS.
Aber nicht in jeder Lage.
Also du musst als Schnitter wirklich spielen können.
Und nachdem ich sage, dass Nahkampfklassen...
Du kannst ein bisschen casten noch als Schnitter, als Veilwalker.
Aber das ist nicht der Rede wert.
Aber nachdem ich schon bei allen anderen Nahkampfklassen gesagt habe.
Nehmt als Einsteiger lieber Abstand davon.
Sage ich das als Schnitter doppelt.
Also Veilwalker als Einstiegsklasse ist glaube ich echt mega frustrierend.
Du bist wahrscheinlich immer tot.
Das würde ich nicht anfangen.
Ansonsten ist das eine coole Klasse.
Vampir gibt es nicht.
Warden.
So.
Letzte Klasse hierbei.
Kann ich ja schon mal ein bisschen weitererzählen und gucken wo muss ich jetzt hin für meine Epic.
Ah ich muss die Eier abgeben.
Wie sich das anhört.
Lasst mal kurz die Eier einreichen.
Was machen eigentlich die Mids in der...
Ist immer noch kein DF Raid.
Ich glaube DF ist nicht ab.
Kann das sein?
Oh hier.
Hier Kollege.
Kriegst du meine Eier.
Nice.
Komm mal.
Und jetzt.
Oh.
Jetzt muss ich den Frontier Step machen.
Da muss ich mal aufs Klo vorher.
Bevor ich den mache.
Jetzt wäre ich wahrscheinlich gefarmt.
Jetzt habe ich so lange gelabert.
Dass die ganzen Leute abends.
Schon online sind.
Und jetzt wäre ich wahrscheinlich.
Bei dem Frontier.
Bei dem RVR PvP Gebiet.
Step meiner Epic.
Abgefarmt.
So.
Wahrscheinlich wäre ich gestream sniped.
Jetzt gleich.
Man weiß ja nicht.
Ja.
Um.
Die letzte Klasse.
Ist.
Secret.
OPS Fuck.
Wenn ihr mich fragt.
Wird kaum drüber diskutiert.
Aber ich finde.
Es gibt.
Ich finde.
Larry.
Für den flee.
FFD.
Reda.
Weiß ich wie man es richtig ausspricht.
Aber.
Aber trotzdem.
Dann.
Ich muss schon in dem ab.
Exzell.
ich.
Finde.
Eines.
Der exceeds.
Klassen.
Im Spiel.
Nicht.
Universell.
Ja.
Aber.
Wenn man.
Richtung.
Auf Eden.
Weil.
Ich zeige euch jetzt den großen Unterschied.
Zu Warden auf Eden.
Zu Warden woanders.
Wo ist er denn? Hier.
Das ist alles normal.
Hüter hieß das Ding übrigens auf Deutsch hier.
Aber.
Warden hat Shields Back.
Das hat er auf Live nicht gehabt.
Und dadurch, dass er Shields Back hat.
Hat er auch, wie alle mit Shields Back.
Einen 42er.
9 Sekunden Nachkampfstun.
Und das gepaart mit dem Rest.
Macht in Gruppenfights.
Oder Smallmanfights.
Hüter finde ich zu einem der besten Klassen.
Im ganzen Spiel.
Du hast Shield.
Das heißt du kannst für andere Leute blocken.
Hüter kann in Live nicht Shields Back.
Never.
Okay. Vielleicht mittlerweile.
Lelo.
Miltopass Raiding.
Dankeschön.
Lelo.
Du hast doch einen Charakter auf mit, der fast genau so heißt, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob du Deutsch verstehst.
Lelo, du hast einen Charakter auf Eden mit, der fast den gleichen Namen hat.
Ich glaube, ich habe dich ein paar mal gesehen.
Und ich glaube, wir...
Du spielst...
Okay.
Ich glaube, wir waren zusammen mal in Sobe.
Mit so einem komischen Typ, der dann keinen Bock hatte nach dem zweiten Vibe.
Ja.
Wo sie sich darüber beschwert haben, dass du die Gegner...
Das war's. Bist du nicht gewesen? Okay.
Dann wundert's mich.
Weil es gibt hier mal einer, der läuft fast genau mit dem gleichen Namen rum.
Ja.
Dann habe ich das jetzt durcheinander gebracht.
Nun gut.
So. Ich muss jetzt meinen Frontier-Epic-Step machen.
Das wird was, ey.
Ich sage es euch.
Ich werde jetzt so krass gefarmt gleich.
Tja
Von wo fahren wir denn
Fahren wir von
Abercraft, vielleicht ist da noch am wenigsten los
Dann bin ich mal gespannt
Ob ich das da hinschaffe
Ich hätte mir vielleicht ein Boot kaufen sollen auf dem Char
Dass ich ordentlich Boot fahren kann
Schauen wir mal
Hat eigentlich jeder einen Buff
Nein, niemand
Der lädt mich ein
Gut, die machen keine Epic, dann lade ich
Dann lehne ich ab
Versuch doch mit dem Solo-Duo-Porter
Das ist mein Plan
Ne, mach ich nicht
Ich versuch Boot zu fahren
Oder
Ich dachte da steht ein Lurie
Keck wait, ich werde jetzt so hart abgefarmt
Weil jetzt sind schon relativ viele Leute
Am Start und hier wird immer so heftig
Gekämmt
Und
Und als Runi mit Level-Ausrüstung
Und allem, dann gibt es richtig gerade
Das ist übrigens der besagte Solo-Porter hier
Äh
Albion Coast
Okay, wir haben es ins Boot geschafft
Immerhin
Ja, ja, mich würde es nicht wundern
Wenn mich jetzt irgendeiner sogar Stream-Snipe gibt
Der Leute, die brauchen das
Ich meine, das ist nicht schlimm, ich kann die Epic auch neue machen
Zumindest, um diese Sache mit Hüter mal abzuschließen
Wir gucken mal kurz
Dark Warden
Was der für Skill-Linien hat
Off-Life
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, der hat kein Schild
Sieht man das irgendwo?
Äh
Sieht man irgendwie, was der für Skill-Linien hat?
Das ist ja, die Wiki-Seite ist ja absolut PP-Germann
Dark Charm-Planer
Gucken wir mal
Irgendwie einen
Für Live-Server
Das Live-Server?
The fuck
Okay, gucken wir mal hier
Äh, Warden
Guck
Warden hat
Oh, oh
What?
Seit wann hat Warden Off-Life denn Schilde?
Nun gut, das war zumindest zur damaligen Zeit in Dauern nicht so
Und das haben die für den Patch dann auf jeden Fall customised
Oh, Sekunde
So
Das haben die auf jeden Fall customised
Und das ist mega nice
Du bist nämlich als Hüter
Hast du
Nicht nur richtig gute Resis, die wichtig sind
Sondern du hast alles, was du sonst als Hüter hast
Plus Shields dann
Was dich im Endeffekt nicht mehr so gut machten hat
Was dich im Endeffekt zu einem
Nahezu vollwertigen Heiler
Und
Nahezu vollwertigem Tank macht
Und das ist super krass
Also ich finde, ich finde Hüter ist mega, mega nice
Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine gute Einstiegsklasse ist
Das kann ich persönlich ehrlich gesagt fast mit am schlechtesten
Ja, ja genau, das meinte ich ja mit allem was du sonst noch mit Hüter hast
Ich kann es ehrlich gesagt relativ schlecht beurteilen
Ich hab Hüter nie großartig gespielt
Ähm
Ich würde sagen, prinzipiell ist Hüter eine gute Einstiegsklasse
Weil du musst nicht viel machen
Du musst auch nicht viel aktiv machen
Hüter ist da eigentlich relativ simpel
Du äh
Slamst ein paar Targets mit deinem Shield
Du machst dein Bubblechant an
Buffst ab und zu mal Resis
Und heilst die Leute, wenn es sein muss
Also Hüter, ich würde tatsächlich sagen
Hüter ist eine gute Einstiegsklasse
Ja, Hüter ist eine gute Einstiegsklasse
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, wenn ihr hauptsächlich
Und das werden die meisten Neulinge machen
Hauptsächlich in Randomgruppen spielt
Hauptsächlich BG-RVR spielt
Bin ich mir nicht sicher, wie rewarding Hüter ist
Weil Hüter macht weder AE-Damage
Noch kannst du sonderlich gut
Deine komplette Gruppe heilen
Ich weiß, hat ein Hüter überhaupt eine Group-Heal
Hat einen ziemlich guten Single-Heal
Aber ob der einen Group-Heal hat
Bin ich mir da gar nicht mal so sicher
Äh
Doch, du kriegst sogar
Du kriegst sogar einen guten Group-Heal
Da ist der Hüter ja noch besser
Als ich dachte
Du kriegst zwar keinen Spread-Heal
Aber die meisten heilen eh nicht mit
Mit
Nicht dauerhaft mit Spread
Du kriegst sogar den schnellen, großen, guten Group-Heal
Also Hüter ist echt krass
Du bist
Okay, dann sagen wir mal so
Du kriegst noch den Hot und alles
Ja, wobei, weiß ich nicht, wie gut der in den Fall ist
Also sagen wir es mal so
Du bist 95% Healer
Main-Healer
Dir fehlt ja eigentlich nur
Dir fehlt ja eigentlich nur das Spread-Heal
Dir fehlt ja wirklich nur das Spread-Heal im Endeffekt
Also Near-Side-Heal, Neo
Du hast fucking Near-Side und Group-Desease-Cure
Oh
Alter
Hüter ist ja noch mehr OP, als ich mir das vorgestellt hab
The fuck
Okay
Ich nehme das nicht zurück, was ich gesagt hab
Dass ich denke, dass Hüter eines der OP-sten Klassen ist
In dem Spiel zur Zeit
Gerade auf Eden
Das ist noch mehr OP, als ich mir das im Vorfeld schon gedacht hab
Da oben stelzen irgendwelche Leute rum
Ich verpiss mich mal ganz schnell
Ab nach Hip
Ich hab noch ein Bade gelevelt
Aber ich hab keinen Bock Hip zu spielen
Oh
Ich stell's mich jetzt hier unten lang
Also wenn mich hier einer findet
Dann Stream-Snipe
Dann call ich Stream-Snipe
Anzeige ist raus
Denn niemand guckt hier unten normalerweise
Okay
Das heißt, du bist
95% Main-Healer
Gleichwertig
Als One
Du hast super nice Resis
Instant Rett
Ey
Okay, ich nehm das zurück
Das ist nicht wahrscheinlich die OP-ste Klasse
Die es zumindest für Small-Men und Group-RVR gibt
Das ist die OP-ste Klasse, die es für Small-Men und Group-RVR gibt
Du meinst, du kannst ja als Hüter alles
Außer Leute killen
Okay, ich komme gleich noch darauf zurück
In der Hoffnung, ich werde jetzt nicht abgefarmt
Und kann meine
Kann meine Quest machen
Quest
Krass, Alter
Jetzt ergibt das für mich auch Sinn
Ich mein, mir war nicht so gut, dass ich das gemacht hab
Mir sind die Hip-Group-Setups schon eine Zeit lang klar gewesen
Warum, wie was gespielt wird
Jetzt verstehe ich aber noch eine Stufe mehr
Warum
Fünfer-Support-Gruppen
Tank-Gruppen in Hip so beliebt sind
Du hast 5 Heiler inklusive
Alter, das ist ja mega krass
Du kannst ja in Hip, kannst du ja theoretisch spielen
Doppel-Bade
Doppel-Druid
Hüter
Ähm
Doppel-Druid
Blademaster
Und du hast noch einen Platz frei für X
Alter, das ist ja so krass
Du kriegst es nicht tot und du hast super Damage
Geil, Alter
Ach, guck mal, da ist das Viech
Nice, ich wurde nicht abgef...
Ich call es mal nicht zu früh
Okay, geh down, please
Einfach sterben, nice
Okay, wir haben die Quest geschafft
Ich wurde nicht gestream...
Gestream-Sniped
Also, das ist wirklich schon heftig, ne
Also, ich glaube, das ist wirklich schon heftig
Du bist 95...
Du bist eigentlich, wenn man mal ehrlich ist
Du bist besser im Heilen als der Main-Healer
Das einzige, was du nicht hast, ist der Spread-Heal
Aber du hast einen Group-Disease-Cure
Den sich die meisten Druiden nicht erlauben können zu holen
Wenn sie buffen müssen
Heißt im Endeffekt, ja, aufkill mich
Heißt im Endeffekt, du bist eigentlich der bessere Heiler als Warn
Als Warn
Du bist eigentlich der bessere Heiler als Warn
Und dann hast du noch deine ganzen anderen Utility-Sachen
Plus Shield-Spec
Okay, was speckt man denn als Warn?
Das muss ich mir jetzt tatsächlich machen
Das ist ja noch krasser, als ich mir das gedacht habe
Also, du brauchst auf jeden Fall Cure-Group-Disease
Und du willst 42 Schild
Und du willst...
Tja, so viel wie geht hier rein
Da geht jetzt ja wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so viel, oder?
Kann ja mal so übel
Und dann hast du noch deine ganzen Utilities-Sachen
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie eine wirkliche gute Warn-Spec aussieht
Aber irgendwas in der Richtung wahrscheinlich nicht exakt
Ja, du machst alles
Du machst alles außer Damage
Und es reicht sogar noch für den Schwert-Town
Nice
Ne, Leute töten kann er nicht gut
Also, der Hüter
Okay, wenn ich mir das so angucke
Ich bin ja auch über 9,15
Also, das ist mega
Alter, die Klasse ist so heftig
Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht
Das ist wirklich mega
Kannst du gerne ein bisschen Parry reinhauen
Das geht sogar auch von Null auf
Wahnsinn
Also, ganz ehrlich
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das eine gute Hüter-Spec ist
Aber sowas in der Richtung wird man wahrscheinlich specken
Du bist ein besserer Heiler als der Main-Heiler
Du hast dein ganzes Bubble-Utility-Zeug
Du hast einen Nahkampf-9-Sekunden-Anytime-Stun
Gibt's irgendwas, was die nicht können?
I don't want to play a 1
I'm just surprised how...
How great the Warden is on Eden
Because they can do everything
Except damage
I have no clue about Warden
I just looked up what you might
could have specced
It looks really OP
I knew it was OP
But after I looked it up
in the character planner
I realized it is fucking OP
You are a better Healer
than the Druid
You're only missing Spread Heal
But you have Group-Disease-Cure
And you can spec higher than Druid in healing
You're a better Healer than the Druid
You have all the Utilities from Plate-Turn and whatnot
You got the Anytime-9-Seconds
Oh, you're missing Instant Heals, right, yeah
You got the 9-Seconds-Anytime-Millie-Stun
You're basically a 95% Main-Healer
A really good Tank
for stunning and removing enemy-Millies from the fight
You can do everything
Except...
You can even Instant-Res
And you can do everything
Only damage
You're not great in doing damage
But... yeah...
I wasn't prepared to see it's that OP
And now that I've seen this
I realize why so many Hipps
playing Tank Group
So you can go 5 Supports
2 Blademasters
And plus X
It's really nice
But I don't play on Hipp
I've leveled Bard
Not even to 50
I'm playing mainly Mid and a bit of Alp
So, also, meine E-Pick ist fertig
Ich muss nach Hagal, okay, gut
Yeah, 35 Shield-Max
Why not Anytime-Slam?
You get 35 Back-Stun
Is it... enough?
Ja, Solo kann ich mir vorstellen, geht's?
It's side?
Ja, Side-Stun
So...
Ja, but I mean...
Who should beat...
What you should play to beat a 5-Support-Hipp-Group?
Maybe you can...
Maybe you should go...
Two Scales in Mid?
For Inter?
I don't know
It looks really, really solid
And quite hard to beat on paper
Okay, meine...
Wo muss ich jetzt hin?
Oh, nee, jetzt kommt der Skull-Step
Da hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
Ich frag mal im Guilden-Chat
Three Wizards Zorg?
So, with Three Wizards Zorg, it's...
Just kill the first target before the fight starts
On live?
I played...
The most fights I did was on...
The most 8-Man-Fights I did on live was Stonehenge-Alp
And Classic-Server Mid
And on Mid...
We played...
Maybe it's outdated now
And it can't be played on Eden because there is no Warlock
We played with...
Two Healers, Shaman, Warlock, Bone Dancer, Warrior...
And I think...
Savage or Berserker
That's the last slot
And we killed everything
And I think I'm gonna miss this setup
But...
I don't know if this is...
Will be possible in the future
Because no Warlocks and...
Now people have gotten better in the game
So, maybe it...
Is more kiting and...
Wouldn't work this well
By the way, warum flieg ich eigentlich nicht?
Hi, es ist Joey, danke schon für den Sub
Ja, Berserker isn't really that popular anymore
Noticed this
But I never was a great...
I never liked to play...
Pure DPS, Melee...
Characters
Paper Dark is nice
It was eSport before...
The term eSport existed
Okay, Leute
Wir machen jetzt den gleichen Step
Den wir eben schon gemacht haben
In Moderna mit dem...
Ding auf dem Berg, wo wir die ganze Zeit diseased und...
Vergiftet und geseucht und alles wurden...
Okay
Ich brauch irgendwie Verstärkung für Skull Step
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob irgendjemand...
Ah, ah
Kannst du mir kurz bei Skull helfen?
Ich frag mal kurz im Discord, ob irgendjemand kann
Anyone could help my AM with Skull and BuzzRam?
Kurz im Discord fragen
Wo renn ich denn hier eigentlich lang, Mann?
Okay, Leute
Jetzt hab ich euch ja erzählt
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn
Was für Klassen ich empfehlen würde zum Starten
Hat das irgendjemand was gefragt?
Oder hab ich einfach nur...
Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg gemacht, oder?
Ein paar Leute haben ja geschrieben
Sie wollen sich runterladen und mal ausprobieren
Wie gesagt, ich kann es euch nur empfehlen
Mal runterzuladen und auszuprobieren
Auf der...
Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg
Ja, gut, ist halt so
Aber ihr müsst ein bisschen, gerade am Anfang
Echt dem Spiel ein bisschen Zeit geben, weil...
Es ist halt nicht alles so offensichtlich...
Und tutorialgespickt
Wie man das von neueren Games erwartet ist
Soll ich mal probieren, ob ich das alleine hinkriege, den Step?
Ich glaube, das funzt nicht
Ich frag mal im Discord
Also ich hab jetzt schon ein paar Leute angeschrieben
Ob die mir helfen können mit dem Step, aber...
Ich frag mal
Im LFG
Anyone Skull Step?
FTP up
Ich ess mal kurz was
Während ich warte, dass ich vielleicht noch 1, 2...
Leute finde
Also ein Heiler wäre halt optimal
Im Heiler-Duo kannst du das machen
Ja, it's really hard for new players
Because there is so many magic going on
For example
If you are a noob
You don't realize
That you need dexterity
For cast speed and not quickness
I mean, why it's called quickness?
Because it's only for melee quickness
I don't know
The European...
Hoster for Dark didn't know this in 2001
A friend of mine has played Friar
And the Hoster of the European Dark said
You should spec
I think Piety and...
Const Strength or something like that
So no quickness and no dexterity
Dark hat jede Menge Magic im Hintergrund
Hab ich euch ja heute auch schon erzählt
Ah, okay
Der eine kocht gerade
Ey, ich kann den Step nicht alleine machen als Runi
Das sagt man
Ich mein, ich hab ein TP auf
Ich kanns ja mal probieren
Mal gucken, wie weit ich komme
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass es funktioniert
Wir gucken mal, wie weit wir kommen
Aber ich glaube, ich bin dead
Even the tutorial isn't really a tutorial
It's just a...
Boost your character to level 10
What do you learn in the tutorial?
How to...
Click quest NPCs that you don't need
The rest of the game?
And...
You learn how to buy a boat ticket
So you learn nothing about the game
I think a lot of new players could really enjoy the game
But it's...
Oh shit
It's just so different
From more modern games
Okay, I'm dead
I love fucking shit
ại
Wo hab ich denn mein, mein TP?
Moment, ich hab Quick Cast noch da
Hab ich nicht ha-
Hab ich nicht Quick Casted?
Bin ich total dumm?
Okay, das wird alleine nix
Als Runi dieser Step
Gucken wir mal
Wir machen kleine, kleine Schritte
Kleine Schritte
Ich muss auch unbedingt nebenbei was futtern
So, hier das Portal
ist gut
Was machen wir jetzt noch?
Da machen wir jetzt noch eins hin.
Also, ich bekomme gleich Hilfe
von einem Skalde.
Der ist gerade noch am Essen kochen.
Der kann mir danach helfen.
Ähm, ansonsten...
Guck mal,
im Discord
ist auch keiner da. Ich glaube, die sind alle noch
auf der Arbeit. Okay, okay,
das sieht doch schon besser aus hier.
Das Problem ist, die Viecher haben halt einen super, super
krassen Dot, was mich killt.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, da machen
welche Skal. Da machen welche Skal.
Da machen welche.
Lass mich durch, Leute, Leute, Leute.
Okay, okay.
Pass auf, ich mache jetzt Assi. Assi.
Richtig Assi mache ich jetzt.
Ja, please, please,
please. Ja!
Jawohl!
Jetzt kann ich sterben, jetzt ist es egal.
Leeched!
Jawohl!
Nice!
Einfach die Quest mal abgeleached
von dem Typ.
Wobei, ich glaube, der hat es auch gekriegt.
Ich glaube, der hat es auch gekriegt.
Oder ich hatte einfach nur mega Glück,
dass er reingerannt ist, alle Mobs auf sich
gezogen hat und ich konnte reinrennen
und grabben.
Sehr nice.
Der ist eh gestorben. Also, dass der gestorben ist,
kann ich nichts für. Der ist reingerannt und wurde halt
gekillt von den Mobs.
Du bist reiner PvPler. Nö, nicht wirklich.
Mir macht alles Bock an der Ork.
Ich hab sogar...
Man glaubt es kaum.
Ich hab sogar Bock dran,
ähm, mich ab und zu mal auf so einen TG-Rate zu sticken.
Und da durch zu rennen.
Wo ich auch mal richtig Bock drauf hätte, ist, ähm, hier.
Mit einer ordentlichen Group zu machen.
Ihr weiß, was ihr macht.
Ich mein, Chars dafür hab ich.
Können den BD nehmen, wir können den Runemaster nehmen,
wir können den Skalde nehmen, wobei Skalde braucht in Sobe keiner.
Oder den Shammy nehmen.
Shammy ist wahrscheinlich der beste.
Oder den Heiler nehmen.
Wobei, der ist 49, das wird nix.
Das würd ich gerne mal mit ein paar gescheiten Leuten machen.
Weil, mit allen, den ich das bisher gemacht hab,
war echt übelst nervig.
Okay.
Wasrem killen.
Also, ich spiel meistens mit ein paar Leuten zusammen.
Wir sind auch wild gemischt.
Franzosen bei, Italiener dabei,
Polen dabei.
Zum Glück alle EU.
Also, das heißt, Zeitzonen-mäßig passt das.
Wobei wir eigentlich,
so gut wie nie, 8 Mann spielen.
Da bin ich auch, ehrlich gesagt, zu noob für, mittlerweile.
Ist mir auch zu stressig geworden.
Wir rennen meistens Smallman rum,
oder eben Maximumes Leeching in der BG.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich hier noch einen Runemaster gemacht hab.
Kann ich nämlich einfach füllen.
Entweder Shammy, Skalde oder Runemaster.
Da hast du immer was dabei, was für die BG gebraucht wird.
Da wird einfach reine Range-DPS für BG gespielt.
Wir hatten an einem Tag 18k die Stunde, Alter.
Da wurde einfach nur AE geswappt den ganzen Tag, Mann.
So.
Mulan.
Der Grund, warum ich ungern
8 Mann spiele, ist,
du kannst das vielleicht vormittags spielen,
wenn es hauptsächlich,
sagen wir mal, random Gruppen
mit
Kerlen, die sich kennen,
sind.
Aber es ist ein Riesenunterschied, das habe ich früher auch gemerkt.
Es ist ein Riesenunterschied, ob du mit einer BG spielst oder nicht.
Ob du mit einer guten
random Gruppe
8 vs 8 spielst
oder 8-Man, wie man das heutzutage nennt, spielst.
Selbst wenn das gute Spieler sind.
Versus
du spielst
mit den 8 gleichen Leuten jeden Tag
oder vielleicht mal 1-1
Phil irgendwie
mit
damals TeamSpeak, heute Discord.
Du kommst einfach nicht mit.
Selbst wenn du mit guten Leuten
eine Gruppe baust, selbst mit Discord
und allem,
man unterschätzt das
schnell, wie
unglaublich eingespielt
man sein kann in einer 8er Gruppe.
Also ich kann mich noch daran erinnern,
gerade
auf dem Classic Server in mid,
ich konnte im Endeffekt schon
die Waffe wegstecken,
weil ich
wusste, dass mein
Heiler hinter mir gerade
irgendeinen Sleep castet.
Ohne, dass ich den gesehen hab.
Also ich hab kein Game
bisher so eine Synergie
zwischen Spielern erlebt,
wie dort.
Was ist jetzt Wasram
Enjoyers?
Ich frag mal den Typ, ob der Bock hat,
Wasram zu machen.
Machen wir uns mal Speed.
Ah, guck mal, der invited mich sogar.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Warte mal dahin.
Man muss aber dazu sagen,
so cool,
so cool das RVR war,
in der 8er Gruppe,
die hatten echt nervige Leute dabei.
Und
da hatte ich irgendwann auch
keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Also die hatten dann Leute dabei, die sich wirklich über
jeden Scheiß aufgeregt haben.
Ich meine, als Galde konnte mir das egal sein,
da warst du ja nichts schuld.
Gewinnst 99,9%
der Fights,
verlierst mal gegen irgendwie 2 Gruppen oder so
und schon sind die Leute gleich schlecht drauf gewesen.
Das war sehr weird irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Aber das war halt auch der Zeit,
wo alle 24-7 gespielt haben.
You already there?
Wo ist der Typ denn?
Oh, okay.
Alter, es ist keiner von den Leuten,
die helfen könnten mit dem Step.
Okay, ich habe einen Krieger,
der kommt.
Ah, die haben alle keinen Bock.
Ist unser,
ist der Krieger eigentlich schon da?
Ey,
der läuft da gerade hin.
Ja, ich war jetzt ein bisschen abgelenkt.
Ich warte jetzt nur drauf, bis
Krieger einloggt, ich den Heiler am Start habe
und der
Hunter am Spot ist.
Ich hoffe,
ich hoffe, dass der Bossmob überhaupt ab ist.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt hier die Leute kehre
und am Ende ist der Boss gar nicht da, Alter.
Das wäre natürlich
doof.
Ich bilde mir ein,
die haben den Respawn ein bisschen runter gedreht in Season 2.
Oh ne, der Hunter stirbt.
Please, nicht sterben.
Ich verlasse mich darauf, dass du da hin rennst.
Ich bilde mir ein, die haben den Respawn runter gemacht
in Season 2. Ich habe irgendwas im Hinterkopf.
Ah, ich habe einen Heiler.
Okay.
Ja, Mann.
Wo ist das TP hier?
Okay.
Ich meine, ein bisschen,
ein bisschen,
ein bisschen heilen kann ich ja auch mit dem Rooney.
Ich meine, ich kann nicht wirklich heilen,
aber,
ich kann dem.
Der ist doch komplett falsch hier.
Wo rennt denn der rum?
Ist Wasrim nicht irgendwo da unten?
Wo ist denn der komische Dinosaurier jetzt, Mann?
Ich mach mal kurz den TP.
So, Leute sind organisiert.
Ich fürchte, das Viech ist nicht da.
Wenn das Viech nicht da ist, Mann,
wenn ich jetzt umsonst die Leute organisiert habe,
dann drehe ich durch, ey.
Der ist doch hier immer irgendwo, oder?
Da ist er doch.
Ich sag doch, der steht falsch, der Typ.
War mir doch klar, dass das die falsche Pose ist,
da unten, Mann.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind.
Die Leute spielen 20 Jahre Dark und finden die Mobs nicht.
Ich hab doch einen Tank.
Ich hab nen,
ich hab nen Savage.
Einen R7 Savage oder R8 Savage.
Reicht doch, easy.
Eden, Eden.
Pass mal auf, der Savage, der rockt.
Alter, Alter.
Hahaha.
Der Heiler ist nicht mal da.
Hab ich nicht eben noch nen,
hab ich eben noch nen Tinder gesetzt hier?
Oh, hier, Tinder.
Der macht das.
Ich hab das Ding sogar schon,
ich hab das Ding sogar schon, ähm,
mit Skalde getankt, das ist kein Ding.
Wenn er ordentliches Equip hast und so,
ist es nicht so wild.
So, ich muss eigentlich gar nichts machen.
Gucken, ob ich noch bei Wasser im bin.
Ja, das liegt, das ist,
das ist das, was ich vorhin gemeint habe.
Der Unterschied zwischen
einem 40er mit ordentlichem Equipment,
ordentlichen passiven Fähigkeiten und alles,
der Char ist dann einfach 50% besser als
ein 49,5er mit Levelgear.
Okay, ich muss kurz ranken.
Ey, auf Level,
der two-shottet
Leute in Levelgear.
Ein Bersih in Levelgear ist two-shot.
Ein Treffer 70%.
Eine große Herausforderung ist sie nicht,
ich mein, das ist Dark PvE.
Okay, wir haben's geschafft.
Hahaha.
Wie gesagt,
ich hab da sogar schon mit einem Skalde
getankt, das Ding.
Was bekommt man als Belohnung, wenn man den besiegt?
Wirst du jetzt gleich sehen.
Richtig nice Rüstung
bekommt man dafür.
Weil es der letzte Step
von der Epic-Rüstung
Quests Chain ist.
Die dauert ungefähr so
naja,
eine Stunde, wenn man sie mit Speed
und gescheiten Leuten macht.
Ja.
Und jetzt kann ich
endlich meine gescheite Runi-Rüstung abholen.
Damals lohnt es sich, das Ding zu zerlegen
für Platz, macht's immer noch.
Es lohnt sich hier enorm,
deswegen hab ich auch ein Battle...
Jetzt verrate ich einen
High-IQ-Dark-Free-Shot-Trick.
Es lohnt sich richtig,
einen Battleground-Character zu haben
und dort, also einen Chain
Battle, also einen
Battleground-Character, der
Kettenrüstung anhat.
Dann geht man in den Battleground,
und
farmt die
Captains für die Captains-Quest ab.
Die droppen richtig krass
Zeug. Und dann salvagest du.
Und da kriegst du so
krass Kohle. Da machst du innerhalb
von ein paar Stunden...
Ach, innerhalb von...
innerhalb von einer Stunde machst du 5 Platin.
Das ist super heftig.
Ich geh davon aus, das nerven die auch noch.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns das mal an.
Pass mal auf. So, ich seh Noob aus.
Ich seh Noob aus.
Und jetzt seh ich gleich
hoffentlich besser aus.
Kopf mit...
Nicer Hut am Start. Okay.
Okay. Zack. Schon mal
viel besser. Zack.
Zack. Zack.
Zack.
Das sieht doch schon mal...
Oh, meine ganze Rüstung...
Hoffentlich hab ich alles bekommen.
Ja.
Ja. Oh, hat gerade so
ins Inf gepasst, alter.
Okay, Hero of Molvik kann weg.
Kann weg.
Jo. Ähm, Hero of Molvik
kann weg. Im Prinzip
ist es nur der Hut, den ich
nicht anhab.
Mh...
Lass mal kurz die Stats gucken.
Ja, das ist doch schon besser.
Das ist doch schon besser.
Das hier mit den Buffs aus.
312!
Okay, damit kriegt man jetzt zumindest
halbwegs was hin.
Was ist besser? Der Epic-Hut?
Das Epic-Circlet?
Oder...
Hä? Achso, ja.
Mit Casting Speed plus 2.
Und das hier ist, der Hut hat
Casting Speed plus 2
und Magic Damage
und Dex Cap.
Okay, der Hut ist auf jeden Fall besser.
Jetzt brauch ich nur ein ordentliches Template
für den Runi. Ich muss sagen,
ehrlich gesagt, Stats...
Naja...
Constitution ist nicht so geil.
Ich hatte schon deutlich
schlechteres Leveling-Gear an als das hier.
Aber es fehlt
natürlich immer noch Casting Speed,
Dex Cap
und Resi Pierce und alles. Also ein ordentliches
Runi-Template muss an den Start.
Ist das ein Boomer-Game?
Ja!
Kann man so sagen!
Ich renne übrigens gerade zu allem Sinnlosem.
Kann man so sagen, dass das ein Boomer-Game ist.
Ja.
Würde ich mitgehen.
Oh fuck.
Ich hab von...
Ich hab den Stängel mitgegessen gerade.
Gut.
Ganz essenziell, Leute.
Ich muss
etwas
besser aussehen, als ich jetzt schon.
So.
Bin ich verwirrt.
Genau.
Ich muss etwas gescheitem aussehen.
Das heißt, ich logge jetzt den Heiler ein
und ziehe ein Skin
von meinem Heiler-Umhang
und gebe dem Runi,
dass der Runi
so aussieht. So aussieht, als ist er Pro.
Er hat zwar kein gutes Template, aber er muss so
aussehen, als hätte er ein gutes Template.
Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt
zum
Skin oder
Pattern Merchant oder wie das
Ding heißt.
Und fertigen uns mal
Skin vom Umhang an.
Weil dann sehe ich zumindest schon nach
Thor und Artefakten und richtig Pro aus.
Ja.
Ich mag das nicht, mit Level 50 so komplett nubig
auszuschauen.
23 Jahre und Best Game Ever.
So sieht's aus.
Frag mal Polemo, was Best Game Ever ist.
Der wird dir schon erzählen, dass es Starhawk ist.
Best Game
Ever.
Wo ist der Pattern-Dude?
Da ist der Pattern-Dude.
Pattern.
Und jetzt
gehen wir gleich in den Vault.
Schmeißen das Pattern da rein.
Und dann sieht mein Runi wenigstens
so semi-professionell aus.
Gothic Online.
Gothic Online ist ja auch nur ein Mod.
Das ist ein richtig echtes MMO.
Habe ich irgendwo
Platz hier noch drinne?
Nee, geil. Was habe ich da für ein Shit überhaupt
noch drinne liegen? Lull.
Ein 41er Utility Ring.
Stärke, ja. Beste, den wir nicht für super viel Geld
verkaufen können.
Der kann weg.
Und jetzt. Oh nein!
Game crashed. Ich habe vergessen Reshade auszuschalten.
Moment, habe ich den?
Sekunde, habe ich den
Oman reingeschmissen jetzt in den
Vault? Oder habe ich den
Skin in den Vault reingeschmissen?
Ich kack noob.
Vielleicht Stamp, ja.
Ich hoffe,
ich hoffe, ich habe den Skin reingeschmissen.
Jetzt was Futter nebenbei.
Das Pattern.
So, ähm,
wo ist mein Umhang?
Level 25 grauer Umhang.
Bestes Equip hier.
Wo habe ich denn meinen Epic Umhang?
Hier, Rune Manzer
Cloak.
Casting Speed. Ja, genau.
Komm her.
Okay.
Machen wir 101 Decks.
Jetzt geht es ab.
Bisschen wenig Con, aber scheiß drauf.
Äh,
Pattern. Ja, ja, Accept.
Jetzt, jetzt sehe ich
pro aus hier. Guckt euch das mal an.
Massive, highly, highly
professional Rune Master.
So, jetzt brauchen wir noch ein paar andere Dinger.
Wie voll ist denn eigentlich
mein Vault?
Nix.
Alter, das kommt da rein.
Das da kommt da auf jeden Fall nicht rein.
Was ist denn das da? Kann ich irgendwie
Aquarian Spirit Hits? Brauche ich nicht.
Rove Molvik brauche ich auch nicht.
Ich muss gerade ein bisschen aufräumen.
Adept Belt.
Den heben wir auf.
Schnitz. Brauche ich auch nicht.
Ich brauche einen Mana Trank, brauche ich noch.
Das können wir alles löschen.
Äh, das heben wir auch.
Das heben wir auch auf.
Das ganze Molvik Zeug,
das kann ich löschen. Das braucht kein Mensch.
Das kann man eh nicht traden.
Den Belt kann man
verkaufen.
Hero of Molvik brauchen wir nicht.
Ich brauche noch einen Stab, habe ich auch.
Ich brauche noch ein bisschen was mit Con.
Falls ich was, falls ich was finde.
Gibt es anscheinend
nicht. Das heben wir auch auf.
Und die Pages
stecken wir in den Vault.
Gibt es hier noch BGs?
Jede Menge BGs.
Ah ne, du meinst Battlecrowns.
Auf Eden haben die das sogar richtig cool gemacht mit Battlecrowns.
Es gibt auch XP off.
Mein Heiler ist XP off.
Und er bleibt für immer 49,5.
Das ist nämlich mein Money,
Money Maker Katal Valley Charme.
So, ich muss jetzt nur kurz gucken,
dass ich kein Mist verkaufe.
Übrigens auch ein cooles Feature.
Man kann Items recoveren,
wenn man aus versehen Sachen verkauft hat.
Ging im Original auch nicht.
Mega, mega POC, was die Leute
von Eden hier fabriziert haben.
Äh,
Last, Last Name
Epiga, wenn schon dann richtig.
Ich muss mal die Sachen sellen.
Okay, das brauche ich auf jeden Fall nicht.
Kann ich nicht sellen?
Sell?
Moment.
Nimmt keine Items.
Dann muss ich zu der hier.
Sell, sell,
sell, sell.
Ah, Tinderbox können wir sell, sell, sell, sell.
Sell, sell,
sell, sell,
sellen, sellen, sellen, sellen.
Hero of Moldvik
kann man nicht sellen.
Sellen, sellen, sellen.
Und sonst haben wir nichts mehr.
Ich brauche Mana Tränke und ansonsten
ist eigentlich alles soweit.
Gut.
Zwei Sachen jetzt.
Ich zeige euch was.
Können wir was lernen jetzt.
Five Head Time.
Daok Tricks.
Ich sollte das vielleicht jetzt nicht zeigen.
Dann machen das noch mehr Leute.
Die Items sind weg.
Ist aber nicht schlimm.
Ich habe zumindest für einen Char noch mehr als genug Items.
Aber ich gucke jetzt mal.
Also, man kann sich selbst buffen.
Ihr seht, ich habe jetzt 312 Decks.
Das ist nicht richtig krass.
Mit richtigen Buffs
geht das auf jeden Fall besser.
Aber.
Buff Bonus wirkt
auf Buff Tränke.
Das heißt.
Ihr könnt in den Market Explorer gehen.
Geht hier auf Any.
Sucht nach Buff Bonus.
Und dann sucht ihr euch
gute Items.
Die ihr temporär rein swappen könnt.
Wenn ihr buffen wollt.
Das ist egal. Das kann ein Umhang sein.
Das ist nix.
Wobei, den habe ich doch sogar schon an.
Es ist Buff Bonus.
Plus 6 ist auch nicht so geil.
Buff Bonus.
Plus 7 ist auch nicht so geil.
Buff Bonus 6
auch nicht so toll.
Das ist schon besser.
Schon besser.
Aber es sollte schon ein bisschen mehr sein.
Was ist denn gerade die Sache im Chat?
Habe ich irgendwas nicht aufgepasst?
Dicke Elfmannschau oder so.
Ne, das klappt nicht mehr.
Du machst richtig gut.
Richtig gut Damage mit SB.
Ich würde aber sagen.
SB.
Ich bin kein großer Schleicher Spieler.
Aber ich würde sagen SB.
Von den Schleichern der schlechteste.
Aber es nimmt sich nicht viel.
Ich würde sagen Nightshade ist der beste.
Zaugt jetzt nicht so wirklich.
7 Buff.
Schild kann ich nicht sehen.
Ah.
Yes.
Das ist gut.
14% Buff.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Hier auf Seite 2.
Der Ring.
9.
Ich brauche noch mal mindestens 11.
Wenn ich noch mal 11 bekomme.
Das ist mir zu teuer.
Wenn ich mindestens 11 bekomme.
Den kaufe ich doch glatt für einen P.
Hallo?
What the fuck?
Was jetzt?
Es bugged wieder rum.
Wobei wir gucken mal weiter.
Ein P ist ein P.
5 ist nicht so geil.
7 ist nicht so geil.
9.
11 bräuchte ich.
7.
9.
12.
Alles gut.
Jawoll. Bye.
Alter. Was ist mit dem fucking Markt?
Denks Explorer los.
What the fuck?
Der will nicht. Der ist broken.
Reset. Buff Bonus.
3.
Okay.
Enhancing Supreme Ring.
Plus 12 Buff.
Okay. Und jetzt passt mal auf.
Ich hab jetzt 312 Decks.
Jetzt zieh ich meine Buff Items an.
Und buff mich nochmal.
Dann switch ich wieder zurück.
Und jetzt hab ich gerade 35 Decks.
Exzellent.
So.
Und wenn man jetzt ganz abgedrehter Dude ist.
Dann baut man sich irgendwas mit Auto-Hotkey.
Was das switcht.
Es gibt bestimmt Leute die schon irgendwelche Magic Auto-Hotkey Geschiss gebaut haben.
Zum Item switchen fürs Buffen.
So.
Und jetzt vergleichen wir nochmal.
Passt mal auf.
Mein Cast Speed jetzt.
Mit 50 und gescheiten Items.
Also mit 50 realistisch hab ich eh nen Decks Charge.
Ach stimmt. Hab ich in Mysterium Isle noch den Mana Save Ding.
Okay.
Und jetzt kann ich mit 50 einen Damage auf so ne 0815 fliegen.
Die ich da vorher versucht hab zu bashen.
Das dürfte ne ganze Ecke besser sein.
Vor allem der Cast Speed dürfte deutlich besser sein.
Also und Farben brauche ich noch.
Ohne Farben kann ich ja nicht aus dem Haus.
Sieht ja aus wie frisch 50 gelafelt.
So Mücke du musst dran glauben.
Alter der Cast Speed ist so viel besser man.
Und das Ding ist...
909 Damage. Okay das Ding platzt einfach.
Und das Ding ist... 909 Damage. Okay das Ding platzt einfach.
Ja das macht echt nen Unterschied.
50 gescheites Equipment, gescheite Buffs.
Ich mein die Buffs, das geht noch mehr.
Decks ne mit Charmy Buffs und sowas.
Aber...
Das ist jetzt schon ganz okay.
Das ist wirklich okay.
Es ist capped Decks.
Ich bekomme maximal glaube ich noch...
Ich kann maximal noch 40 Decks mehr bekommen.
Weil ich glaub 100, 150, 150 Decks.
Weil ich glaub 100, 150, 150, 150 Decks.
Was ist Decks Cap 153?
Nicht Decks Cap, Speck Buff Cap.
Weiß ich gar nicht aus dem Kopf.
Alter wie die platzen nur noch.
155 ne.
Wie die platzen jetzt die Viecher man.
Perch is overrated, outdated.
Moment was hab ich denn jetzt eigentlich schon gekauft?
Nix großartig ne.
Bisschen Decks weil das Preis leistungsmäßig gut ist.
Powerball Preis leistungsmäßig gut ist.
Longwind und TBF.
Ja als nächstes mal zumindest...
Zum minimalsten Perch.
Ey die Dinger platzen einfach nur noch jetzt.
Die platzen einfach.
Ich glaube ich kann die jetzt sogar...
Ich könnte die Viecher sogar komplett ohne Bowls killen.
Okay das war jetzt nur ein Blauer.
Aber die platzen jetzt einfach.
Guckt es euch an. Bam.
Einfach dead kill.
Wir sind noch nicht in hip.
Wir sind nicht in hip.
Ich mein Huni mit Base-Science dann immer her damit.
Ich würd es sofort nehmen.
Ey Moment was?
Gap nur her damit.
Warum hab ich eigentlich kein Speedlaufen?
Warum bin ich so dumm?
Guck mal wie schnell er jetzt castet.
Macht eigentlich irgendjemand DF zur Abwechslung?
Nö keiner Bock DF zu machen.
Okay.
Farben kaufen.
Und...
Mana Pots kaufen.
Die hab ich noch vergessen.
Die ganzen Hips haben Base-Science dann.
Ench hat Base-Science dann.
Manta ist richtig krass mit Base-Science dann.
Mit dem 209er Nuke.
Mana Tränke kaufen.
Power.
Strong Trout of Power.
Jawoll komm her.
90. Jawoll.
Zack.
So ich stack gerne meine Usables von unten.
Und...
Manche Sachen von oben.
Ich weiß nicht nach welchem System ich das mach.
Aber so wie ich es irgendwie am besten finde.
Okay.
Jetzt porten wir nach...
Jetzt porten wir Agir.
Und jetzt brauch ich noch ein paar Farben.
Ja Manta sind richtig krass.
Früher war die Klasse ja so...
Semi nice.
Haben auch nicht viele gespielt.
Aber nachdem die ein paar Buffs gekriegt hat ist die richtig gut.
Okay also.
Farben.
Ich brauch...
Kappa Pride Färbung.
Jawoll.
Violet Violet.
Black.
Alle meine Chars sehen so aus.
Deswegen werden die hier auch so gefärbt.
Moment.
Ich hab mich verklickt.
Jawoll.
So der Hut.
Chat.
Frage an euch.
Gleiche wie beim Heiler.
Cappy?
Oder Hut?
Und wenn Hut, welche Farbe?
Schwarz oder Violet?
Komplett random Farbe.
Grün.
Ein Redhead.
Okay Chat.
Ich seh man kann euch ja nicht fragen.
Guck mal wie das Violet aussieht.
Oh.
Okay.
Eventuell.
Mache ich auch Hütchen auf.
Und noch unschlüssig.
Hütchen oder Hut.
Zumindest muss ich erstmal Gilden Logo auf den Umhang drauf machen.
Und oh Waffenfarbe.
Waffenfarbe darf ja auch nicht vergessen werden.
Da machen wir erstmal Gilden Logo drauf.
Your time.
Ups.
Ich versuche immer noch die ganze Zeit mein Abendessen zu essen.
Seit einer Stunde.
Wo ist der Gilden Logo Typ? Na.
Gut.
Yes.
Excellent.
Das sieht doch richtig gut passend aus.
Müsst ihr zugeben.
Passt von der Farbe.
Das sieht wirklich ganz gut aus.
Okay und jetzt.
Eine Waffenfarbe noch als letztes.
Wie heißt das?
Wenn ich das richtig schreiben könnte.
Oh.
Sluster.
Grey.
Pride Rosé Weapon Luster.
Bin mir nicht sicher ob
Pride Rosé das richtige ist.
Ähm Crimson.
Crimson.
Pride Rosé Weapon Luster. Okay.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Okay.
Jetzt sieht das auch ganz gut aus.
Bisschen. Bisschen.
Kappa Pride Farbe.
Nice. Okay. Gut.
So lassen wir das.
Jetzt macht der Huni ein bisschen was her.
Jetzt sieht er nicht total Level 50.
Das ist doch Shit Ausrüstung.
Wenn du dir das hier anguckst von den Dinger und so.
Aber ich mein.
Ich hab halt auch noch null Sachen an äh.
Templates.
Geschweige denn SC Sachen hier auf dem Huni.
Aber.
Insgesamt
für bisschen BG Gezerge reicht das
auf jeden Fall.
Ja. In Rot würde meine Mütze so aussehen.
So Leute.
Ich bin jetzt 6,5 Stunden on.
Jetzt noch eine Sache nach. Gut.
Ähm.
Ich geh jetzt ins.
Ich mach jetzt noch eine BG RVR.
Kann ich euch leider nicht mitnehmen gerade.
Weil ich ohne Delay streame.
Und das ist
für die 100 anderen Leute unfair.
Wenn direkt gesehen wird wo wir hingehen.
Ähm. Name.
Ich weiß gar nicht wo die Nameplate Standards sind.
Ja.
1200.
Achso. Ne sieht man gar nicht was man hat oder?
Ne 1200 ist die Falltrend. Ich hab nix umgestellt.
Ich hab nix umgestellt.
Ich hab nix was am Start für.
Für BG.
Nicht wirklich.
Gut. Chat Game.
Das wars für heute.
Schön das so viele dabei waren.
Erstaunlich viele wieder.
Für so ein olles Kack Game.
Best Game ever.
Da bin ich überzeugt von.
Hab ich glaube ich heute oft genug erzählt.
Warum ich denke das beste Game ever ist.
Falls irgendjemand Bock hat auszuprobieren.
Wie gesagt. Da auch eben.
Es ist super easy darauf zu spielen.
Ihr müsst im Endeffekt nur den offiziellen Client runterladen.
Und dann
den Eden Launcher starten.
Und fertig. Das wars.
Das heißt.
Ich geh jetzt ne Runde BG RvR spielen.
Da könnt ihr das nächste mal mit.
Wenn ihr wollt.
Da kann ich das nächste mal streamen.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat.
99200 Patch.
Dafür ist der Patcher ja da.
Und wenn es euch gefallen hat.
Nehmt mir Bescheid.
Dann kann ich demnächst auch nochmal ne Runde.
Dann machen wir auch mal ne Runde BG RvR zusammen.
Aber dann muss ich neu starten.
Mit.
Delay.
Sonst wird das nix.
Alles klar.
Sehr schön das so viele dabei gewesen sind.
Wir gucken jetzt mal ganz kurz hier noch.
Wer streamt denn noch Dark?
Und dann hosten wir den einfach mal.
Dark streamt so untereinander.
Okay.
Es streamt genau.
Seh ich das richtig?
Einer.
Neben mir noch Dark.
Eben Dark Skull running around.
Zwei Zuschauer.
Pandamans Häus ist am Start.
Pandamans Häus ist abgewünscht.
Pilz.
Okay. Okay. Seriously.
Ein Hip Pilzzerger.
Den host ich net.
Und hier haben wir nen.
Ollen Dings.
Da Festung rumläuft.
In dem.
Trelle Trelleburg.
Weiß ich net ob das so spannend ist.
Da gibt es einen schlicht und ergreifend keinen.
Ich bin der einzige von drei Leuten die da auch gestreamt haben.
Ja das ist normal.
Michael verwirft Spillian.
Das erwarte ich auch net.
Das ist ein olles.
MMO.
Was wer es nicht gespielt hat.
Wahrscheinlich die wenigsten Reihen finden.
Außer man steht auf so alte Sachen.
Ob online oder offline.
Wir sehen uns Leute.
Bis dann machts gut.